ein chat recht früh eigentlich nicht eigentlich ist es wenn man mal durch
gezählt hatte von gestern ist 9 uhr 15 stimmte updates ja tatsächlich das
müssen wir noch machen bei der rechte zeit moment so gerade dabei sind machen
wir updates aber obwohl es eine stunde länger war heute nacht eine stunde
länger oder ja war eine stunde länger die haben um 3 uhr die zeit
zurückgestellt auf zwei uhr also was eine stunde länger will ich mich
trotzdem nicht so krass wach oder so dass ich wie es bei euch aussieht so
lange ich ja keine ahnung arch by the way ja das haben wir schon gelesen es
kam übrigens ein paar tagen raus ja gar nicht so viele updates hält sich ja in
grenzen guck mal nur 16 pakete was sind da los
und wir haben ja schon ein paar tage lang gelesen
schon ein paar tage nicht mehr geupdatet es gibt eine neue swell cli okay warum
braucht man eine neue kommt man nicht die alte nicht abtaken soll mir recht
sein alles was das setup da irgendwie
easier macht ist mir ist mir recht ja macht man jetzt so komische geräusche
das kabel ist verknotet er ist fack und es wackelt und schlägt beim wackeln
gegen das gehäuse vom anderen headset das
macht komische geräusche das heißt habt ihr gar nicht gehört guck mal ob es hier
irgendwelche updates gibt übrigens wisst ihr was mega nice ist erste mal bevor
ich euch das zeigen was mega nice ist ich entknoten mal kurz mein headset
aber man muss ja mit muten zu sonst fällt euch gleich das ohr aus da geht
schnell so schon wieder am start guck mal hier ob's jetbrains neue sachen zum
updaten gibt ja also naja genau hier gab's update und zwar wir hatten gerade auf dem
jackpot da hab ich noch einen rat dax-signal geklagt hat der fahrer hat
also ja genau hier gab es ein update und zwar wir habe mal ich habe auch durchgelegt
dass das jetzt nochmal so ein fifty mal gefestigt wird und天oramuse, so dass wir
das hier auf dem jackpot online werden und so wir haben hier nur einen
Naja, genau, hier gab es ein Update.
Und zwar, wir hatten es doch erst letztens davon.
Letztens jemand im Stream gefragt, wie viel ich für mein JetBrains Abo bezahle.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich bezahle, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ich glaube 280 Euro im Jahr oder sowas.
Zumindest gab es jetzt, gestern oder vorgestern oder die letzten Tage auf jeden Fall, gab es eine Ankündigung, zeige ich euch auch gleich.
Also aktuell habe ich hier JetBrains All Desktop, All Products Pack.
Ja, ja, I want it all in individual use.
Jetzt müssen wir auf jeden Fall erstmal Dark Mode, äh, okay, der Dark Mode verkackt.
Ich dachte, JetBrains hat einen eigenen Dark Mode, den man einschalten, naja, was auch immer.
Zumindest, ähm, ja, also aktuell bezahle ich hier, okay, es ist inklusive Mehrwertsteuer, inklusive FAT.
Es ist 205 Euro.
Man muss hier oben immer umstellen, standardmäßig steht das nämlich hier for Organizations.
Was, äh, ziemlich bewilligt ist, es kostet auch doppelte.
Sogar ein bisschen mehr Individual Use braucht man.
So, zumindest, aktuell muss ich im Jahr, weil ich habe das schon lange, also auf jeden Fall über drei Jahre, äh, muss ich 173 Euro oder 205 Euro mit Mehrwertsteuer, muss ich abdrücken.
Im Jahr, ich finde das ist durchaus okay.
Okay, für das, was man bekommt, aber viel nicer, guckt mal, was die, was die gepostet haben bei JetBrains auf Twitter.
Und zwar haben die gepostet, dass, wie man hier sieht, am 24. Oktober, ja, also vor, vorgestern, haben die gepostet, dass ab jetzt WebStorm und Rider, Alter, diese ganzen Overlays, Mann.
Dass jetzt WebStorm und Rider.
Free for Non-Commercial Use sind.
Und die meisten Leute, die daheim irgendwas bauen, die sind ja, äh, Non-Commercial Use.
Ich zeige das nachher nochmal, dass alle mitbekommen haben.
Also PyCharm ist schon seit einer Weile kostenlos.
Und IntelliJ E heißt im Endeffekt, die haben jetzt für Python, für Java, Kotlin.
und sowas für dotnet und für frontend sachen haben die quasi eine jeweils kostenlose idee
die meiner meinung nach somit die beste ist die man verwenden kann was aus ihrem komischen
wishles studio code konkurrent geworden ist habe ich schon wieder vergessen wie das fleet
geworden ist keine ahnung redet irgendwie keiner mehr drüber vielleicht rausgewonnen gibt es immer
noch juckt aber alle das alter was ist mit der seite los sie das ruckeln das ist okay das ist
wenn man wenn man zu hart css ich will mir gar nicht sicher ob ich das ja doch erkennt das auch
dass es nicht flüssig ist und meine cpu auslastung beim scrollen guckt euch das mal an die seite
aller die seite lastet einfach ein cpu core komplett aus wenn man
sie scrollt wahrscheinlich ist das auch der beschränkende faktor und stimmt automatisch
zu dass nutzerdaten gesammelt werden naja gut stimmts bitte ja sollte man sollte man sich
überlegen ob man das will aber du stimmst ja mittlerweile fast allem dazu zu zumindest
webstorm und rider sind jetzt kostenlos für non commercial use es gab bisher die möglichkeit
für open source projekte sich für eine open source lizenz zu bewerben das sieht
man auch hier irgendwo vor open source project ja also das gab es die ganze zeit schon und ich
habe von einigen leuten gelesen auf reddit die so eine open source projekte lizenz haben dass
man also dass die anforderungen für so eine open source lizenz sehr gering sind also dass das die
meisten leute die ein paar projekte auf github haben und da regelmäßig kommenten dass sie das
auch bekommen können
können wir das hier gucken bist du heute noch früher aufgestanden naja heute nacht wurde die
zeit umgestellt eigentlich ist es ganz normale uhrzeit jetzt eigentlich ist jetzt 9.30 also easy
ja das ist es halt die wollten gegen den visual studio konkurrent machen aber ohne plugins geht
das halt nicht ne hello everybody and welcome to was job einstieg als softwareentwickler sap sap
ja können wir gucken erinnere mich gleich noch mal dran falls ich es wieder verdrängt habe oder so
ich muss unbedingt mal wieder zum friseur er merkt das hier schon ob das headset auf ich merke dass
es schlechter passt weil so viele haare oben sind also ist jetzt ich habe keine ich habe gerade keine
langen haare oder so aber die sind also also jetzt nicht irgendwie das irgendwie hängt großartig als
früher mal ich hatte früher sie habe ich das überhaupt hier mal erzählt habe ich habe wo ich
jünger war hatte ich so eine heavy metal frisur mit 16 17
kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen war so ja aber ich merke dass ich wusste echt mal wieder ein
bisschen abschneiden lassen wenn das sap ist benutzt ja nicht aber nicht alles in sap irgendwie
aber so updates sind alle durch damit sind überhaupt einen reboot waren köln update
überhaupt dabei ich hab jetzt gar nicht gucken wahrscheinlich scheiße wahrscheinlich braucht er gar
keine die wut
Quade, HD,
XD. Oh, guck mal,
ich hab mich bei meinem hochkomplexen
VM-Passwort verschrieben.
Ja, Reboot ist immer nicht
verkehrt. Ja, genau, okay.
Reboot war, glaub ich, gar nicht notwendig.
Aber okay.
Warum nicht? Und Chat, wie habt
ihr geschlafen heute Nacht? Wie gesagt,
ich hab so
semi-gut geschlafen. Das lag bestimmt irgendwie ein bisschen mit
an der Zeitumstellung. Guckt man so manchmal auf die
Uhr und denkt sich, irgendwie stimmt was nicht.
So ging's so.
Warum machst du eigentlich nur Windows
als Haussystem?
Ja, weil
sich Linux für meine
Zwecke deutlich einfacher unter Windows
virtualisieren lässt als umgedreht.
Ja, bin ich vielleicht...
Ich meine, das ist auch ein Aufwachen-Stream, ja.
Dass sich, weil sich Linux unter
Windows für meine Anwendungszwecke
einfacher virtualisieren lässt als umgedreht.
Und weil ich unter Windows
halt noch ein paar Sachen mache, die
Windows brauchen.
Gehen wir mal von meinem Video-Editor
hängen, Zeug und Thumbnails erstellen und so.
Gehen wir mal weg. Ich will
vielleicht ja auch mal
die ein oder anderen aktuelle Spiele spielen
mit Anti-Cheat.
Das wäre ja durchaus, ne?
Ne, LOL
will ich nicht spielen. Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Keckweh.
Trotzdem, dass eigentlich
9.30 Uhr ist, ne?
Jetzt so 8.30 Uhr ist so die normale
Zeit, wo ich so langsam an den Rechner
gehe. Ich war heute schon ein bisschen früher am Rechner,
weil halt, ne, andere Zeit und so.
Jetzt muss ich aufs Klo.
Oh, guck mal, ich hab
einen Knopf bei mir.
Ist ja wie bei meinem Vorschau-Rechner.
Da steht jetzt anklopfen
bei Wobblors.
Ich klopf an. Ah.
Man kann nicht bei sich selbst
anklopfen, okay.
Ah, da kann ich bei anderen Streamern anklopfen,
ob die irgendwie...
What? Das ist doch ein
Feature, was
jeder größere Stream so ausschaltet,
weil sonst klopfen bei ihm 3 Millionen,
das ist doch ein anderer Streamer an, oder?
Ah, schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
Jetzt ernsthaft? 3 Minuten?
Das ist ja krass. Das ist ja...
Nicht, dass ich das irgendwie
toll finden würde,
dass du 3 Minuten
Werbung vor dem Stream gucken musst.
Ja.
Ziemlicher Sack. Also ich hab mir
mittlerweile tatsächlich Nitro
gekauft. Ne, ne, ne, nicht
Nitro. Nitro ist Discord.
Turbo.
Fast. Warum ist das Zeug auch so ähnlich?
Heiß, ne? Turbo.
Jemand von euch...
Okay, ist das so?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das ist eh verschwindend gering, was man so von
Werbung... Ich weiß gar nicht,
was ich da kriege. 2,50 Euro oder so.
Hat jemand von euch Black Ops 6 schon
gespielt? Ich hab mir das
runtergeladen am Freitag.
Ich glaub Freitag war Release, ne?
Ich hab mir das am Freitag runtergeladen
und ich hab's nicht einmal
gestartet.
Ich hab den, die letzten...
Die letzten hab ich auch nicht gekauft.
Aber...
Also ich hab die letzten...
Ich hab weniger Call of Duty's gekauft,
als ich gekauft habe.
Ich glaub 59 Euro oder sowas.
Es gibt irgendwie so eine super hyper
Vault Edition, wo man sich mal wieder fragt,
but why? Echt jetzt?
Wie, Moment, man muss
für Audiosettings extra bezahlen?
Sind die... Ja, gut.
Die Frage erübrigt
sich eigentlich, ja. Ich wollt sagen, dass ich das nicht so gut finde.
Sind die denn total bescheuert? Aber...
Man hat die letzten Jahre ja über schon gesehen, dass
die äh...
ziemlich bescheuert sind.
Da kannst du schön die Kohle verbrennen, ja.
Aber richtig...
Vepo Burn Money
kannst du machen.
Also, ich mein, ich muss jetzt mal
zumindest...
Haben die eigentlich ne Singleplayer-Kampagne
diesmal wieder? Also da muss ich
zumindest mal kurz den Singleplayer durchspielen.
Das dauert ja wahrscheinlich nur wieder 3 Stunden oder so.
...
Dass ich zumindest... sich der Kauf in irgendeiner Art...
Ja, oder...
Ich mein, es ist Steam.
Wenn man bei Steam was gekauft hat
und
nicht gespielt hat, kann man's... oder weniger
als 2 Stunden gespielt hat,
kann man's doch zurückgeben, oder?
Ich mein, ich hab's noch nicht mal gestartet.
Ich hab's, glaub ich, installiert. Das war's
dann auch. Natürlich hab ich das
in Steam gekauft
und nicht irgendwie... äh...
bei...
in der Blizzard-App. Nur, aber...
48 Stunden nach dem Kauf. Shit.
Das müsste...
Also, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich hab's...
Wann kam's raus? Sonnstag oder Freitag?
Ne, ich glaub Freitag, ne?
Na, das könnte ein bisschen knapp werden.
Das Matchmaking wird...
...manipuliert.
Okay.
Du meinst das ganz normale Skill-Based Ma...
Also, normal. Das ganz normale
Skill-Based Matchmaking, was es halt so gibt.
Ja, gut.
Ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich das jetzt
auch nicht anders erwartet, weil...
Sehen wir mal ehrlich.
Die Zeiten von...
Ja, ja gut, ist ja...
Man kann quitten,
neue Lobby suchen, quitten, neue Lobby suchen,
bis man die Ultra-Noob-Lobby hat.
Ähm...
Harrier, Choppergunner, Nuke...
Die Zeiten sind halt vorbei.
Was ich... Ich muss sagen...
Also, ich verstehe
es, dass es Skill-Based Matchmaking gibt,
genauso scheiße finde ich
allerdings persönlich
Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Skill-Based Matchmaking
ist
vielleicht für die
aller, aller krassesten
nicht so wild, weil die einfach so
Top 0,01% der Player sind.
Und das heißt,
die sind immer besser als alle anderen,
wobei ja auch schon immer, muss man ja mal ehrlich sagen,
Call of Duty ja die übelsten...
Also, ähm...
Nennen wir es mal...
Mechaniken hatte.
Früher haben wir uns über so Sachen...
Erinnert sich einer an Fuck You, Last Stand?
Haben wir uns über sowas aufgeregt.
Heute ist es ja quasi schon im Spiel
im Matchmaking integriert.
Aber es ist ja
nicht so, als hätte Call of Duty nicht eh schon ziemliche
Abwracksachen, wo du Leute
across the map random
killen kannst. Also, bei Call of Duty
macht es ja eh, sagen wir mal, nur zu
80% aus, ob du gut oder schlecht
spielst. Da ist halt auch super
viel Luck dabei. Die
80% wurden jetzt mit dem neuen Movement
vielleicht ein bisschen skilliger, das weiß ich nicht.
Das hab ich noch nie auspro... Hab ja noch nicht gespielt.
So, das Dumme ist nur,
also, was ich halt gerne gemacht hab
in den Games, ich wusste, dass ich in dem
Spiel halt ein bisschen
besser spiele als der Durchschnittsspieler.
So, und das hat gereicht,
dass du regelmäßig Lobbys bekommen hast, wo du
alles zerstört hast. Das hat halt Bock gemacht, ja.
Dass das
den Leuten,
die
6-7 Minuten am Stück
zerstört werden, keinen Spaß macht.
Das haben wir uns...
Chat, ich mein, seriously. Nehmen wir mal
irgendwie... Sandy
Ravage, gibt's den noch? MW2?
Ich mein, hat
wirklich jemand jemals gedacht,
dass es den Leuten,
die in diesen Games
hier sind, ja,
die Gegner in diesen Spielen,
hat wirklich jemand gedacht, dass es den Spaß
macht, die Runde, ja?
Alter, vor allem diese
scheiß Videoqualität damals.
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das
allen Ernstes irgendjemand sich gedacht hat,
oh ja, die Gegner, die finden das
sicherlich richtig, richtig geil,
da abgefarmt zu werden.
Chat,
wir hatten
doch, jetzt wo ich dieses
MW2-Gameplay sehe,
wir hatten doch mal
vor ein paar Jahren so ein Channel,
der noch oldschool
MW2-Gameplays hochgeladen hat.
Hat noch
jemand eine Ahnung, was das
war?
Wer das war?
Und wir hatten so ein Battlefield,
wir hatten so ein, ich glaub,
so hieß der Battlefield-Highlights-Channel,
weiß gar nicht, macht der noch was?
Nee, I'm done.
Okay, Battlefield 22
just isn't it, I'm done.
Geil, doch, vor zwei Jahren.
Wir hatten so ein Channel mal
für MW2, also für richtig
echtes, nein, nein, kein deutscher
Channel, irgendein
13er,
ja, da gibt's so viel,
keine Ahnung,
keine Ahnung mehr.
Naja, zumindest, worauf ich eigentlich
raus wollte,
denkt ernst, also hat jemand wirklich damals
gedacht,
dass irgendwie die Gegner da großartig
Spaß haben,
so in dieser, in diesen Runden, ja?
Der hat irgendwie zweimal Chopper, zweimal
Chopper, Ghana, Bam, Nuke, also,
und die Gegner sind ja auch wirklich absolut
braindead.
Guckt euch, guckt euch, ich meine
seriously, seriously, was ist, was
ist mit den Leuten los? Das hab ich damals schon mal gefragt.
Der läuft, legit.
Okay, der ist Level 17, der ist halt komplett
clueless, der Typ, ja? Also kann mir aber
keiner erzählen, guck mal, der läuft sogar in die andere Richtung.
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass die damals
daran Spaß hatten, die Gegner. Trotzdem,
muss ich sagen,
ist mir das lieber gewesen,
als Skill-Based
Matchmaking. Weil wenn du da,
sag mal, überdurchschnittlich gespielt
hast, du musst nicht irgendwie der Top 1,
0,1% Player gewesen sein.
Du hast immer mal wieder Lobbys
gefunden, wo du übelst zerstört hast.
Und jetzt mit Skill-Based Matchmaking
ist es aber einfach ultra
anstrengend.
Wenn du nicht mehr ultra rein
tryhardest,
kriegst du halt mega auf den Sack.
Klar kann man jetzt sagen, ey, dann ist die
nächste Runde vielleicht nicht mehr so
anspruchsvoll. Wobei das
ja alles, also wenn das ordentliche Skill-Based Matchmaking
ist, alles ein bisschen schwanken sollte.
Dann gibt es so Sachen wie Reverse Boosting.
Weiß nicht, ob das noch ein Ding ist.
Aber gerade als Skill-Based,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es
immer noch ein Trend, ja.
Gerade als es angefangen hat
mit Skill-Based Matchmaking,
haben die Leute Hardcore
Reverse Boosted.
Ja. Die haben Hardcore
Reverse Boosted, so nach dem Motto
50 Games
sich immer mit einer Granate
im Spawn gekillt.
Und das für
50 Runden, sodass die
gegen halt solche Leute,
ne, gegen solche Leute
gematcht wurden. So welche hier.
Gegen solche Leute wurden die dann nur noch gematcht.
Plus, dass die gesamte Lobby halt so war.
Und für solche Leute ist halt
das
heftig anspruchsvoll halt.
Und super ausgeglichen da
andere solcher Leute zu spielen.
Ja. Dann kam die ganze
Geschichte mit
Account von jemand anderem, ja.
Du kannst ja heute auf Ebay, wie gesagt,
ich, ich, ich
will nur sagen, dass das ein Problem ist.
Ich sag nicht, dass man ernsthaft dafür Geld
ausgeben sollte, aber man kann sich wirklich ernsthaft
einen Reverse Boosted
Account und sowas kaufen.
Manchmal.
Ja, das sind ja mit zwei oder was man da suchen muss.
Ja.
Okay, vielleicht auch nicht mehr, vielleicht löscht das
Ebay. Ja.
Aber zumindest konnte man sich ne Zeit lang
Alter!
Das sind die, die mit irgendwelchen
...
Alle Atomkraft.
So, so. Naja.
Zumindest konnte man sich ne ganze Weile, wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile, vielleicht unterbindet's
Ebay, ich weiß es nicht.
Konnte man sich Reverse Boosted Accounts kaufen
und dann ein paar Runden spielen, bis das
Reverse Boosting wieder weg war.
Konnte auch Leute beauftragen, sich Reverse
boosten zu lassen.
Dann gab es noch die Leute, die
Playstation gespielt
haben und
in die Lobby nachgechoicht.
Das war schon lange Zeit so ein Trick für Warzone.
Das hast du ja immer gesehen bei irgendwelchen Warzone-Videos.
Leute, die nachgejoint haben,
wenn
irgendwelche Freunde mit schlechtem
Account quasi
oder mit schlechtem Matchmaking-Account
in der Lobby waren, da sind die nachgejoint
und sind halt in der übelsten
Kack-Noob-Lobby gelandet und waren selbst ganz brauchbar.
Also da sieht man Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Sobald es sowas gibt, gibt's halt auch
genauso viele Leute, die es wieder versuchen auszunutzen,
um halt dieses
Wir bashen die Noobs weg zu erreichen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich kann verstehen, warum es das gibt,
aber genauso kacke
finde ich
Skill-Based Matchmaking auch.
Ja, also hat aus meiner Sicht
eigentlich
das Spiel schlechter gemacht.
Ja, ich meine
sowas wie Battlefield,
das war so ein Oldschool
Commentary-Account,
der hat aber, also englischsprachig,
der war allerdings nicht
Oldschool in Form von einer Zeit, der hat
immer wieder neue Videos gemacht, aber tatsächlich
Original MW2.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie der Account hieß.
Ich meine, wir können
Nicht, nicht
Kennst du? Ja, den habe ich schon mal gehört, ja.
Wir können
mal hier Transkript
suchen. Aufwachen Stream
Resident Sleeper, guck mal.
Vor 5 Jahren, da haben wir ein MW2-Video geguckt.
Ist das mein eigenes Video?
Mal gucken, was das
von welchem Channel
das Ganze ist.
PORTUENET, genau, den meine ich.
Ja, gibt es den noch?
PORTUENET war das.
Okay, das Spiel hinkram immer noch.
Den muss ich mal bug machen,
wenn ich mal irgendwann Oldschool
Style-Videos
sehen möchte.
Five Head Search, ja, muss man sagen, hat
Max echt gut hingekriegt. Also nicht ich,
ist Max Modge.
Richtig gut hingekriegt
mit dem Archiv, das ist richtig Pogge.
Pogu
ist das. Wusste nicht, dass
du auf dem Zweitkanal World of Tanks spielst
mit Facecam.
Klar, es liegt.
Ach, gibt es wirklich einen Channel, der
so heißt, oder wie?
Naja, gut.
Wundert mich jetzt nicht so
ausgefallen ist das Ganze nicht. Tatsächlich
World of Tanks, ja.
World of Tanks mit Facecam.
Es liegt. Shit.
Wirst du dir das neu... Natürlich, natürlich.
Soll der Gegenwart sein
und drei Viertel...
Da habe ich ein Video letztens gesehen,
Level Cap oder
Jack Frax oder irgendwie einer von diesen Oldschool
Battlefield Leuten, das war natürlich wieder so ein übelst
reißerisches Ding. Und am Ende hast du irgendwie
kurzes
Gameplay-Ausschnitt gesehen, wo irgendwie einer
in so einer
eindeutig Test-Map
rumgelaufen ist und
nicht viel war. Ja.
Also, ich werde mir das auf jeden Fall angucken. Egal.
Also,
es ist fast egal, wie das
Game wird. Angucken werde ich es mir auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich ja immer noch die Hoffnung nicht
komplett aufgegeben habe, dass es
mal ein wirklich gutes, neues
Battlefield geben wird. Ich meine,
nach 2042
schwinden die Hoffnungen so langsam aber
sicher, ja.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass die so viel in Richtung
Battle Royale gehen werden.
Also, mittlerweile...
Also, ich hätte
gedacht,
die letzten paar
Battlefields wäre
vielleicht zu Release ein Battlefield-like
Battle Royale-Modus nicht
schlecht gewesen, als Battle Royale so in aller
Munde war und voll gehypt.
Mittlerweile bin ich fast
der Ansicht,
dass der Battle Royale-Zug
eigentlich
abgefahren ist.
Und man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen,
Battlefield ist halt ein Spiel für mich,
das von
Rush und Conquest lebt.
Ich persönlich bin ja Rush-Fanboy.
Ich brauche eigentlich gar keinen Conquest.
Aber ich weiß, Conquest ist der Kern-Battlefield-Modus.
Also, insofern...
Ja, okay.
Also, mir wäre es lieber,
die würden das weglassen.
Also, kein Battle Royale
machen.
Und ihre gesamte Energie und Zeit
und auch kein Extraction-Mode.
Ich meine ganz ernsthaft,
Hazard Zone.
Ja, genau, die Hazard Zone.
Das war ja grottenschlecht.
Du hast die ersten 1-2 Runden gedacht,
ja, ist doch eigentlich ganz nett. Und danach hast du gesagt,
geh weg.
Hazard Zone, ja.
Nee, mir wäre es lieber,
die investieren ihre Zeit
in
Rush und in
Conquest. Anstelle,
dass sie da irgendwie Battlefield versuchen
sowas zu machen.
Was Battlefield nicht ist, beziehungsweise
sich
das so sehr in die falsche Richtung
entwickelt. Weil ich denke mal, so eine
Battlefield ist jetzt ja auch eine
Spielereihe, die ist schon
bisschen älter und
ich weiß auch, wie ich wollte gerade sagen, also, wenn die
die Leute ansprechen wollen,
die das Spiel halt schon eine Weile spielen,
dann sicherlich nicht mit Extraction
und Battle Royale. Die Frage ist
halt nur,
ob sie diese Leute überhaupt ansprechen
wollen. Weil man darf
nicht vergessen, die original Battlefields, die
Battlefield Player,
oder ich meine jetzt nicht
1942 unbedingt, sondern
Leute, man darf nicht vergessen, Battlefield 3
kam ziemlich genau auf den Tag vor 13
Jahren raus.
Ja, 25, 25,
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
25. Oktober 2011
kam das raus. Krass, oder?
Und man darf nicht vergessen,
13 Jahre, Leute,
die dort 18 waren,
die sind jetzt 31.
Das heißt, Leute, die da reingesuchtet haben,
sind höchstwahrscheinlich nicht
mehr die größte Gruppe,
die die ansprechen wollen.
Die haben heute vielleicht Kinder
und gehen auf jeden Fall arbeiten.
Gehen arbeiten, haben Familie,
haben vielleicht Kinder, haben andere Probleme.
Dafür, auf der anderen Seite,
ist es auch eine relativ
zahlungskräftige Gruppe, weil
Leute, die arbeiten gehen
und Geld verdienen,
die können halt auch mal ein bisschen Kohle in das Game
reinstecken. Also,
ich weiß nicht, was sie da vorhaben,
aber ich denke mal nicht,
dass diese Gruppe
die ist, wo sie
das Hauptaugenmerk drauf legen.
Aber es wäre gut, wenn die mit dem neuen
Battlefield versuchen würden, möglichst breit
die Leute anzusprechen. Ja, das denke ich.
Ehrlich gesagt, das habe ich mir
auch schon oft gedacht. Ich glaube,
ein gutes Battlefield, das ist ein relativ,
also, wenn man sich mal anguckt,
ähm,
wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie gut sich das
immer noch spielt, ja. Ich habe gestern ein bisschen
BF3-Streams geguckt, nebenbei,
wie gut sich das immer noch spielt
und wie die Leute da bei, keine Ahnung, hier
Grand Passage Rush
immer noch abgehen und sich da
übelst reinsteigern in den Spielmodus
und alles, dann ist das was,
wo ich mir sehr sicher bin, das ist
ein relativ zeitloses
Multiplayer-Konzept
und
ich denke, dass das auch durchaus jüngere
Leute ansprechen könnte, zumal
die den Vorteil haben,
das ist ja wirklich ein Vorteil,
die kennen das nicht
in dieser
guten Ausführung.
Die haben vielleicht was vom Battlefield
2042 gehört,
festgestellt, boah, was ein Schrott-Game, Alter,
geh mal weg, aber die Jüngeren
kennen das ja gar nicht. Hat doch keiner
13 Jahre alt
das Battlefield gespielt oder gar BC2
oder sowas. Wird Company 3
BC ähnlich geben, weil
DICE ja angeblich nicht weiß, was Bad Company ausgemacht hat
oder irgendwie so ein Blödsinn
oder whatever, sie ist ja großartig erzählt,
haben. Ja, das meine ich ja,
Kinder sind da eine gute Zielgruppe
für solche,
nicht Pay2Win, aber für solche Microtransaction
Geschichten.
Ja. Also,
gestern, wie gesagt, witzigerweise
ein paar Battlefield 3, ein bisschen
Battlefield 3-Stream geguckt bei einem auf YouTube,
äh, nicht auf YouTube, auf Twitch
und
bei, ich kann mir
immer die anfangen, Bounty,
TC Bounty, irgendwie so,
also der einzige
deutsch-englischsprachige
Streamer, der irgendwie noch Battlefield 3 streamt
und da habe ich auch
geschrieben im Chat, ähm, Leute,
es wäre so geil, wenn es einfach
nur ein Game so im
Geiste von Battlefield 3 gäbe,
Battlefield 3 4 Mischung,
ich will,
ich will kein, ich will kein
Remaster, Remake oder sowas,
wobei ganz ehrlich,
die können gerne die
guten Karten einfach übernehmen.
Die können einfach,
Damavand Peak, Sand Crossing,
Grand Bazaar, das können die gerne ruhig
übernehmen, bisschen anpassen, vielleicht für das jeweils
neue Game
und da reinschmeißen. Es ist ja nicht so,
als hätte, als hätten die nicht in der Vergangenheit
schon mal gute Maps auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Auch für eine variable
Anzahl von Spielern. Muss natürlich ganz
klar sagen, also, so, so Grand Bazaar
mit Maximum Players ist halt Rush
mit Maximum Players ist halt schon
an manchen M-Comps
Hardcore Clusterfuck.
Da könnte man, könnte man vielleicht was
machen. An mir fällt heute, wenn ich
Battlefield 3 Streams und so gucke,
fällt mir immer noch auf, wie gut
durchdacht die Maps einfach sind, so.
Aus welchen
Winkeln du quasi was abamen kannst
oder du langlaufen kannst, dass du
gut Deckung hast, die anderen dich nicht sehen
und so. Da fällt, fällt mir immer wieder was auf,
wo ich mir denke, alter, da haben sie
sich wirklich was bei gedacht.
Naja, Battlefield 4 war auch okay, aber Rush
war nicht mehr auf dem gleichen Level wie Battlefield 3.
Meiner Meinung nach, ja.
Zu Proxmox umziehen von VMware.
Könnt ihr das überhaupt?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob diese
gesamte Palette, die es da so gibt, ja,
an Ökosystemen
für VMware, ob es die
in Proxmox auch
gibt. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob die
Hochverfügbarkeitslösung, dass ich, wie gesagt,
ich hab keine Ahnung von Proxmox, ich hab das nie
Enterprise-mäßig verwendet, ob
die Hochverfügbarkeitslösung
von Proxmox so gut
funktioniert, wie die Sache von VMware
und auch was integrierte Backup-Tools
und alles, ich weiß es nicht, ja.
Also, ich weiß halt nur, dass es um VMware
ein riesengroßes Ökosystem
gibt. VMware selbst
hat jede Menge Sachen und es gibt halt auch, wie gesagt,
jede Menge
Third-Party-Sachen, die aber auch
sehr verbreitet sind, fast schon Standard sind
bei VMware. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es
bei Proxmox das alles
auch gibt. Bad Company 2
bei Rush am besten,
ja, das hatte die besten, also
die besten,
ich würde gar nicht mal sagen, die besten Rush-Maps,
so, also
insgesamt durch die Bank weg kann man das
vielleicht sagen, weil da waren eigentlich alle
Maps in Rush ganz gut, aber
Bad Company 2
hat auf jeden Fall einige sehr gute
Rush-Maps.
Vor allem hatte Bad Company 2
diese, so diese
Landschaftsmaps, ja,
das waren ja fast alles, Bad Company 2
waren ja fast alles so
Landschaftsmaps. Ich weiß nicht,
wie ich das anders beschreiben soll, ja,
das war nicht so Grand Bazaar,
Zen Crossing oder sowas,
nicht so Stadtkarten, Battlefield 3
hatte ja relativ viele Stadtkarten, Terran, Highway
und so, hatte ja relativ viele Stadtkarten, du hattest
ein paar Sachen, sowas wie beispielsweise
Firestorm oder
Caspian Border hat so ein paar Sachen, die waren
ein bisschen im Style von Bad Company 2,
aber die Bad Company 2 Maps,
das waren eigentlich alles so relativ
offene so, so Environment-Karten,
du hattest so quasi so ein
ein Umweltthema, so
Dschungel oder Schnee
an Küste, so Port Valdes und sowas.
Ja.
Und, ähm,
deswegen fände ich, wäre eine
Mischung da echt sehr, sehr
pogu.
Okay, genug gelabert,
Leute. Oh, ich bin
echt nicht gut geschlafen, ey,
übelst im Arsch.
Was garantiert an der Zeitumstellung
liegt, ey.
Ich glaube, vielleicht habe ich einfach auch zu
lange gelegen, ja, das könnte
auch sein, also, ich mein,
ich bin um
bin um 22
ins Bett und hab bis
so ungefähr, keine Ahnung,
um 8 oder so,
hab ich im Bett gelegen,
ist halt, ist halt schon,
also 8,
8 nach neuer Zeit, was 9
ist, sind halt 11 Stunden.
Das ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen lang, oder?
Gut, ich mein, ich hab nicht 11 Stunden
gepennt, das nicht,
aber, ah, vielleicht,
war vielleicht echt ein bisschen lang.
Wie gesagt, das kann
ich nicht, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Ich hab,
ich hab Proxmox noch nie hier im
Enterprise-Business-Umfeld
verwendet.
Ja, SV, äh, BC2
war, war nice.
SV98 mit
ACOG-Scope.
Bei uns ist eigentlich alles
vor MWR, trotz Broadcom.
Ähm,
was auch cool war in
BC2,
war die,
diese 50-Kaliber,
Kaliber 50, ich weiß nicht, wie die sich hieß, ne,
Sniper, weil die hatte
ne längere One-Hit-Range,
aber SV98 war die,
M95, genau, aber SV98
war die, war die offensivere,
skilligere Sniper, weil du hattest mehr Schuss und konntest
schneller schießen, dafür war die
M95, hat halt längere
One-Hit-Range gehabt.
Und außerdem muss man sagen,
dass das
ACOG-Scope
in BC2 auf der Xbox
einfach bescheuert OP war,
weil du hattest ein Auto-Aim
auf die Gegner,
wenn du reingezoomt hast.
Du konntest quasi übelst
krass quickscopen in BC2.
Du hast reinge-aimt, bam, und hast
direkt getroffen. Vielleicht war das
auch einfach nur, vielleicht war das auch nicht
richtiges Auto-Aim, aber es hat sich schon eben
ein bisschen so angefühlt.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Gucken, ob es da noch ein Gameplay gibt von mir,
wo man das sieht.
Sniper.
Ja, mal gucken, ob das Xbox ist.
Ist das Xbox? Chatgear, das sieht so
kacke aus, die Quali.
Das ist bestimmt Xbox, oder?
Erkennt irgendjemand, ob das Xbox ist?
Jaja, hier, hier, eindeutig.
Xbox.
So, passt mal auf. Ich guck mal,
ob ich euch das zeigen kann, was ich meine.
So, tschau.
Ihr habt das gesehen? Habt ihr das gesehen?
Erster Kill. Guckt's euch an.
Guckt's euch an.
Da ist der Gegner, ich dreh mich hin.
Guck mal, guck mal. Guck mal
die Sniper. Guck mal.
Fallen ass. Okay, das war
jetzt, das war jetzt ein Kill.
Das könnte ja sein, dass ich einfach super krass geaimt hab.
Lasst mal den nächsten Kill abwarten.
Könnte ja sein, dass ich der ultra krasseste
Aim-Skiller auf dem Xbox Controller damals war.
Warum ist denn das
eigentlich so dunkel, das Video?
So was,
so was haben die Leute damals geguckt,
Alter. 720p,
Kack-Auflösung,
Kack-Bildwiederholung.
Na gut, es ging ja auf YouTube damals nicht besser.
Bisschen heller hätte ich das Gameplay
vielleicht machen können, ne?
Ne, Leute, das ist nicht
mein Skiller-Aim. Das ist die Waffe,
die aimt. Guckt mal.
Guckt doch mal.
Guck mal, ich bin, guck mal, ich bin da überhaupt
Ich bin da überhaupt nicht richtig drauf.
Ich ziel viel zu weit vorbei.
Na, wobei, der ist schon ziemlich in der Mitte.
Aber jetzt,
der snappt schon auf den Gegner, oder?
Ich kann mir keine...
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ist es das Game, was mir beim Zielen hilft,
oder ist es einfach mal ein überkrasses Controller-Skill-Aim?
Aim-Bot.
Okay, das war jetzt,
das war jetzt wirklich normal
geaimt, ja?
Das auch? Das war gar nicht geaimt?
Oh.
Ich war ja mal, ich war mal ne richtige
Schneiberstelser hier auf BC2, auf
der Xbox.
Gut, das, das war auch manchmal, manchmal hat's
nicht funktioniert. Guckt.
Obwohl das drauf war.
Aber das ist durchgeflogen. Das kam
manchmal vor.
Dass es einfach durchgeflogen ist.
Was geht los?
Witzig, dass ich mir heute das Gameplay angucke.
Ich kann mich null dran erinnern, dass ich das jemals
gespielt hab, dieses Game.
Also, das Gameplay hier.
Ah, diese Motion-Sensor-Dinger waren
auch so nice. Bam.
Das war
das war not even
close, oder?
Das war doch, okay, man darf
man darf nicht vergessen,
BC2 hatte
reine Server-Side-Hit-Detection, ne?
Reine
Server-Side-Hit-Detection.
Und ich glaube,
die hatten in BC2 auch schon
ähm
Flugdauer und so von,
also, das kann durchaus sein,
dass das Game gedacht hat,
der läuft da jetzt
rein, ja?
So Server...
Also...
Naja.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob das ein Headshot war?
Okay, das war nix.
Irgendwie finde ich, kann man eigenes
Gameplay voll faszinierend, mir das anzugucken,
was ich damals zusammengewurschtelt hab.
Wie gesagt, das ist alles Xbox, ne?
Und man beachtet,
dass das nice Xbox-Controller
Scheibenwischer-Aim...
Oh nein!
Ja, gerätzt wurde er damals
prinzipiell nicht. Guckt euch mal an, wo unsere Leute
wieder rumkrebsen, leider. Die Noobs
fliegen den Heli, man.
Ich seh den gar nicht! Wo ist er denn?
Ach da, doch, doch.
Alter, doch, ich hab
geheadshottet. Das war wirklich
legit geaimt.
Aber Sniper war schon krass in dem Game,
oder? Okay, der war
außer One-Hit-Range, ist aber One-Shot,
der mit einem Treffer ist, genau.
What the fuck?
Guck dir mal an, was die für ne Range hat.
Wobei, das...
Einfach in den Ass geballert. Bam, dead.
Also, muss schon sagen,
Sniper war in dem Game
echt...
weggemessert. War in dem
Game schon echt O.P.S.
Fuck. War das ein Headshot?
Das war ein Headshot!
Also, man muss sagen,
die Hitboxen waren schon
sehr...
Die haben einem schon echt viel vergeben,
oder? Ich mein, das war
semi... drauf.
Ja, da war ein One-Hit-Range.
Alter, ich geh ja richtig
ab in dem Game, man.
Guckt euch das an! Bam, bababam!
Die kriegen ja übelst krass auf den Sack.
Ich bin fasziniert von meinem eigenen
Gsniper auf der Xbox grade.
Sorry, Leute, das...
müssen wir jetzt leider noch ein
bisschen weitergucken. Moment.
Da müsste er jetzt durch.
Was? Achso, ja gut, der hat schon
Damage gefressen. Ja, ja,
also die Hitbox war schon sehr forgiving, so.
Das war
vorbei? Einfach? Okay.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie um die Ecke.
Oh, oh, oh, da hat er veraimt. Jetzt wird er
gebasht. Ne, zack, in
One-Hit-Range gelaufen. Xbox
Aim, kek wait. Ja, aber...
Das war außer
One-Hit-Range. Da kommt bestimmt jetzt gleich noch einer.
Äh, das war halt auch
was, wenn man sich das mal heute überlegt.
Das war schon ziemlich übertrieben OP.
Dieses
ewig lange Spotten
durch Wände und so.
Und vor allem in Bad Company 2 war es ja auch so,
du konntest durch ganz viele Wände
einfach durchspallern.
Juli, danke schön für den Sub.
Ist jetzt Zufall,
dass ich grade auch BC2-Video angucke.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken,
ob es damals so krasses Auto-Aim
beim Scopen hatte,
wie ich es in Erinnerung hatte. Und ja,
hat es teilweise, aber nicht nur. Ich find das Gameplay
richtig nice zum gucken gerade.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor, jetzt ist die Base
ja eh vorbei.
Moment, da sind wir, da werden wir da geschneubert.
Bam, Double-Kill.
Ne, okay, die standen einfach nur... Da ist er.
Bam, in your face. Leute,
das Gameplay ist ja richtig gut.
Oh, das hat einfach nicht gehittet.
Ich mein, man muss mal, muss man mal
sagen, mit Xbox-Controller.
Ich mein, wenn ich mir heute die Warzone-
Leute angucke, die
mit ihrem Playstation-Controller
besser
treffen und moven
und alles, als ich mit Maus und
Tastatur je könnte.
Es ist natürlich nochmal ein anderes Level.
Wobei ich da immer nicht sicher
bin, ob sich nicht generell
irgendwie an den Games
auch am
Support, wie gut das heute funktioniert
mit Controller, nicht irgendwie das
die letzten Jahre über auch krass verbessert hat.
Weil es gibt ja sogar Leute, die spielen mittlerweile
am PC mit Controller.
Warzone. Also ich weiß, in Halo
in Halo ist es super krass.
In Halo spielen die am PC
auch im Controller, weil
dieses sticky, sticky
Halo-Aim
richtig, richtig heftig ist.
Ja, und
ansonsten, was ich
auch schon gelesen hab, letztens
auf Twitter,
dass einer, einer
spielte auf dem PC,
allerdings,
jetzt passt mal auf, dass ich
weiß nicht, ob das Fifed ist oder schon
Cheaten, das könnt ihr mir ja gleich sagen, was ihr davon
haltet. Da hab ich letztens ein Gameplay
gesehen, auf Twitter, Warzone,
Warzone Gameplay. Sorry,
ich meine x ehemals Twitter.
Äh, hab ich ein Video
gesehen von einem, der hat geschrieben,
das ist anscheinend auch gar kein Geheimnis, anscheinend ist das
mittlerweile relativ normal, in Anführungszeichen.
Weiß ich nicht, wie normal das ist. Und zwar,
der hat
Warzone gespielt,
mit Controller
und, also am PC,
mit Controller,
allerdings mit emuliertem
Controller. Der hat quasi
mit Maus und Tastatur gespielt,
die allerdings
als Controller
irgendwie dem Game gemeldet wurden.
Weiß ich nicht, wie das geht. Entweder hat
er so ein Zusatz-Device
gehabt, was sich als Controller
meldet, aber Input von Maus und Tastatur benutzt,
oder aber es gibt Softwarelösungen
mittlerweile.
Ähm, für
PC weiß ich nicht, ob so was gibt.
Aber ich meine, von der Idee her ist es
easy. Du programmierst
halt was, was sich als Controller anmeldet,
oder was halt ein Controller-Device
presentet, dem Computer.
Und als Input nimmst du
Maus und Tastatur. Und wahrscheinlich ist es
sogar besser optimiert,
als
irgendwelche Hardware-Devices. Zumindest,
der spielte halt mit
Maus und Tastatur
als Controller-Input gemappt,
Warzone. Und das war so krass,
der Typ, das kann ich gar nicht nachmachen,
der movte wirklich so
Das war so ein übelst krasses Ninja-Movement,
plus
krassestes Auto-Aim des Todes,
Mann. Das gab's zu PS3-Zeiten
schon. Ich weiß,
es gibt, ähm, oder gab, ich hab
ja mir auch mal so ein Ding zum Ausprobieren bestellt.
Es gab diese Kronos-Devices
mal, und ein paar andere
Sachen. Ja, ich hab mir auch mal so
einen, so eine Tastatur
zu PS3
war's damals bei mir, bestellt.
Und einen, das war so ein Kombi-Gerät.
Das war quasi Tastatur-Maus-Input
zu PS3
und Xbox
zu PS3. Das hab ich mir
hauptsächlich damals gekauft, weil
ich, und bis heute ist das mein Problem, ja,
ich komme mit dem Playstation-Controller
nicht klar. Ich komme ganz gut mit dem
Xbox-Controller klar, und damals war's
halt so, ich wollte
Uncharted spielen, eines der besten
Playstation-3-Games ever.
Ich wollte Uncharted spielen, aber
ich bin, ich hab einfach Knoten
in den Fingern bekommen mit dem Playstation-Controller.
Also hab ich kurzerhand
den Xbox-Controller angeschlossen.
Und das funktionierte ganz gut.
Das einzige, wo ich, wo ich Probleme hatte,
war, Uncharted 1 hatte noch
diesen Motion-Input
vom
vom DualSense
Controller. Das hatte so, das hat
kaum ein Game benutzt, aber, ja, und
da bin ich halt immer verreckt, oder musste schnell auf den
PS3-Controller.
Ja. Ich will jetzt noch mal
kurz mein, mein
mein eigenes Gameplay
kurz, äh, fertig skippen.
Was da noch so kommt,
ja. Uncharted ist so schade,
dass es das exklusiv gibt. Ja,
wobei, das 4er
gibt's, glaub ich, auf dem PC, ne?
Das ist, äh, Uncharted 4
und Lost Lake.
Es ist, es ist echt schade, dass es kein
Uncharted 1, 2, 3 auf dem PC gibt.
Das ist wirklich sad-Gil.
Ja, Uncharted
4 gibt's auf dem PC.
Aber wie gesagt,
ähm,
ich würde, ich würde echt gerne
Uncharted 1 mal wieder spielen.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht, oder auch 1, 2,
3, ja. Ich weiß
nicht, wie gut die
PS3-Emulatoren mittlerweile
sind. Ich könnte's auf der original
PS3 spielen, aber ich würd's halt gerne
mit 60 FPS und höherer
Auflösung, bisschen verbessertem Zeugs halt
alles spielen. Also ich,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, wird man auf Twitch
für gebannt, wenn man Emulator-Content
streamt? Wenn man
ein Spiel im Emula-, also mal angenommen, es ist
kein Legacy
Super-Nintendo-Spiel oder so.
Da wird man nicht für gebannt. Es gibt so viele,
ähm,
äh, A Link to the Past Randomizer
und sowas zum Beispiel. Das ist ja alles
auf dem Emulator
und, äh, theoretisch, wobei,
das stimmt nicht ganz, theoretisch kannst du sogar auf der echten
Konsole spielen, wenn man so nen, so nen,
so ne Custom-Cardridge hat, wo man, wo man quasi
Custom-ROMs drauf kopiert.
drauf kopieren kann.
Also das, die spielen alle, äh, im Prinzip
genau. Also Super-Nintendo N64,
die Sachen, die, äh,
gefühlt jeder auf, auf
Twitch gefühlt, außer halt die krassen Ultra-Speedrunner
N64, Mario 64,
die spielen das meistens auf Konsole.
Aber, das, viele spielen da auf Emulator.
Ich frag mich, ob es auf Twitch Probleme macht,
wenn man beispielsweise Uncharted
spielt im Emu-, auf dem Emulator.
Falls das überhaupt gescheit geht, da bin ich mir
nicht mal sicher. Müsste ich mal, müsste ich mal.
Also ich darf mit Sicherheit nicht
auf dem Stream gucken.
Gibt es nen PS3-Emulator,
der funktioniert,
äh, und
dann irgendwie der Uncharted zum Laufen kriegen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich verboten, aber wenn ich schon was Fertiges habe,
wo einfach nur Uncharted im Fullscreen
läuft, ich glaube, das ist dann weniger ein Problem.
Außerdem, aus-, naja, weil's
besser aussieht vielleicht, oder weil man das Emulator-Fenster
sieht oder sowas.
Also, zum Glück, es ist ja nicht Nintendo.
Die sind aber
sowas immer, ja,
hat er nicht sogar, kann ich sagen,
ne Musik nochmal neu stellen,
hat er nicht Domtendo letztens Probleme gekriegt?
Habe ich nur so
um drei Ecken über, über
x ehemals Twitter
gelesen, dass er sein,
wie heißt
das letzte Zelda-Game, Wisdom?
Echoes of Wisdom?
Kann das sein? Dass er das angeblich
auf dem Emulator gespielt hätte.
Habe ich Gerüchte gelesen, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, ja.
Habe ich Gerüchte gelesen, habe ich so
um drei Ecken auf Twitter mitgekriegt, dass er das angeblich
auf dem Emulator gespielt hätte.
Habe ich davon hochgeladen und Nintendo wollte,
dass er das Display wieder runternimmt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt, aber
das kann ich mir bei Nintendo schon gut vorstellen.
Das war so ne 4K-Version, ja, also
Emulator.
Der Switch läuft bestimmt nicht einfach mal random
ne 4K-Version, ne?
Das muss dann also Emulator
gewesen sein, wenn das, also, wenn es
deutlich besser aussah als auf der Switch
normal, dann war es wahrscheinlich
Emulator. Ich meine, dann hätte ich,
an seiner Stelle auch gesagt, 4K-Version.
Aber wie gesagt, ich kenne den Sachverhalt
gar nicht, ja.
Palworld verklagen war auch wieder richtig ernst.
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Wie ging das aus, oder läuft das noch?
Weil, ganz ehrlich,
ich habe ein paar, ich habe ein paar
Pokémon-Designs, oder POKEMON,
wie das die Amis immer so schön sagen,
Designs gesehen, so Vergleich zwischen
Palworld und Pokémon, da muss man schon sagen,
also,
die Ähnlichkeiten
waren schon
nichts zu leugnen, ja.
Wie kann es denn im Emo besser
quali laufen, als es entwickelt ist?
Nö, das kann in höhere Auflösung gerendert
werden, zum Beispiel.
Kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, wie der Emulator
gemacht ist. Also, bei
Super Nintendo Games geht das natürlich schwierig.
Die sind halt hardcoded
auf 256 mal
230 oder so, was die
damals an Auflösung hatten. Wobei, der Super Nintendo
konnte auch ein paar unterschiedliche Auflösungen, aber
die waren halt pixelgenau, die
waren halt
modernere Games, die verwenden ja auch
irgendwelche, oder oftmals
irgendwelche Zwischenabstraktionsschichten
zum Rendern.
Und,
wenn die im
Emulator implementiert sind,
könnte man dort durchaus abgreifen,
ich rede jetzt so aus dem Ärmel
geschüttelt, ja, nicht, dass ich mir das groß angeguckt hätte,
das abgreifen, was das Game eigentlich
machen möchte, und das in höherer
Auflösung rendern. Also, du kannst zum Beispiel schon ewig
PS1
Games zum Beispiel in höherer Auflösung
rendern, und da siehst du auch, die haben deutlich
weniger Kanten, als
damals auf der PS3. Das ist
nicht reines
PAL-Auflösung hochgerechnet auf
Full HD, das ist wirklich intern
höher gerendert.
Was es nicht besser macht, sind die Texturen zum Beispiel,
ja, da kannst du ein bisschen Texturfilter machen
und sowas, aber Texturen sind halt Texturen,
die bleiben halt in der Auflösung, wie sie in dem Game drin sind.
Aber, so die
Geometrie an sich, so Polygone
rendern, das, äh,
geht im Emulator dann auch in
höhere Auflösung.
Breath of the Wild Emulation,
ja, die sieht besser aus, als das
Originale. Ja, das ist halt
das Ding, die Switch kam 2017
oder so raus, 2016?
Ne, ne.
Alter, was ist
das? Ne, da steht's doch.
2017. Ja.
2017. Das heißt,
die ist jetzt 7 Jahre alt, und die
Switch war ja damals zu Release jetzt nicht
gerade
das Powerhouse, ja.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, die Switch
war zu Release ungefähr
so über den Daumen gepeilt
mit Ach und Krach auf dem Xbox 360
Niveau. Sofern man die Plattform
überhaupt irgendwie miteinander
vergleichen kann. Ich meine, das ist schon was anderes.
Die Xbox 360 war halt eine richtig
fette Plattform damals, als sie rausgekommen ist,
mit drei CPUs. Muss ich überlegen,
zu der Zeit, als die Xbox 360
rausgekommen ist, war das mit
Multicore-CPU und sowas,
das war noch gar nicht so verbreitet.
Wahrscheinlich war die Xbox 360
für viele Leute das
leistungsstärkste
PC,
leistungsstärkster
Computer, den die zu der damaligen Zeit
bei sich in der Wohnung stehen hatten.
Das muss man echt sagen.
Innovationstechnisch bin ich
der Meinung, wenn man mal von
den ganz alten Sachen absieht, wo halt auch
sich viel sprungmäßig getan hat,
aber so einen richtig krassen
Sprung von dem,
was die Hersteller mit der Hardware da
getrieben haben, waren die letzten
Generationen nicht mehr, im Vergleich
zu der Xbox 360 und der PS3.
Die PS3 war wahnsinnig
innovativ von der Architektur her,
hatte aber
bis zum Schluss Probleme,
dass, also ein
Großteil ihres Lebenszyklus hat die
PS3 Probleme, dass die
Entwickler Schwierigkeiten hatten, die
PS3 ordentlich zu benutzen.
Deswegen
war es ja auch so, dass man gesagt hat, ey die PS3
theoretisch irgendwie doppelt
so schnell wie die Xbox 360, aber
die Leute kriegen es nicht ausgenutzt.
Und außerdem war
die PS3 sehr teuer zu releasen, das stimmt.
Die PS3 war aber eine sehr
innovative Hardware, was den Entwicklern
aber auch sehr viele Probleme gemacht hat.
Die Xbox 360 war aber auch eine richtig
innovative Hardware, also man muss
mal so sagen, man hat, ja man hat damals,
zumindest gab es da ein paar Versuche, Supercomputer
mit Playstation 3s gebaut.
Es gab ja noch Zeiten, wo Linux auf der PS3 lief.
Aber mittlerweile hat das,
mittlerweile haben die das ja sogar rausgepatcht
wieder. Jo.
Und die Xbox 360 war auch
eine sehr innovative Konsole.
Das war eines der ersten Kisten
so Mainstream-mäßig mit 3 CPUs.
Kein Desktop-Rechner hatte damals Dual-Core.
Die Xbox 360
kam 2006 Release.
2005, ja
sagen wir 2006, wo man sich dann gekauft hat.
2006 Release.
Und die war wirklich,
also die Xbox 360 hatte wirklich,
ah, mein Auge, alter!
Das war kein Pentium, was die
drinnen hatte.
Das war eine, das war eine IBM Power
PC-Plattform, die
Xbox 360.
Die hatte aber
echt richtig
Power für die damalige Zeit.
Achso, die PCs damals, ja das
stimmt.
Sieht man irgendwo mal eine
ordentliche Hardware-Übersicht?
Ja hier, da genau.
3,2 Gigahertz Power PC
Triple Core.
Das war brutals
schnell. Und ich meine,
die Xbox 360,
die war ja auch, man darf
nicht vergessen, die
diese
Plattform, die waren
10 Jahre fast aktuell.
10 Jahre.
Guck mal hier, 2013, das war glaube
ich,
naja, nicht ganz.
8 Jahre.
Das war eines der längsten
Konsolen-Lebenszyklen,
die es so gab. Und auch noch in
einer Zeit, wo sich game-technisch
sehr viel getan hat. Man muss aber auch
wirklich mal angucken, also auch Release
Xbox 360 Spiele sahen deutlich
schlechter aus als spätere.
Vergleicht mal das irgendwie in den letztes
Gears of War, was auf der 360 rausgekommen ist,
aber in den ersten 360 Spiele. Aber man muss
auch echt sagen, also die 360 war
zur Release so ein richtiges Power-Teil.
Wirklich mega, das Teil.
Also, für die damalige
Zeit. Deswegen hat das auch so lange gehalten.
Man darf nicht vergessen, Battlefield 3,
ja, BF3 kam irgendwann so
in dem Dreh raus, ne.
Ja, so. Wir haben noch vorhin
geguckt, mein Hirn funzt wieder nicht. 2011.
Also das kam, Battlefield
3 kam quasi
zwei Jahre vor Ende des Lebenszyklus
der Xbox 360 raus.
Und man muss sich das mal angucken.
Battlefield 3
auf der Xbox 360, ich meine, das
kannst du nicht vergleichen mit dem PC.
Wirklich nicht. Gerade nicht mit einem PC
aus dem Jahr 2011 dann.
Ein PC im Jahr 2011
war der Sache
schon
deutlich dann voraus.
Ich meine, das ist eine Konsole von 2005,
gerade in der Zeit, wo sich viel getan hat.
Aber trotzdem,
trotzdem muss man sagen,
BF3 sah auf der Xbox
360 echt ganz
brauchbar aus. Auch,
wenn man sich das heute noch anguckt.
Ich habe gestern einen Stream geguckt auf Twitch.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das finde. Genau.
Und der hat
Just for Fun mal gestern auf der Xbox gespielt,
weil es abgeschaltet wurde.
Wow, fuck.
Weil es abgeschaltet wird.
Und man muss sagen, Leute,
das sieht doch,
leider ist die Auflösung nicht
so geil,
das sieht doch durchaus,
guck mal, sogar der Wubblos ist hier am schreiben.
Kennt ihr den?
Das sieht doch
echt ganz okay aus.
Das ist ein Xbox 360 Game.
Das sieht jetzt
mal, ja, es sieht schlechter
aus. Gerade, wenn man es direkt vergleicht
mit einem PC, sieht es schlechter aus.
Und der PC läuft mit 60 FPS.
Mindestens mal 60.
Der BF3 läuft heute mit
350 FPS ohne Probleme.
Aber das sieht
durchaus okay aus.
Ja.
Und man darf jetzt nicht vergessen,
es ist auch ein bisschen pixelig durch die Bildflur.
Aber, ja, und auch hier, guck mal,
gerade das Kantenflimmern und sowas,
das war auch schon, ja.
Es wird, es wird, ähm,
ähm, wie heißt es?
Shutdown. Ja, es wird eingestellt.
Ja, Shutdown.
7. Console Servers, genau.
7. November wird Battlefield 3 für Konsole ausgeschaltet.
Das wäre ja, Leute,
soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Eine super Gelegenheit,
am 7. November
Battlefield 3
relaunched
oder sowas
rauszubringen.
Für aktuelle Konsole angepasst,
paar Bugs gefixt,
aber das wird es nicht geben.
Set Servers,
ja, ich würde es gerne tatsächlich
weitermachen, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die
Probleme, die wir das letzte Mal hatten, schon gefixt hatten.
Aber leider wird es das, leider wird es das nicht,
nicht geben.
Ja, Sadge, ja.
Leider, leider wird es das nicht geben.
Aber das wäre, das wäre doch cool, oder?
Stellt euch mal vor,
wäre es nicht geil,
am 7. November
kommt die Meldung, okay, Leute,
wir haben das Game jetzt lang genug
supported, wir schalten
die Battlefield 3 Server jetzt endgültig
ab auf der Konsole
und dann zu sagen, aber
ihr müsst nicht traurig sein,
ihr könnt es jetzt spielen, weiterhin
auf dem PC und auf den neuen Plattformen.
Und relaunchen das in der geupdateten Version.
Wie geil wäre das?
Aber es wird nicht passieren.
Also es wäre extrem geil,
aber es wird nicht passieren.
Ihr müsst euch auch mal überlegen,
die machen sich ja,
die würden sich ja selbst
Konkurrenz machen mit 2042.
Ich meine, 2042 ist ja immer noch hier.
Steam Charts,
ich meine, immerhin,
immerhin, also,
das war schon, das war schon mal deutlich
schlechter, ja. Das war schon mal deutlich
schlechter.
Wir waren hier mal runter, wobei, so viel
schlecht, naja.
Ja, es spielen wir, also,
BF1 wird, wird, wird mehr gespielt
und BF5 wird, glaube ich,
mehr gespielt als das.
Ja, bisschen mehr
und auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr spielen
Battlefield 5. Also BF5
dürfte zur Zeit das meistgespielte
Battlefield sein, was alles über
2042 aussagen dürfte,
weil, seriously, gefällt mir
prinzipiell vom Setting her,
2042 besser
als BF5,
aber 2042
hat ein Schrott Game.
So, und jetzt überlegt euch mal, wir können übrigens
nochmal Just For Fun Battlefield 4 gucken,
das sind aber nur 2000, 2000
oder, jaja. Wobei man das halt nicht direkt
vergleichen kann, weil diese,
diese Games, die gab es halt nicht
auf Steam. Die gab es erst über 10
Jahre nach Release auf Steam. Das ist
halt vielleicht ein bisschen
unfair, das zu
vergleichen und die Leute, die sich halt hier, die
haben das halt immer zu Release gekauft, ja,
die, äh, die haben das halt auf einer anderen
Plattform schon, kaufen sich das vielleicht.
Aber BF3 kannst du auch vergessen.
Spiel auf dem PC,
PC keiner, die Leute haben das kostenlos
bekommen in der, in, über Origin und so,
das kauft sich niemand auf dem PC. Aber
nichtsdestotrotz,
die würden sich, die würden auch nicht
sich selbst nochmal krass Konkurrenz machen, oder?
Überlegt mal, die vorletzten zwei
Battlefields werden schon mehr gespielt wie
2042.
So.
Warum sollten die in Battlefield 3
relaunchen?
Übrigens, es gibt ein Problem mit Battlefield 3 auf dem PC.
Äh,
äh, äh,
Battlelog.
Es gibt ein Problem, und zwar,
äh, die Server crashen.
Was man
auch daran sieht, dass
es keine Server
mehr gibt. Also die ganzen
Server, ach guck mal, doch, den gibt's wieder.
Aber es ist
kein Team Deathmatch. Also es gibt ein Problem,
und zwar haben die mit einem,
äh, mit einem
Wartungsupdate
Anfang des Jahres, irgendwann,
irgendwann im März,
haben die ein Update
für Battlelog gebracht, was,
ich kann, ich kann dir sagen,
was sie mit den gleichen Maps haben.
Die haben ein Update gebracht, was die Server kaputt macht.
Alle Server,
die wechselnde
Kartenrotations haben,
so wie der hier, crashen nach
zwei, drei
Maprotations. Du kannst
gar nicht richtig spielen.
Dass die einzigen Server, die halbwegs
stabil oben bleiben, sind die,
die nur eine Karte haben und nicht
rotatet werden muss. Und das ist,
Moment, BF3 Server Crash,
da sieht man mal,
wie DICE uns da,
uns Battlefield-Fans wieder
pickt.
Ähm,
das interessiert die halt gar nicht, ne.
Also der, der, der Threat ist übelst
lang.
Es wird das alles berichtet, ja.
Irgendwann hat einer von EA geschrieben,
dass das under
investigation ist.
This is still under investigation.
Wir reden hier vom April.
Also die Battlefield 3 Server sind
kaputt auf dem PC.
Auf der Konsole funktionieren sie
witzigerweise, da werden sie aber abgeschaltet.
Demnächst.
Ähm,
es ist seit April.
Die haben, die haben Wartungsarbeiten
gemacht. Irgendwann im April.
Und seitdem ist das kaputt.
Und das ist, man muss sich
das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, das ist für die sicherlich
ein echt
easy fix, behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal.
Darkseid, danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute,
ich hab sie gar nicht gecheckt. Das ist für die sicherlich
ein easy fix,
wenn sich da mal 1, 2 Leute
wirklich hinsetzen dürften
und sich damit mal am Nachmittag beschäftigen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es echt ein easy fix.
Aber die, die wollen nicht. Guck, das
geht jetzt ewig weiter hier und,
ähm, das ist immer noch.
Du kannst Battlefield 3
Metro spielen. Also du kannst aktuell,
wenn du es auf der Xbox hast oder PS3, kannst
du noch spielen.
Weil, die Server werden
abgeschaltet bald, auf der Konsole.
Und PC kannst du es immer noch
spielen. Wenn du einen Server hast, der nur,
der nur, guck mal mal, BF3, Battlelog,
wenn du einen Server hast, der quasi
nur Rush Metro oder sowas spielt,
dann
müsste das eigentlich halbwegs
funktionieren.
Suchen wir mal hier Rush.
Gibt es eigentlich noch irgendjemanden, der Squad Rush spielt?
Nee, oder? Tatsächlich.
Squad Rush war eigentlich ein richtig cooler
Competitive Modus. Leute, das ist,
das ist der Modus, den ich persönlich
als ein, ähm,
also als eine
Möglichkeit des
Battlefield eSports gesehen habe.
Wurde nie wirklich großartig
verfolgt. Es gab, glaube ich,
mal ne,
ne ESL
Squad Rush Liga vor 15 Jahren
oder so.
Aber Squad Rush ist echt ein Modus, wo ich
finde, der, also das ist quasi 4
gegen 4 im Endeffekt dann.
Also nicht zwangsläufig, du kannst noch
mehr spielen, aber wenn's Competitive
spielen, würdest du halt 4 gegen 4 spielen.
Oder, oder, ja.
Tja.
Weiß nicht, wie Squad Rush mit 16 Leuten funzt.
Nee, Moment, ein Squad ist nicht 4, sorry.
Wie viel, wie, wie, wie groß ist ein Squad in
BF, BF, äh, 3, 5?
Nee, 4, oder?
Nee. Leute, ich bin verwirrt.
4, ne?
4. Ja, ja, doch.
16 heiße
sind da quasi 4 Squads.
Naja. Zumindest
hätte ich das hier durchaus als Competitive
Chance mal vor ner Weile gesehen.
Für Battlefield
Competitive. Weil ich finde, das
ist ein, das Squad Rush ist ein Modus,
der repräsentiert
Battlefield ganz gut,
finde ich. Er hält das
Battlefield an sich, Battlefield
Feeling, Gameplay.
Lässt sich aber relativ taktisch Competitive
spielen. Lass mal kurz gucken, Rush,
Felix BF3 ist aber.
Okay, nee, Rush,
Rush ist kaputt zur Zeit, so wie es aussieht.
Da crashen
die, crashen die Server immer.
Sad. Sehr,
sehr sad.
Sehr, sehr sad. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da
drauf gekommen bin. Eigentlich wollte ich doch schnell mal
mein eigenes PC2 Gameplay durch
switchen und gucken, ob ich der krasse Übersniper
bin. Guck mal, da ist er.
Oh, das war kein Headshot.
Ich script da mal kurz durch. Ich will gucken, ob ich noch irgendwas
auf die Reihe gekriegt hab in diesem Gameplay.
Davon haben wir uns sidetracken lassen.
Bam.
Da kommt er.
Die Leute hatten damals auch echt Reaktionszeiten
echt jenseits von Gut und Böse.
Vorne in die Eier gesniped. Hier hat man
wieder gesehen. War das Auto-Aim wieder?
War das wieder Auto-Aim?
Kannst du sagen, Leute, oder?
Auto-Aim oder war der, oder hatte ich den einfach
schon gut in der Mitte?
Doch, doch, guck mal. Das Auto-Aim
ein bisschen. Dieses, das, das,
das ACOG-Visier war auf der Konsole
bekannt dafür.
Zu Auto-Aimen.
Wenn man quickscoped.
Oder sind meine krassen Sniper-Skills.
Was für ein Setting
hättest du am meisten Bock in Battlefield,
äh, im Modern-Warfare-Setting?
Hätte ich tatsächlich am meisten Bock drauf.
Und nicht so Future
gehaucht wie 2042, sondern wirklich
im Modern-Warfare-Setting.
Und wisst ihr, was ich cool fände, wenn das
halt irgendwie
nen Bezug hätte zu heute?
Ich meine damit nicht, dass man irgendwelche super krass
kontroversen Sachen machen sollte. Die haben ja damals in der
Kampagne ein bisschen was versucht.
Sondern irgendwas, was halt wieder ein bisschen Bezug
zu heute hat.
Ja, also von den
Fahrzeugen, die es gibt. Von den Waffen, die es gibt.
Vielleicht auch von den Maps, wo man
das Ganze ansiedelt. Es gibt ja
leider Gottes genug
Kriegsschauplätze auf der Welt,
wo man sich vielleicht Inspiration auch für
ne Battlefield-Game dran holen könnte.
Das hat Battlefield 3 gut gemacht. Also Battlefield 3
muss man sagen, das Game an sich
war nicht realistisch vom Gameplay her.
Aber das gesamte Feeling fand ich
doch sehr nah dran gemacht.
Die hatten die Waffensounds, haben sie alle
aufgenommen. Die haben damals
sich beraten lassen, was
ähm
in so nem Einsatz gesagt wird. Deswegen ist
ja auch dieses Chatter zwischen den
Soldaten, so dieses automatische
Gelabere, was in Battlefield 3
kommt.
Ähm, also was
die Soldaten in Battlefield 3 so untereinander zu sich
sagen, das, das ist,
das würden die, das würden die heute überhaupt nicht mehr
sagen. Guck mal, in Battlefield 3
sagen die, I get fucked in the
ass over here. Das wär heute schon
super krass homophob
und das Spiel würde dafür geshitstormt.
Wenn das in nem Game heute drin vorkommt.
Das war, aber ich finde in Battlefield 3,
das war, aber ich finde in Battlefield 3
waren das durchaus
realistische Sachen, die ich mir
durchaus vorstellen könnte,
dass die im Eifer des Gefechts gesagt werden.
Und das haben sie dann nachher schon runter
gedreht, ne, aber
ich find Battlefield 3 war da wirklich, war da
wirklich sehr nah dran. Das fand ich,
das fand ich gut gemacht in Battlefield 3.
Die haben die, ähm,
die haben die Waffensounds aufgenommen
und die haben sich
inspirieren lassen so von wie sich das
in echt verhält, ohne dass es
irgendwie in
Simulation abdriftet,
was es ja wirklich nicht war. Guckt euch mal die
Jetfights. Also ich finde Jetfights ist
ein gutes Beispiel für
wie gut sie das gelöst haben oder wie gut sie
das mal lösen konnten
in Battlefield. Jetfights
haben einen gewissen Hauch von Realismus.
Gerade das du gucken musst, ähm,
ja, so
wie nennen wir das mal so Energiemanagement
so ja. Also wie hoch bist du,
wie schnell wirst du durchstroppen. Du musstest
ja möglichst, möglichst
mit korrektem Speed turnen,
dass du den Gegner da vorkriegst. Also Jetfights
hatten so den Hauch
des Realen in Battlefield 3
wo man sagt, wo man sich sagt,
okay, sie haben sich da schon ein bisschen angeguckt
was würden so Jetfights in echt ausmachen.
Gut, ich meine in echt, in echt
ist es eh komplett unsinnig zum größten Teil.
Da passieren, da sehen
Fights zwischen Jets
im Leben nicht so aus wie in Battlefield 3.
In echt,
wenn ihr euch da mal irgendwelche Einsatzsachen
durchliest oder so, sind Flugzeugfights
vorbei, bevor die sich überhaupt gesehen haben.
Ja.
Also wer den Gegner zuerst auf
dem Radar sieht und wer die besten Raketen
hat, gewinnt in der Regel.
Also so diese Sache
in Battlefield 3, man kreist
zwei Minuten um sich, um
sich dann abzuschießen, ist
sehr selten in echt. Ja.
Aber,
wenn solche Situationen mal vorkommen,
da haben sie sich, und ich finde das hat man in Battlefield 3
gut gesehen, Battlefield 4 auch,
haben sie sich schon inspirieren lassen von
du musst schon ein bisschen
gucken, dass du
so dein, ich weiß nicht wie man das nennt, so irgendwie
ich glaube, man nennt das irgendwie so eine Art
Power oder Energiemanagement, so quasi
dass du dann halt, dass du halt
nicht steigst und
Geschwindigkeit verlierst und wie auch immer.
Das haben sie, das haben sie denke ich gut umgesetzt
in Battlefield 3, wenn halt auch nicht
auf Simulation getrimmt.
Das finde ich, das war genau die
Stärke mit von Battlefield.
Es hatte eben die Atmosphäre
von Battlefield,
aber es war halt immer noch
ein gut spielbares
Game und keine Simulation. Also es ist,
genau, es ist kein Arma gewesen, ja.
Es hatte, es hatte die Atmosphäre,
aber es war ein gut spielbares
Multiplayer-Game mit auch
total viel unrealistischen Elementen.
Ich meine, überlegt mal, wie realistisch ist es,
dass einer mit einem Defibrillator
fünf Mal
hintereinander nach lebensgefährlicher
Verletzung wiederbelebt wird.
Nur mit dem Defi, einfach dranhalten
so, so bam,
durchlöchert, pssst,
Defi, alles wieder gut, ja.
Ist halt, aber
das hat, das war finde ich so die große Stärke
und dass es einfach
eingebettet war, und das fand ich halt
in Battlefield 3 auch gut,
in ein realistisches
Szenario drumherum.
Wo das eben immersive, wie man so schön war,
sagt. Ja, Defi nach dem,
ja, du bist aus dem Panzer rausgesprungen,
der Panzer explodiert in Battlefield 3,
du stirbst durch die Panzerexplosion,
da kommt ein Typ mit dem Defi,
retzt dich, und du rennst weiter, als wäre
nie was gewesen. Ja, war jetzt äußerst realistisch.
Lass mich mal kurz mein Sniper-Gameplay vorspulen.
Wir machen einfach, Leute, wisst ihr was wir machen?
Wir machen einfach Wiedergabe-Geschwindigkeit
mal zwei. Da können wir uns das Game
in schnell angucken. Ich kann meinem
Sniper-Gameplay noch ein bisschen huldigen, und dann
sind wir in zwei Minuten durch.
Mich interessiert, ah, oh!
Das war Spawn, die Spawn-Protection
in BC2, ja, die war krass.
Die sind gespawnt,
du musstest ungefähr abschätzen, wann die
Spawn-Protection abläuft.
Voll in der Ask-Schule hier. Guck mal hier!
Achievement unlocked.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Achievement ist.
Ach, das ist dieser Spezial-Skin,
oder? Ach nee,
Get All Awards. Okay.
Ich hab anscheinend schon oft genug,
oft genug, was ist denn da, was ist denn da drinnen?
Du hast mich geteabagged.
Hast mich daraufhin gebannt.
Hahaha!
Nice.
Schön, dass du da bist, ja.
Was sind denn die Achievements
dafür? DLC ist
no longer available, okay.
Was gibt, was braucht man dafür für Achievements?
Spec Ops Recon Elite.
Ja, okay, keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer. Egal. Ich will jetzt mal kurz
gucken, wie krass ich hier noch am Schneipsern bin.
Ich mein, wir sind Rush-Attacker.
Wir müssten quasi jetzt einfach
nur durchrennen, dass wir
alles packen, so. Aber, guck mal, wir haben,
wir haben die erste Ba... Leute, kann das sein?
Seriously? Ich hab mal ne ernst gemeinte
Frage. Ich steh hier seit, ich bin
noch nicht einmal gestorben, glaub ich, oder? Bis jetzt.
Ich steh, doch einmal bin ich gestorben.
Ich sehe, ich stehe seit 8 Minuten
am M-Com. Ich hab
ein M-Com gelegt.
Wo ist mein Team?
Die ganze Zeit.
Wo sind die eigentlich grade?
Ernst gemeinte Frage.
Wo ist, wo ist eigentlich mein Team grade?
Da guckt er raus, guck mal hier. Bäm.
Afge im Spawn, ja.
Ich glaub, dass mein Team kreiselt im Helikopter
und springt ab und zu raus
und wird gefarmt. Ich glaube, jetzt versuch ich
das andere M-Com noch zu leg... Nee, nee.
Ich trau mich nicht. Er ist aber auch scheiße als Sniper.
Ohne jeglichen Support da vorne.
Bäm. Hier wieder gequickscoped.
Zack, vorbei.
Bäm, in the ass.
Ich glaube, ich versuch es jetzt zu legen.
Ich glaube, ich versuch es jetzt zu legen, aber...
Alter, ich rasiere
die ja so krass.
Oh nee, ich glaub, jetzt sterb ich gleich.
Sad girl.
Zweiter Tod insgesamt.
Guck ich, guck ich nochmal auf
Gliederbo... auf gleich zwischendurch auf die Stats?
Naja, ich bin zu angestrengt.
Jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, was
die, jetzt weiß ich, was meine Teammates machen.
Die fliegen Heli und Snipern
vom Arsch der Welt
in die Gegner rein. Verstehe.
Jetzt weiß ich, was die machen. Aber wir
haben, wir haben einen Eng... Ist das ein Engineer?
Wir haben einen Engineer. Der sitzt wahrscheinlich im Heli gerade.
Bäm. Alter, die werden schon echt hart rasiert.
Da, guck mal, guck mal. Da sind drei
Stück abgesprungen. Die rennen jetzt bestimmt zur WM kommen.
Da gab es keinen
Skill-Based-Matchmaking. Ja, so spaßig
kann ein Game ohne Skill-Based-Matchmaking sein, ne?
Da kommt einer. Zack, in the ass.
Next.
Sag mal, sind die alle drei instant gestorben?
Jetzt hier, die Teammates?
Ich glaub schon.
Instant dead ge...
Oh nee. Kann man kurz
ausspulen.
Oh nee, nochmal dead.
Oh, da ist ein Panzer jetzt.
Ich glaube, ich habe kein C4 dabei. Habe ich C4 dabei?
Oh, jetzt sterbe ich aber öfters
hier. Was habe ich geswitcht jetzt?
Aha, andere Scope.
Ich dachte mir, Leute,
mein krasser Scope-Ausstellungsmus
wieder anstatt...
Ja, jetzt pushen sie schon in unseren Spawn rein.
Versuche ich den zu C4-en
jetzt gleich? Nee, nee, nee.
Ich versuche nochmal durchzukommen.
Ich glaube, das wird nichts. Guck mal. Wir werden, wir werden
in drei Minuten sicherlich nicht,
sicherlich nicht die Map gewinnen.
Nee, ich sterbe jetzt nur noch ein paar Mal und dann ist es vorbei,
denke ich mal. Ja.
Hier versuche ich es nochmal. Vier Tickets nochmal
irgendwie auf das M kommen.
So schnell wie es geht irgendwie nochmal auf das M
kommen.
Also ganz ehrlich, an mir hat es nicht gelegen
die Runde.
41-8, Schneiber-Stelz.
Das war, ey, das, ohne Mist, das war für die damalige
Zeit ein richtig krasses Gameplay.
Richtig, richtig nice.
Man konnte, guck mal, guck mal,
die ganzen Pins.
Die, ja, das war damals so, wenn man
zu viele Pins hatte,
waren die letzten Pins gebackt.
Oh Mann.
Wie bin ich jetzt nur da drauf gekommen, Leute?
Richtiges Oldschool-Zeug.
Okay.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Geht schnell.
So, wieder am Start.
Ja, über das Thema Skill-Based Matchmaking
habe ich wieder vorher ausgelassen. Ich verstehe, warum
es gemacht wird. Ich bin trotzdem kein Fan von.
Ne, ich glaube, es ist genau das
Gegenteil der Fall.
Weil, ohne Skill-Based
Matchmaking, da wusstest du, okay,
du kannst auch mal
dich ein bisschen entspannen, mal ein bisschen was ausprobieren.
Die, wir können das jetzt anscheinend
mit Skill-Based Matchmaking hast du immer so den Druck,
du kannst jetzt nur
Metabills spielen, du musst jetzt quasi
immer hundertprozentig auf, zack,
das ist einfach super krass anstrengend.
Ohne SBMM hattest
du so manche Games, wo du das Gefühl hattest,
ey, da geht richtig gut was, da warst du voll
fokussiert, hast voll alles gegeben, hast dich voll reingehängt.
Aber die letzten Games hast du normal
gespielt. Skill-Based Matchmaking ist
immer so
übelst anstrengend die ganze
Zeit. Deswegen, ich
kann ohne Probleme,
sagen wir, MW1, MW2, das Ort
das echte, by the way,
mit dem Fabian, mit dem Frasier
irgendwie 8 Stunden oder so auf der
Konsole gefühlt spielen am Tag, kein Problem.
Mit SBMM kriege
ich das 1-2
Stunden hin, dann kann ich nicht mehr.
Spätestens.
So. Darum wird schlecht über
Trade Republic geredet. Ich bin mal
scalable, wird da auch schlecht drüber geredet?
So, also Chat meint, dass ihr
Job-Einstieg als Softwareentwickler bei SAP
bei SAP.
Na, ob der
ABAP programmiert gleich?
Okay.
Was gar nicht passieren darf, ist, dass mir
eben ein Fehler unterläuft. Gerade bin ich
maximal nervös, ja.
First aim is to provide instant recommendations.
Ich hoffe, dass ich jetzt positives
Feedback von Ralf bekomme.
Dieses Klischee vom
Nerd entspricht jetzt nicht unbedingt der Realität.
Ich weiß nicht, also wenn ich mich so
umgucke, doch schon. Gerade die Leute, die
was taugen, da ist schon ein
hoher Anteil von Kellerkindern
wie ich dabei.
Hallo, ich bin Jonas und ich arbeite
als Softwareentwickler im Norden
von München bei SAP. Heute
werde ich eine neue Funktion für unser Produkt
als Signavio Process Intelligence entwickeln.
Und das ist für mich
eine Herausforderung, weil ich die Aufgabe im Detail
noch nicht kenne und es eben auch bis morgens
16 Uhr fertig werden muss.
Deadline!
Das ist definitiv ein Ritual von mir.
Also so ein Kaffee hilft mir einfach dabei, wirklich
dann Lust aufs Programmieren nochmal mehr zu spüren.
Tja, ich trinke keinen
Kaffee. Das
fällt mir jedes Mal auf. Ich bin einer der wenigen,
die in der IT keinen Kaffee trinken.
Und ich meine, ich trinke
ja doppelt wenig Kaffee.
Es gibt kaum Fahrradfahrer, die keinen Kaffee trinken
und kaum IT-Leute, die keinen Kaffee trinken.
Und ich bin beides in Kombination und trinke keinen Kaffee.
Das ist aber auch sehr generic, oder?
Software optimieren,
die SAP-Kunden hilft, ihre Daten zu analysieren.
Das kann einfach alles bedeuten.
Die Aufgaben eines Softwareentwicklers
werden typischerweise...
Das ist ein guter Stuhl.
Der sieht...
Der sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie
mein Stuhl.
Ist es aber nicht. Nee, nee, ist es nicht.
Wenn das der ist,
die Lehne von dem sieht. Aber das ist auch ein anderer.
Das ist ein anderer als der hier.
Der sieht fast ein bisschen aus
wie mein Stuhl. Nicht ganz von den
Armen. Fast ein bisschen
modernere Variante von meinem.
Bürostühle größer Gaming...
Jajaja, auf jeden Fall.
Die Aufgaben eines
Softwareentwicklers werden typischerweise...
Ah, der da unten.
Ist das die Ubuntu-Uhr? Nee, oder?
Chat.
Was ist das da unten? Was sehe ich da?
Nee, das ist Windows. Der Windows-Login-Screen, oder?
Ganz normale Windows-Login-Screen.
Das ist nicht Ubuntu-Uhr.
Windows 11, ja.
Entwickler werden typischerweise
in sogenannten Tickets...
Mac?
Sieht das aus wie ein Mac auf den ersten Blick?
Typischerweise in sogenannten Tickets
strukturiert.
Dort steht dann einfach drin, was genau erledigt
werden muss. Und was ich jetzt hier hinzufügen soll,
ist eben die Funktion Greatest.
Das bedeutet, wir haben einen
Tabellen-Layout, ähnlich wie
man das auch aus Excel kennt.
Moment. SAP
kann nicht...
Das größte Element irgendwo
standardmäßig?
Diese Funktion soll es eben möglich machen, dass man
zeilenweise den
maximalen Wert aus verschiedenen
Zellen selektieren kann. Das gibt es nicht standardmäßig?
Die Vorgabe, die ich jetzt für die Funktion habe, ist, dass ich
bis morgen 16 Uhr ungefähr fertig sein sollte.
Wenn ich mich jetzt
tatsächlich mal richtig konzentrieren möchte,
dann höre ich eben sehr gerne Musik.
Das hilft mir einfach dabei, dann die anderen Kollegen
auszublenden und wirklich nur an den Call zu denken.
Verstehe ich.
Ist das Rust?
Ja!
Es ist Rust am Start.
Blazingly fast
hier, Leute.
Krustentiere am Start.
Was gar nicht passieren darf, ist, dass mir eben
ein Fehler unterläuft, also die Funktion
falsche Ergebnisse liefert. Wenn es dann einmal in
Produktion gelangt und wirklich Kunden darauf
zugestimmt wird.
Ich meine, das ist ja glücklicherweise was.
So nach dem Motto, gibt immer den größten Wert aus.
Das kann man ja glaube ich jetzt,
ich weiß nicht, wie es im SAP-Umfeld ist,
aber ich würde sagen,
das lässt sich doch noch ganz gut testen,
ja auch mit viel Input,
ob das denn dann funzt.
Das darf eben nicht passieren, dass da irgendwelche Fehler
wirklich in den Produktivcode kommen.
Ich versuche mich jetzt an verschiedenen anderen
Funktionen zu orientieren,
wie ich das eben schon in der Vergangenheit gemacht habe.
Ich sage Overflow, Copy, Paste und so ist gut.
Ja, dann werde ich quasi verschiedene Dateien
editieren und das dann quasi einmal
komplett durch die Codebasis
durchziehen, sodass dann
am Ende auch die Funktion aufgerufen wird,
wenn man jetzt sie eingibt.
So ein großes Ding?
Createst?
Das klingt jetzt nach,
weiß nicht, so
vier, fünf Zeilen,
vielleicht noch ein Test und
irgendwo in irgendwelchen
XMLs oder so reinschreiben,
dass es die Funktion jetzt gibt wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es übrigens, lustige Story,
ich musste noch letzte Woche eine Schulung machen
für so eine Software.
Der Grund, warum ich die Schulung machen muss,
ist relativ einfach.
Die war witzigerweise zum
größten Teil, was heißt zum größten Teil, die war
komplett unter Windows.
Die haben die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken
quasi gefunden, dieser Softwarehersteller,
denn der Softwarehersteller
sagt, nur Leute,
die die Schulung bei uns,
die offizielle Schulung besucht haben,
nur die dürfen das Produkt benutzen
und nur die dürfen Supporttickets aufmachen.
Das heißt, ich mache die Schulung einzig und allein,
um die Schulung gemacht zu haben, offiziell,
in dem Sinn. Die Schulung war nicht schlecht
oder so, kann man sagen, war gar nicht übel gemacht.
Der Trainer hat sich Mühe gegeben,
aber es war schon teilweise
echt, echt, naja,
bisschen langweilig.
Die Übungen
waren halt auch so,
Tipp halt einfach mal ab.
Und irgendwann
hat der Trainer erzählt,
ja, und wenn dieses Produkt
das dann quasi nicht kann,
gibt es auch noch die Möglichkeiten,
Plugins zu erstellen.
Und da habe ich dann gefragt, ach ja, das ist ja interessant,
in welcher Programmiersprache
sind denn
vier Tage, vier Tage,
Dienstag bis Freitag,
in welcher Sprache sind denn
diese Plugins programmiert?
Und jetzt dürft ihr raten,
was die Antwort war.
Wir reden hier von einer Hardcore Business Enterprise.
Die Antwort
ist aber so bescheuert, dass ihr wahrscheinlich...
Ne.
Dan2Dev, danke für den Sub.
Geht es dir nicht so an? Ne, ne.
Leute, ihr seid alle falsch, ihr seid alle falsch,
ihr seid alle falsch, ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch.
Ich sag's euch.
XML.
Dann habe ich auch erst mal verdutzt geguckt
und ja, die haben
echt irgend so einen XML-Dialekt,
wo du ganz viel Zeug
drinnen definieren kannst.
Unter anderem
auch Logik irgendwie in
XML
definieren kannst.
Und du brauchst
für so gut wie nix irgendwie wirklich
eine echte Programmiersprache.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Was der Nachteil davon ist,
dass keine Sau durchblickt,
würde ich jetzt einfach mal sagen.
Ich habe es mir nicht weiter angeguckt.
Bei XML war die Sache bei mir schon
abgehakt, ja.
Genauso, wo er mir erzählt hat, wo ich auch
bisschen gecringed habe,
wo der Trainer meinte
so, ja, und
wenn die Software dafür keine Integration
hat, dann
erstellen wir auf Anfrage auch ein
AutoIT-Skript, was das macht.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Moment, AutoIT?
Ist das nicht so ein Hack
Windows, gehackte
Windows, na gehackt ist ein falsches Wort,
so eine Hacky
Windows-Automatisierung,
wenn mal nix besseres einem übrig
bleibt, als Button und Maus-Inputs
zu simulieren?
Also eine ordentliche Integration ist
für mich kein AutoIT-Skript.
Eine ordentliche Integration ist bei mir
was, was eben
Teil der Software ist
und eine andere Software
über die offizielle
Schnittstelle dieser anderen Software
anspricht. Und nicht
wir haben ein AutoIT-Skript,
was dann
quasi automatisiert
Copy-Paste macht aus einer anderen
Software und sowas.
Wir reden hier von
ultra-teurer
Business-Enterprise-Software.
Und was der Trainer
auch gesagt hat, der war echt nicht
schlecht, dem habe ich auch volle Punktzahl
gegeben. Und was der Trainer auch gesagt
hat, er wollte uns natürlich die
Zertifizierung schmackhaft machen.
Die haben echt den Infinite Money,
das haben die auch. Der wollte uns
die Zertifizierung schmackhaft machen und zwar
eine Begründung,
dass wenn man ein Zertifikat hat für
diese Software und wenn man das
in seinem LinkedIn-Profil einträgt,
da bekommt man sofort
Anfragen auf
LinkedIn dafür, weil das so
beliebt ist. Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter,
du kannst auf LinkedIn
das größte Bullshit-Profil
machen und hast einen Tag
später 20 Anfragen. Ich meine
sogar Peter
Aguilé, der
natürlich ganz offen
berichtlich ein realer Account ist,
mit echtem Foto
bekommt sinnlose Anfragen.
Leider habe
ich das Login für den Account nicht mehr.
Leider habe ich das Login nicht mehr.
Würde mich mal interessieren,
was da... Ich habe das
höchstwahrscheinlich auch mit irgendeiner
10-Minute-Mail
erstellt oder so und
das Profilbild...
Ja, deswegen finde ich halt witzig, weil auf
LinkedIn sind die halt alle so super business unterwegs.
...
Ja, na gut.
Gucken wir uns jetzt das Video fertig an.
Ich glaube, Leute,
ich glaube, es wird echt Zeit.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Erstelle ich mir nachher und dann
mit einem E-Mail-Account,
den ich wiederfinde.
Der braucht aber ein gutes Profilbild dann.
Der nimmt einfach... Guck mal.
Peter Aguilé
hat dieses
eine Anime
Girl, aber diese Szene
besteht daraus zwei.
Es gibt einmal diese Ayaya
und
dann gibt es die Aya.
Wenn ihr das mal gesehen habt.
Ich kenne auch nur diese eine Szene.
Die müsste eigentlich dann die andere nehmen.
Als Profilbild.
Normalstes-IT-Guy-Discord.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal das Video fertig.
Weil, jetzt werden wir hier
ein bisschen Allgemeinbildung treiben.
Wer nicht weiß, um was es bei
dieser ganzen Ayaya-Intensifies-Sache
geht.
Da geht es darum, dass eine
britische Austauschschülerin in einer
japanischen Schule voll gedisst wird.
Ne, umgedreht.
Dass eine britische Austauschschülerin
eine japanische
Schülerin voll disst in einer japanischen Schule.
Und man erkennt die daran,
dass sie natürlich eine
britische Flagge
als Schuluniform trägt.
Logisch. Wer kennt die?
Wer kennt es nicht?
Die Austauschschülerin, die eine
britische Flagge als Schuluniform
trägt. Logisch.
Und
die japanische Schülerin sagt,
dass sie mit Namen Aya heißt.
Und
die Japaner hängen an sowas immer noch
ein Ja dran. Das heißt, es wird aus
Aya, wird Ayaya.
Oder wird Aya.
Und
daraufhin fängt die wie verrückt an
Ayaya zu brüllen.
Was auch immer.
Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid.
Nein.
Wir gucken das Video jetzt fertig.
Noted Chat, oder?
Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid.
Wir müssen diese Bildungslücke
für euch schließen.
Ayaya.
Ayaya intensifies.
Genau.
Das ist Ayaya.
Okay?
Und sie wird jetzt dafür verarscht,
dass die Japaner nicht Ayaya
sagen, sondern Ayaya.
Oder Ayaya. Irgendwie so komisch.
Und deswegen schreit die jetzt wie verrückt
Ayaya rum. Also eigentlich
wird die voll gemobbt gerade.
Ayaya.
Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid.
Und jetzt können wir das Video weiter gucken.
Jetzt wird programmiert.
Okay. Rust wird programmiert.
Rust wird programmiert.
Also wie gesagt,
für mich sieht das jetzt nicht so kompliziert aus,
eine Funktion zu schreiben,
die greatest,
also die größten Werte
aus einer Reihe von Elementen
zurückliefert.
Nachdem der Patrick jetzt auch da ist,
der wird das wahrscheinlich in Assembler in 10 Zeilen
basteln.
Oder in 3 Zeilen in C.
Ich mein, im Prinzip musst du alle Werte durchgehen
und gucken, ob du noch einen größeren Wert
findest.
Als den aktuellen Wert.
Wenn die unsortiert sind.
Wenn die Werte sortiert wären.
Wobei, da kannst du das vergessen.
Dann nimmst du einfach immer den letzten.
Gibt es noch was besseres, Chat?
Das ist natürlich nur ein Examen.
Gibt es noch was effektiveres als das,
was mir so spontan einfällt?
Immer quasi von Anfang bis Ende durchgehen
und sich immer den aktuell größten Wert merken.
Und wenn du am Ende bist,
hast du den größten Wert gefunden.
Gibt es da noch was besseres?
Aber jetzt müssen wir mal fertig gucken.
Natürlich könnte man das Ganze auch
multithreaded machen.
Einmal von vorne und einmal von hinten.
Dann jeweils die größten Werte sich merken
und am Ende nochmal einen Vergleich.
Das lässt sich sogar relativ gut multithreaden.
Das ist eigentlich
ein Stück weit schon ein Klischee.
Ich bin in einer ländlichen Region
groß geworden, wo ich eben mit Freunden
sehr viel online gezockt habe.
Unter anderem dann Modifikationen
für Minecraft und Arma installiert habe.
Und ja, so kam es dann.
Wie kann ich meine eigenen Mods schreiben?
Und darüber habe ich dann auch
am Start programmieren gelernt.
Es ist ein Ziel von mir,
mich weiter technisch zu spezialisieren
und dann eben noch mehr technische
Verantwortung auch übernehmen zu können.
Und deshalb ist es dann mein Ziel,
dass ich in zwei, drei Jahren
auch zum Senior-Entwickler befördert werde.
Gut, dann gibt es auch mehr
Kohle.
Ich gehe jetzt in das Daily Meeting.
Also ich habe ja auch Kollegen,
die in Berlin und Walldorf sitzen.
Dann mal gucken,
ob die agil sind und sich nicht hinsetzen
beim Daily.
Es ist einfach notwendig, dass wir uns jeden Tag austauschen,
wo jetzt jeder gerade dran arbeitet
und ob es da irgendwelche Hürden gibt.
Ach ne, die machen das Remote.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Ja, ob einfach alles glatt läuft.
Okay, die sitzen auch. Sehr gut.
Wenigstens nicht fake agil, um agil zu sein.
Und Chat,
ihr habt übrigens recht gehabt,
das ist ein Mac.
In meinem Alltag als Software-Entwickler
verbringe ich ca. 70% der Zeit
mit dem Programmieren.
Und die restlichen 30%
sind zwischen Meetings
und Weiterbildung geteilt.
So yeah, as you can see,
I just pulled the greatest function
into To-Do.
So I'm currently working on it,
getting it implemented.
And yeah, if I have any trouble
getting it implemented,
then I'll of course reach out
to the next developer,
that's obviously very important
as a Software-Entwickler.
And in an international company
like SAP
it's also normal
that someone comes along
and speaks only English
and that's normal
that we stop meetings
in English.
Oh, I get it.
But you have to ask yourself
whether we should
noch einen gewissen Reibungsverlust,
wenn du irgendwie
zehn Native-Speaker hast und die müssen sich dann
alle zwingen. Man könnte ja sagen, okay, dann lernt man's
besser.
Ja, müssen die wissen.
Das bedeutet, ich hab noch eine halbe Stunde bis zum
Mittagessen.
Ja, ich glaube, in der Zeit liege ich eigentlich relativ gut.
Dann denke ich, schaffe ich das bis morgen.
Aus meiner Sicht hat Programmieren auf jeden Fall
auch einen... Guck mal, der ist nur so glücklich,
weil er in Rust programmieren darf.
Also ich bin jetzt keiner
der irgendwelche krassen Bilder malt,
aber es ist eben
schon notwendig, dass man jetzt mit
einer Problemstellung auch verschiedene
Lösungsansätze entwickeln kann. Nichtsdestotrotz
sollte man natürlich auch analytische
Fähigkeiten mitbringen. Und jetzt im
Beruf habe ich auch die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man eben
sehr kommunikativ sein muss, um
eben auch seine eigenen Ideen richtig
rüberbringen zu können. Lass mal essen gehen.
Davon wird man
aber nicht pepofett. Das sieht viel zu gesund aus.
Dieses Klischee vom Nerd
entspricht jetzt nicht unbedingt
der Realität. Also wir arbeiten natürlich
im Team und da findet einfach eine Menge
Austausch statt. Da wird eben auch mal Privates
diskutiert.
Ja gut, was willst du auch sonst die ganze Zeit machen?
Ja, ab und zu mal ein paar
so, ja und hier, was weiß ich,
äh, wie geht's,
wie geht's deiner Katze
oder irgendwas?
Das Tischständespielen,
das ist natürlich auch zur Erholung, um
dann eben mal, ja, weg vom Bildschirm...
Ist das Arbeitszeit oder nicht?
...um zu kommen und sich ein bisschen körperlich zu betätigen.
Das könnte
auch nur ein bisschen Show für den Videobeitrag sein.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich
die Auswahl hätte, guck mal, da entsteht sogar
eine Playstation oder was auch immer, wahrscheinlich.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
eine halbe Stunde
Tischtennis mittags noch spielen oder eine halbe Stunde
früher heimgehen, dann würde ich
auf jeden Fall
eine halbe Stunde früher heimgehen.
Sehr schön. Wir haben knapp
gewonnen, aber ich denke, wir müssen einfach noch
mehr Mittagspause und so verbringen.
Dann wird's noch...
Gibt es Gran Turismo überhaupt auf der Xbox?
Besser.
Als nächstes muss ich eine Präsentation vorbereiten,
die jetzt in circa eine Stunde ansteht.
Und dafür werde ich jetzt in den Meetingraum gehen.
Es ist natürlich absolut nicht unüblich, dass ich
meine Arbeitsergebnisse präsentiere.
Aber für mich ist es definitiv was Besonderes,
das in diesem größeren Rahmen zu präsentieren.
Und ja, also viele meiner Kollegen sehen mich dann jetzt
dort zum ersten Mal in einer Präsentation.
Und dementsprechend möchte ich auch einen guten Eindruck hinterlassen.
Guten Eindruck hinterlassen ist nie verkehrt.
Du weißt nie, wo du die Leute mal wieder siehst,
wer da irgendwie dabei sitzt, der mal über irgendwas entscheidet.
Deswegen, ich habe es schon oft genug gesagt,
coole Sachen machen ist das eine.
Aber dann auch drüber reden, dass man coole Sachen gemacht hat,
ist im Business-Umfeld einfach wichtig.
Besser als weiterhin gute Sachen machen.
Ja, wenn man einfach Hälfte der Zeit gute Sachen macht,
die andere Hälfte der Zeit darauf verwendet, zu erzählen,
dass man gute Sachen gemacht hat,
steht man unterm Schnitt, unterm Strich und im Schnitt besser da,
als wenn man 100 Prozent der Zeit geile Sachen macht.
Klingt doof, ist aber so.
Das sieht so okay aus.
Okay, also jetzt der Punkt nochmal.
Additionally, we want to assist our customers,
including those in non-technical roles.
Our aim is to provide instant recommendations.
Da wird spioniert hier. Guck mal.
Instant recommendations for redesigning processes.
Ja, ich wurde jetzt gerade von einer Kollegin gefragt,
ob ich spontan mich zu einem Kaffee treffen kann.
Und ich glaube, das nehme ich jetzt auch mit.
Einfach nochmal abchecken, was bei der Kollegin geht.
Hallo, Selina. Na, wie geht's?
Die wird uns jetzt wahrscheinlich auch irgendwas zeigen,
was so cool ist an diesem SAP-Standort.
100 pro.
Gut, freut mich, dass es noch geklappt hat.
Ja.
So, ach, wir haben ja zufällig auch eine kostenlose Kaffeebar oder irgendwas.
Wenn die da jetzt 100 pro, 100 pro kommt Werbung für den Standort indirekt wieder.
Spontan.
Ja, mir kommt das auch echt gelegen, dass du mir nochmal geschrieben hast.
Ja.
Also ich habe jetzt gleich eine Präsentation um 16 Uhr.
Und da ist das eigentlich die perfekte Ablenkung, um nochmal ein bisschen...
Bist du aufgeregt?
SAP-Placement.
Ich würde nicht sagen Placement, aber die gucken schon,
dass sie in solchen Beiträgen gut dastehen, ja.
Das erste Mal vor so 20, 30 Leuten, auch außerhalb des Teams.
Okay.
Ja, hoffentlich kommt es gut an.
Bestimmt.
Irgendwie machen die nicht den Eindruck,
da sitzen die da gerade freiwillig, oder?
Da hat doch irgendjemand gesagt, ja, wir müssen...
Macht doch nochmal irgendein lockeres Gespräch in der Cafeteria.
Nee.
Hat sich bestimmt lange darauf vorbereitet.
Dann wird das schon...
Ja, also es sind jetzt noch 10 Minuten bis zum...
Warum es da so leer ist?
Weil die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich arbeiten und von diesem ganzen Kram gar keinen Gebrauch
machen.
Meeting.
Jetzt kommt natürlich nochmal die Nervosität hoch, weil gleich wird es ernst.
Ey, jetzt geht's los.
Ich habe gerade keine Ahnung, wo er ist.
Also ich muss ihn jetzt gerade erstmal suchen.
Ganz ehrlich?
Pech gehabt.
Den würde ich nicht suchen.
Ich würde es entweder absagen, wenn er zugesagt hat, er kommt nicht.
Würde ich sagen, ja, ohne den müssen wir es leider ausfallen lassen.
Aber ich würde mich nicht darum kümmern, dass der Typ beikommt zum Meeting.
Ganz ehrlich.
Einladung ist da.
Einladung ist bekannt.
Der hat angenommen.
Der hat gefälligst da zu sein.
Wenn dann der da ist und er ist wirklich essential dafür, warten wir 5 Minuten, vielleicht
noch 10 Minuten, schwätzt ein bisschen mit den Leuten.
Und ansonsten kann man sagen, gut, der hat keinen Sinn, müssen wir das nochmal machen.
Wenn er da ist und er ist wirklich essential dafür, warten wir 5 Minuten, vielleicht noch
10 Minuten, schwätzt ein bisschen mit den Leuten.
Und ansonsten kann man sagen, gut, der hat keinen Sinn, müssen wir das nochmal machen.
Sagt man ab oder man macht es einfach und er ist nicht dabei.
Ist er nicht sogar nur Azubi?
Ich habe es jetzt, ich habe, achso.
Ne, Job einschieben, das ist auch verbleibend.
Ja, okay, in der Probezeit sollte man vielleicht noch nicht, aber ich finde trotzdem, dass
es einen guten Anspruch hat, dass man sich auf die andere Seite stellt, dass man sich
wirklich mit den Leuten beschäftigt.
Also der Typ, der er ist und der hat gefälligst da zu sein, der hat angenommen, der hat gefälligst
da zu sein, der hat angenommen, der hat gefälligst da zu sein, der hat gefälligst da
zu sein, der hat gefälligst da zu sein, der hat gefälligst da zu sein.
Und ansonsten kann man sagen, gut, hat keinen Sinn, müssen wir es nochmal machen.
Sagt man ab oder man macht es einfach und er ist nicht dabei.
Ist er nicht sogar nur Azubi?
Ich habe es jetzt, ich habe, achso.
Ne, Job einschüttet, ist auch vorbei.
Ja, okay, in der Probezeit sollte man vielleicht noch nett, aber ich finde trotzdem, dass sich das nicht gehört.
Also, dass der Präsentator einen, der angemeldet ist, suchen muss, das sollte wirklich nicht sein.
Dann muss ich ihn loben.
Ist er generell nicht so viel da?
Ich würde auch sagen, Pech gehabt.
Ich würde jetzt einfach drinnen sitzen bleiben und warten, bis er kommt.
Und wenn er eine Viertelstunde nicht auftaucht, tschüss.
Kurz spioniert.
Gefunden.
Hat er eine Hose erkannt?
Ich glaube, er ist gerade noch in einem Meeting, aber ich schreibe ihm einfach und dann weiß er Bescheid.
Ja, ich finde, das sollte, achso, das ist, ja gut, bis es losgeht, hätte man schon warten können.
Ja, also das finde ich.
Ich glaube, gerade bin ich maximal nervös, ja.
Also, das ist jetzt, glaube ich, so ziemlich.
Die Spitze der Nervosität.
Ja, verstehe, verständlich.
Also, wenn man die Beförderung zum Seniorentwickler anstrebt, dann hilft es einfach ungemein,
wenn man zeigen kann, dass man an verschiedenen Initiativen mitgearbeitet hat, wie jetzt eben diese Präsentation
und dass man eben auch ohne große Leitung einfach den Sprung ins kalte Wasser schafft
und eben trotzdem Ergebnisse dann auch präsentieren kann.
Naja, man muss halt seine Sachen auch gut darstellen können.
Es ist halt so.
Da ist er.
Der Sam ist am Start.
Oh ja, also diese Creators-Funktion ist super top secret, verstehe ich, ja.
Boah, da sind aber ganz schön viele am Start.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alle chillen ohne Kamera im Homeoffice.
So muss das sein.
Dann bist du gut zu gehen, Jonas.
Hallo, alle und willkommen zu dieser Session von der SAP Signavio Process Intelligence.
In dieser biwöchigen Session werde ich euch ein kurzes Update geben.
On Process AI Initiatives.
Our first aim is to provide instant recommendations for redesigning processes.
And last but not least, these features should empower every single customer, including those and non...
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, Leute, warte mal.
Sehe ich das richtig oder ist die Hälfte einfach schon raus, der Leute?
Oder muss man auf Punkt, Punkt, Punkt drücken und dann kommt die restliche Teilnehmerliste?
Ich glaube, dann kommt die restliche Teilnehmerliste.
Das wäre fies.
Das mag ich auch immer nicht.
Sich erst anmelden und dann zwischendurch abhauen.
Mir macht es einfach sehr viel Spaß, in dem Beruf vor komplexe Aufgaben gestellt zu werden und dann eben auch genügend Freiraum.
Das, finde ich, gehört sich auch nicht.
Irgendwo rein zu joinen, wo man angemeldet ist und sich dann abzuhauen dazwischen.
Da sollte man zumindest, wenigstens wenn es so ein Teams-Call ist, drinnen bleiben.
Dann sieht das wenigstens so aus, als interessiert es einen.
Ich finde, das ist schon dem Präsentator, der da auch Zeit reingesteckt hat und so, das ist einfach nur angemessen.
... zu bekommen, um eigenes...
... eigene Ideen zu entwickeln.
Letztendlich erfolgt es dann aber trotzdem immer im Team.
Das bedeutet, dieser Austausch mit anderen Informatikern und dieses gemeinsame Nachdenken finde ich auch sehr gut.
Ja, thank you, Darko.
I think we will stay in touch.
Okay, then, we're set.
Thank you very much.
Thanks, bye.
Alright.
Man sieht schon, dass sie alle eigentlich gar keinen Bock haben, da irgendwie jetzt vor der Kamera zu hocken.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist ganz gut.
Es hat gut gelaufen, also die Vorbereitung hat auf jeden Fall geholfen, erleichtert bin ich auch, also jetzt wäre eigentlich die ideale Zeit für ein Bier, aber es ist noch ein bisschen zeitig.
Hat es ja auch sehr gut gemacht, ich glaube, ja, gut vorbereiten und, ja, war sehr interessant zu sehen.
Ja, ich glaube, jetzt gehe ich noch mal ein bisschen programmieren und dann geht's auch nach Hause.
Servus.
Der Berufseinstieg selbst hat bei mir sehr gut funktioniert.
Warum machen die immer so krasse Nahaufnahmen von den Gesichtern der Leute?
Ich habe hier bei SAP...
So, lass mich dir erstmal die Kamera ins Gesicht halten kurz oder ranzoomen.
...für Unterstützung bekommen.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es für das Studium sehr hilfreich, wenn man auch genügend praktischen Anteil hat, ob das jetzt in Form eines dualen Studiums ist oder ob man sich nebenbei noch einen Nebenjob sucht.
Ich glaube, es hilft einfach ungemein, wenn man vor dem Berufsleben schon ein bisschen Ahnung hat, wie das Leben als Softwareentwickler dann aussieht.
Ja, sowieso hat durchaus den Vorteil, dass man da nicht negativ überrascht wird.
So nach dem Motto.
Man stellt sich was anderes vor, als es dann wirklich ist.
Aber es scheint warm zu sein.
Die sind alle in kurzen Hosen am Start.
Finde ich nice.
Habe ich mich nicht getraut bei mir, aber ich bin ja auch hier Business Enterprise Finanzsektor.
Da rennen ja genug Leute sogar im Anzug rum.
Ich habe immer eine lange Hose auf der Arbeit an, aber ich habe eine kurze Hose dabei, wenn es warm ist, wo man sich umziehen kann.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es eine Kleider...
Ordnung oder Vorschrift bei uns gibt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich vermute nicht.
Aber nachdem bei uns auch so viele Business Enterprise keckkeck wie Business Anzug Leute rumlaufen.
So welche hier.
Da ziehe ich wenigstens auch lange Hose an.
So.
Ja, so ist das bei uns auch.
So trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Genau.
Und ungeschriebene ungeschriebene Regel.
Ja, genau.
Ja, und ich ziehe mich dann meistens um.
Bevor ich, bevor ich rausgehe, wenn es warm ist.
Letztens richtiger Fail, richtiger Fail gewesen.
Ich war in Frankfurt.
Und.
Da war es warm.
Ich habe mich umgezogen, kurze Hose, quasi Moment abgewartet, wo keiner im Büro war.
Hinter eine der Trennwände gegangen.
Hose runter, Hose aus, kurz Hose an.
Mein Unterhose bleibt ja an.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich kurzzeitig nackig im Büro stehen würde oder sowas, bevor sich da jetzt wieder einer irgendwelche, ne,
Dinger ausmalt.
Einfach nur eine Hose aus, eine Hose an, hinter so einer Trennwand umgezogen.
Und ich habe dann später gemerkt, ich finde meinen Schlüssel daheim nicht mehr.
Und glücklicherweise hat jemand anderes.
Aus meinem Team den Schlüssel gefunden, hat ihn aber der falschen Person zugeordnet.
Warum nicht auf der Toilette?
Weil es da zu eng ist.
Hat ihn aber der falschen Person zugeordnet.
Sodass der Schlüssel dann da zwei, drei Tage bei dem anderen im Schreibtisch rumlag.
Und ich erst, nachdem ich gefragt habe, sag mal, Jungs, hat irgendeiner einen Schlüssel gefunden mit so einem roten Band dran?
Und der meinte, ja, letzte Woche, den habe ich doch da auf den Tisch gelegt.
Ja, und der hat ihn dort auf den Tisch gelegt, zu dem die Trennwand gehört, hinter der ich mich umgezogen habe.
Das muss mir beim Umziehen einfach aus der Tasche gefallen sein.
Da, ich hatte schon, ich hatte schon den Typ da.
Vom Schreiner hier, der Schlösser austauscht.
Und er hat gesagt, ja, er muss ein neues Schloss bestellen.
Und dadurch, dass er ein neues Schloss bestellen muss, hat es sich gerade glücklicherweise zeitlich so überschnitten,
dass mein Kollege gesagt hat, ja klar, den habe ich gefunden.
Zu, ich konnte da noch absagen, weil ansonsten, wenn er das jetzt schon bestellt hätte, hätte ich ja nicht noch einen Rückzieher machen können.
Ähm, nee, baue mal doch nicht ein oder so.
Ja.
Okay, hi Jonas. Bist du bereit fürs Review?
Jo.
Dann gehen wir mal rüber.
Also, ich bin jetzt fertig mit dem Ticket, soweit auch pünktlich.
Warum Reviewen? Einfach first try, perfekt, fehlerfrei. Ist doch logisch.
Errorless Programming, wie wir das auch immer im Stream praktizieren, hat nur Vorteile.
Man braucht keine Tests.
Man braucht kein Review.
Man braucht keine Kommentare.
Man braucht keine Dokumentation.
Es muss einfach nur first try für immer perfekt funktionieren. Easy.
Ich weiß nicht, dieses, dieses und dann direkt Produktion live deployen. Ja, korrekt.
Was man sich damit für Geld sparen könnte.
Einfach keine Fehler programmieren. Das ist doch so einfach.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die Leute da nicht schon früher drauf gekommen sind.
Warum ich das denen immer erzählen muss.
Einfach keine Fehler machen und du kannst dir ganz viel sparen.
Was das für Geld spart.
Was es für Zeit spart.
Keine Fehler machen.
Es ist ganz easy.
Du brauchst keine Tests umgeben.
Nichts, was du für Geld sparen kannst.
Einfach fehlerfrei.
Immer.
Und ich hoffe, dass ich jetzt positives Feedback von Ralf bekomme, damit die Änderung heute noch übernommen werden kann.
Ralf sagt jetzt bestimmt, ähm, hättest du es mal in C programmiert.
Ralf ist bestimmt Linux Kernel Maintainer.
Er hat Rust.
Was ist da los?
Gibt's kein Rust.
Mach das mal in C ordentlich.
Nee, also so wie ich das verstehe, er ist glaube ich nicht Azubi.
Er ist quasi so eine Art Juniorentwickler nach dem, nach seinem Studium oder noch während dem Studium.
So genau habe ich ehrlich gesagt am Anfang nicht zugehört.
Wir gucken jetzt, ähm, ja.
Vielleicht hat einer von euch genau zugehört.
Okay, also mit dem Ticket bist du ja im Wesentlichen...
Wait, warum muss man dazu in den extra Raum?
Wäre es nicht viel sinnvoller, sich zu ihm an den Schreibtisch zu setzen mit dem großen Bildschirm, dass man alles, äh, sehen kann?
Super, Rella, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog.
Sehr, sehr nice.
...vertraut, aber ich würde es trotzdem nochmal kurz wiederholen.
Genau.
Also an sich, ähm, ja, habe ich diese Greatest-Funktion hinzugefügt.
Ja, was, äh, war denn deine Überlegung, sagst du mal?
Also wenn jetzt A größer als B ist und, ähm, A größer als C ist, dann würden wir natürlich A rausbekommen.
Ja.
Weil wir ja das Maximum suchen.
Also Mathematik ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Bestandteil des Informatikstudiums.
Ich, äh, also bin ich jetzt total wirr im Kopf? Kriege ich das größte Element nicht raus, indem ich einfach, ich nehme das erste Element, sage, das ist mein größtes Element.
Ich nehme das zweite Element und gucke, ob das größer ist. Wenn ja, ist das mein größtes Element.
Ich nehme das dritte Element, gucke, ob das größer ist. Nein, also bleibt das zweite mein größtes Element.
Ich laufe einfach linear von Anfang bis Ende durch, weil muss ich ja, das ist, es geht ja hier nicht um irgendwelche sortierte Sachen oder so.
Das ist doch super simpel, oder? Da musst du hier keine Trees oder so.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich für die, für die, für den Show-Effekt, oder?
Und ich bin auch froh, dass es den Stellenwert bekommt, den es jetzt hat. Also gerade zur Analyse von Datenstrukturen und sowas ist es auf jeden Fall notwendig.
Aber im Tagtäglichen verwende ich tatsächlich weniger Mathematik, als ich gedacht hätte.
Ja, tagtäglich verwendest du mehr Google wahrscheinlich.
Tests, wo sind die?
Also, wie wir es immer machen, habe ich halt auch einmal logische Tests hinzugefügt.
Ja, nice.
Genau, die sich nur um die Sprache kümmern.
Sieht gut aus. Genau, dann können wir es aber jetzt auf unseren Test ausrollen, würde ich sagen.
Und...
Dann...
Wie jetzt? Da wird getestet.
Ei, ei, ei.
Das wird ja voll Zeit kosten.
Ja, sehr gute Arbeit. Gut gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Den Code würde ich trotzdem am Ende jetzt gerne nochmal sehen, weil mehr als drei, vier Zeilen sind das doch nicht.
Ich weiß, es ist Show für den Beitrag. Ich will das auch nicht schlechtreden.
Es gehört viel mehr dazu, als rein die Sachen zu programmieren in diesem Job.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Ich finde, das haben die auch in dem Beitrag gar nicht schlechtreden.
Gar nicht schlecht dargestellt.
Aber ich würde jetzt trotzdem das Endergebnis nochmal...
War nicht der Code sogar in den Kommentaren irgendwie?
Leider nicht.
Das wäre doch cool gewesen.
Closed Source SAP in den Kommentaren auf YouTube.
Dann bis später.
Ja, ich schaue es mir nochmal an.
Jo, ciao.
Ja, also aus meiner Sicht ist es sehr gut gelaufen.
Also, Ralf hat mir positives Feedback soweit gegeben.
Und ja, wenn er dann jetzt nochmal am Rechner geschaut hat, dann kann ich es, glaube ich, auch auf der Testlandschaft ausrollen.
Ja, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gehofft, das hat er schon getestet, bevor er da großartig gedingst hat, lokal.
Aber wahrscheinlich geht es jetzt drum, so nach dem Motto, wir machen jetzt einen Pull-Request oder einen Merge-Request,
oder wie man es bei Ihnen nennt, ein Feature-Request mit Dings und Pull und keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich macht er ein Merge-Request auf.
Es wird dann gemerged und dann läuft das nochmal durch irgendeine offizielle Pipeline, wo dann geguckt wird, okay, die...
Offizielle Testsuite läuft offiziell auf den offiziellen Testservern mit offiziellem Input und allem durch.
Vermutlich.
Wenn jetzt natürlich irgendein Fehler meinerseits mit drin ist, dann könnte es natürlich passieren, dass das Testsystem abstürzt.
Ja, dann machen sie sowas jetzt.
Abstürzt.
Das wäre natürlich nicht gut.
Dann gibt es dann wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Pipeline-Fehler, so nach dem Motto, ah, hier, guck mal hier, Inputnummer 870, Test failed.
Das ist schon ein Glücksmoment, wenn ich sehe, dass es dann tatsächlich funktioniert.
Ja, bei mir auch, bei mir auch, weil bei uns ist es so, wir haben mittlerweile so übertrieben viele Linter, Syntax-Checker, Guideline-Checker und sonst was.
Du kannst fast nichts committen.
Und es geht nicht darum, dass das irgendwie von der Logik oder vom Inhalt her falsch wäre.
Du kannst aber mittlerweile fast nichts committen.
Ohne, dass sich irgendeines dieser 30.000.
Dieser 30.000.
Milliarden Tools irgendwas zu meckern hat.
Und sei es nur, dass du an irgendeiner Stelle ein Leerzeichen hinten dran hast, wo gefolgt von einem New Line und solche Dinger.
Wobei man das im Editor noch schön aufräumen kann.
Ich hatte letztens, ich habe letztens was committet in einem Terraform-Modul von uns.
Und da machen wir mal exemplarisch.
Ja, haben wir hier.
Irgendwie Terraform-Modul.
So.
Da steht dann hier irgendwie drinnen so, keine Ahnung.
Blub gleich 1.
Muss man da ein Komma machen?
Weiß gar nicht.
Keckel gleich 0.
So.
Und da hatte ich das so.
Und da hat dann einer der 5.000 Linter gesagt, Max, das können wir nicht annehmen.
Das ist Fail.
Pipeline fehlgeschlagen.
Warum?
Da ist ein Leerzeichen dahinter.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist ausgeschlossen.
Das ist broken as fuck, wenn da ein Leerzeichen dahinter ist.
Das muss weg.
Ich benutze Terraform-FMT.
Deswegen war das auch nicht exakt das Beispiel, was ich gezeigt habe.
Das macht das Automat.
Das macht auch glücklicherweise, Terraform-FMT macht auch glücklicherweise diese Geschichten hier einheitlich.
Wenn du schreibst, blub gleich 1 und schreibst dann irgendwie Omega 0 gleich 2.
Dann macht es uns safe die Einrückung schon so, dass das hier alles auf der gleichen Höhe ist.
Aber es war ein Fehler so ungefähr in dieser Größenordnung.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Alter, unsere Linter fucken mich mittlerweile so krass ab.
Oder auch schlimm.
Wir haben einen Linter drinne.
So, stellt euch mal vor, ich habe hier ein Terraform-Modul oder irgendwas, ist egal.
So, da habe ich irgendwo mal eine Variable angelegt.
Blub gleich 1.
So, ich will jetzt was ausprobieren.
Aber ich weiß genau.
In dem Dev-System, wo die das testen, macht es gar keinen Sinn, dass dort jetzt irgendwie ein extra Server versucht wird zu spawnen über Terraform, weil das eh nicht funktioniert.
Dann kommentierst du hier diesen Kram mal aus und dann kommt er wieder an.
Aber Max, unused variable.
Ja, ich will es ja auch nicht final committen.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob das prinzipiell durchlaufen würde, was ich gebaut habe.
Aber unused variable, das geht so nicht.
Ich führe es erst gar nicht weiter aus.
Dann musst du dann den Scheiß noch so ein bisschen wie ein Go, ja.
Musst du den Scheiß noch auskommentieren und dann sagt er, haha, aber jetzt ist das hier nicht richtig eingerückt, weil jetzt muss das so sein.
Boah, das ist so abfuck, Alter.
Und wir reden jetzt nicht davon, dass ich fertig bin und das abschließend committen will.
Nein, nein, das ist während meiner Entwicklungsphase sind da teilweise die Linter schon am Start, die mich so abfucken.
Und ich muss manches tatsächlich immer über unsere...
Pipeline aufbauen, weil ich potenziell gar nicht die Rechte habe, von meinem Entwickler-Notebook in irgendeiner Cloud-Umgebung dort über Terraform irgendwas zu provisionen, weil ich ja nicht das richtige Account für habe und sowas.
Oh, das fuckt immer richtig ab.
Das dauert.
Und dadurch, dass diese Pipeline auch so lahm läuft, weil sie, glaube ich, zu wenig Runner haben, wobei ich glaube, mittlerweile haben sie das, muss man sagen, also unser Team, die sich darum kümmert.
Die ist sehr nett und helfen einem auch immer und blicken durch.
Also ohne die wird das gar nicht funktionieren.
Und das hat auch alles Hand und Fuß, was die bauen.
Aber die können halt auch nichts machen, um einen Prozess, der langsam ist, der halt trotzdem verlangt wird, obwohl er eigentlich an der Stelle keinen Sinn macht, besser zu machen.
Und das fuckt mich so ab immer.
Da brauche ich dann irgendwie drei Stunden was zu basteln, was daheim auf meiner Linux-Kiste mit bisschen Drei und Error
in Terraform in der Viertelstunde erledigt gewesen wäre.
Aber letztendlich macht auch keinen Sinn, sich darüber aufzuregen.
Ich meine, ich kriege es bezahlt und im Endeffekt können die sich das ja überlegen, was sie für ihr Geld haben wollen.
Unrecognized Function, ja, das fehlt bestimmt noch in irgendeinem XML drinne.
Signavio Process Intelligence.
Das da oben sieht ein bisschen wie ein Google-Account aus.
Aber vielleicht sieht das bei SAP gut aus.
Weiß ich nicht.
Sieht sehr nach Google, aber wahrscheinlich einfach nur ähnlich.
Es sieht halt so Material Design mäßig aus, dieses Interface, deswegen vielleicht.
Funktioniert es quasi noch nicht, diese Funktion.
Wo sind wir denn da?
Kurz gucken.
Test Workspace, Process, Value Staging, Cloud.
Value Staging.
Updates, Value Staging, Cloud.
Ist das irgendein Helm-Chat?
Wird da gerade irgendwas auf Kubernetes deployed?
Weil Values klingt so ein bisschen danach.
Irgendwelche Helm-Value-Files.
Aber man könnte da viel raten, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Was da unter der Haube jetzt infrastrukturmäßig funzt und nicht.
Und, äh, ja.
Ah.
Value Staging, Cloud, OS, EU, YAML.
Ja.
Ja, Kubernetes-Config.
Leute, ich sag's euch doch.
Das ist irgendein Helm-Chart-Value-File, was da geupdatet hat.
Siehste mal.
Sixthead.
Nur vom Sehen, nur vom Sehen der, der, ähm, der Datei oben im Browser,
war's mir klar schon wieder hier.
Guck mal und sieht.
Es ist ein K8, es ist ein Kubernetes-Config-Verzeichnis.
Und das hier klingt ganz stark nach einem Helm-Chart-YAML-File.
Was da geup-, äh, was da geupdatet wurde.
Hab ich recht gelegen.
Da drüben hab ich jetzt, äh, die Möglichkeit, das Ganze auf das System aufzuspielen.
Und, ja.
Jetzt, äh, die Möglichkeit, das Ganze auf das System aufzuspielen.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Signavio, ist das auf GitHub?
Heißt das so Signavio?
Ups, wo sind wir?
Lass mal gucken.
Suite K8S-Config.
Nee.
Ah.
Das gibt's hier nicht.
Wir können's mal ausprobieren.
Ob es mir, ob es mir sagt, dass ich da keinen Zugriff drauf habe.
Ja, gut.
Das ist, ähm, das ist ja nur die Organisation der Suite.
Was war das?
Minus?
Ah, darf ich nicht.
Jetzt könnte man natürlich an der Stelle mal gucken, weil, falls dieses Repo nämlich jemals öffentlich war.
GitHub Events.
Ah, ich find die Seite nicht.
Es gibt so eine Seite, die alle GitHub Events, die es jemals gab, auflistet.
Und da könnte man gucken, ob das jemals der Fall war.
Aber das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Könnte man schauen.
Nee, keine Ahnung mehr.
Es gab so eine Seite, da konnte man alle öffentlichen GitHub Events, äh, durchsuchen.
Die Wayback Machine stimmt.
Das, nee, mit, mit, mit, ähm, ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Es gibt so eine, gibt so eine Webseite, die, ähm, kann alle GitHub Events durchsuchen.
Nee, war nie public.
Zumindest nie, wann das, äh, hier initiiert wurde.
Ist ja auch egal.
Wollt einfach nur mal gucken.
... zu spielen und ja.
Okay, also jetzt seh ich, dass hier drüben der Fehler verschwunden ist und tatsächlich, äh, ein Ergebnis.
Huge Test! Massive!
OSS Insight.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das meine.
Nee, es ist komplett nicht öffentlich.
Ah!
Da findet man tatsächlich schon ein bisschen mehr über die Webseite.
Witzigerweise.
Aber das wollen wir jetzt nicht.
So.
Nee, man findet nix, man findet nix.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken, ob die ihr Repo auch ordentlich, äh, private gestellt haben.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist schon, ich glaube, das war schon die richtige Seite.
Das ist das, man kann, man kann alle, also das ist, das ist nix Geheimes.
Es gibt, das ist ein, ja, weiß ich nicht, ein Feature eigentlich von GitHub, dass du, äh, dass die alle Events von Repos, die public sind.
Und teilweise kriegst du die auch irgendwie raus von allen Repos, die jemals public waren, quasi dir angucken kannst öffentlich.
Also sprich, wenn du beispielsweise ein Repo mal öffentlich hattest und dann private machst, aber das jemals jemand geforkt hat davor, dann hat er immer noch Zugriff, das ist ganz weird.
Weird.
Müssen wir uns, da gibt's Videos zu, die das, die das zeigen, dass, ähm, private Repos auf GitHub nur wirklich private sind, wenn sie von Anfang an und für immer private waren.
Das rauskommt.
Also mit dem, was ich jetzt gesehen habe auf der Testlandschaft, äh, ist das Ticket aus meiner Sicht abgeschlossen und meine Arbeit ist damit auch geschlossen.
Ah, gibt's hier.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie das Informatikstudium so abläuft, dann schaut doch mal hier.
Genau, da gibt's hier, gibt's jede Menge solcher, ja, das, also wenn ihr das wissen wollt, kann, können wir uns das angucken.
Das geht nur neun Minuten.
How to access private and deleted GitHub repository data.
Das ist kein Hackerman-Shit, das ist ein, wohlgemerkt, ne, falls jetzt irgendwie einer von Twitch zuguckt.
Das ist ein offizielles Feature von GitHub, was nicht so bekannt ist und man sich fragt, warum es überhaupt da ist.
Okay, es wäre, es wäre auf jeden Fall kein Mental-Outlaw-Video, wenn er nicht Microsoft bisschen dissen würde irgendwie zwischendurch.
Aber hat, er hat ja recht, er hat, haha, geht schon los, geht schon los.
Nee, noch nicht.
Aber er hat ja meistens recht.
Google hat in zero years time re-reported GitHub-Property in 2018 in 7 and a half billion dollars.
By the way, by the way, Milliarden, armi-billionen.
GitHub, being a Microsoft Property now, fits perfectly with this major privacy issue on the platform,
where anyone can access deleted and privated data from any other repository on GitHub.
Truffle Security, who wrote up a blog post about this phenomenon,
zwei kurze Videos, die die Frage zeigen, die wir jetzt zusammen sehen und ich erkläre, was
für die weniger technisch wachsenden Leute losgeht. Okay, also hier am Anfang ist er die OpenAI
Cookbook-Repository aufgeräumt, was bedeutet, dass er grundsätzlich den Code über eine Repo kopiert, die er kontrolliert,
damit er seine eigenen Modifikationen dazu machen kann. Und wenn wir uns die Readme für diese OpenAI-Repo anschauen,
können wir sehen, dass es als Beispielcode und Guides für die Erfüllung von gemeinsamen Tasken mit der OpenAI-API beschrieben ist.
Und um diese Beispiele zu funktionieren, werden Sie eine OpenAI-Account und eine API-Key benötigen.
By the way, das hat übrigens alles nichts mit OpenAI zu tun, das ist nur ein Beispiel jetzt anhand des Repos.
Die API-Key wird in eine Umgebungsvariante in deinem Programm gespeichert, damit es die Query von GPT-4 oder
einigen anderen Daten, die du in deinem Programm hast, überprüfen kann.
Die API-Key wird in eine Umgebungsvariante in deinem Programm gespeichert, damit es die Query von GPT-4 oder einigen anderen Daten,
die du in deinem Programm hast, überprüfen kann.
Und wir können auf der Website von OpenAI sehen, dass der Preis für eine API-Key
bei 1 Millionen Input-Token startet.
Wenn deine API-Key leidet, kann jemand all die Token, die du bezahlt hast,
für eine Wartestelle
Prix uppen für eine andere API-Key an紹ieren.
Wenn deine API-Key leidet, kann jemand all die Token, die du bezahlt hast, skulle du über ein Fan und anderen einen E-Pass benötigen.
Wenn deine API-Key leidet, könne jemand all die Token, die du bezahlt hast, gucken, dass der Preis für eine API-Key
bei 1 Millionen Input-Token startet.
Ihr müsst nicht vermutlich irgendetwas ilusiv machen.
Aber einfach vermitteln, dieard heavy-out, also eine API-Key zu verändern.
Das sind Halo Lab. BEVAN, beispielsweise, zwei E-P eigentlich A4学생.
Also werden wir sinnvoll, wenn ihr Quad combining zu E5ровieicken einstellen dürft die Art, wie ich denen die APPs matchesistent.
So wird die Cloud IDS District Web.
Ah, okay, komm mal zum Punkt.
So, jetzt.
Nee, wusste ich nicht, wusste ich nicht mit dem Copilot-Chat.
Auf, komm zum Punkt.
Ja, und das, und das, genau, und das bringt nix.
Das war's, so rum war das, so rum war das, ja.
Das war das.
Das ist schon kacke, oder?
Nur mal, nur mal, um das nochmal zusammenzufassen.
Jemand hat dieses Repo geforkt.
In dem Fork hat er was committet, was er nicht hätte committen sollen.
Und danach hat er den Fork wieder gelöscht.
Wenn du allerdings die Commit-ID weißt, kannst du auf dem Ursprungs-Repo
das Commit dir wieder angucken, obwohl es nie auf dem Ursprungs-Repo
passiert ist.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen kacke.
So, und jetzt ist halt das Ding, es gibt Suchmaschinen,
die alle GitHub-Events listen.
Und da findet man sowas relativ easy nachträglich noch raus.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber das war ja nur ein Beispiel jetzt dafür.
Muss ja nicht gleich um Secrets gehen.
... for accessing commits from private repositories is also very similar.
Here we see that he creates a repo called NewTool,
that is supposed to be private.
You can see he selected the private option.
And then he forks this private NewTool repo
to make a new repo called Internal NewTool,
which is also private.
And as the name and description implies,
it's only meant to be used internally.
Then he creates this feature.py file,
which is also meant to be private,
since it's part of the private internal repo.
Then he goes back to the original NewTool repo,
makes it public,
so now this part of the code is open source,
just like the OpenAI cookbook.
And now if you copy the commit hash from the private...
Das ist halt kacke,
weil das könnte quasi retroaktiv dann Sachen zugänglich machen,
die du gar nicht zugänglich machen möchtest
und überhaupt nicht mehr dran denkst,
weil du war doch alles private bis dahin.
... internal repo.
... and paste it after the public NewTool repo,
you're able to access the sensitive data for that commit
from the internal repository.
Now, the worst thing about this GitHub bug
is that according to GitHub...
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar kein Bug.
It's not even a bug. It's a feature.
People have been reporting this feature problem
to GitHub's HackerOne-Program for years now
to try and...
... collect a bug bounty
and, you know, of course, get GitHub to fix this feature.
But GitHub always says that things are working as intended.
So I assume that...
Working as intended ist ja mal die beste Antwort,
so schlechthin so...
Wie ist das Schrott?
Ja, wir wollten ja, dass das Schrott ist.
Erinnert mich an ein altes MMO, was ich gespielt habe.
Da gab es einmal im Monat...
Also, da gab es...
Wie in jedem MMO gab es mehrere Klassen, die man spielen konnte.
Und es gab einmal im Monat oder...
Es kann auch sein, dass es einmal im Quartal...
Einmal im Quartal gab es dort quasi einen Report
für jede Klasse mit Änderungsvorschlägen aus der Community
und Bugs aus der Community, was es denn für Probleme gibt.
Ja, was weiß ich.
Irgendwelche Songs, die man nicht richtig switchen kann,
weil es rumbuggt.
Also, im Prinzip gab es einmal im Quartal...
Einen Zusammenfassungspost im offiziellen Forum von diesem MMO,
wo quasi so ein...
Ja, ein Community-Lead-Typ, im Prinzip halt ein Freiwilliger,
der das alles gesammelt hat,
quasi einmal im Quartal zusammengestellt hat für den Hersteller,
so, was es gerade für Probleme mit der jeweiligen Klasse gibt,
für Bugs und für Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Und der Hersteller hat darauf reagiert.
Man könnte schon sagen, in der heutigen Zeit eigentlich...
Unbezahlbar, dass Hersteller überhaupt direkt kommunizieren
mit Leuten, die ihr Spiel spielen
und wahrscheinlich die Hersteller sogar selbst das Spiel spielen.
Aber in der damaligen Zeit war das noch, sag mal, relativ normal,
dass sich MMO-Hersteller mit den Spielern ihrer MMO-Community
da auseinandergesetzt haben.
Zumindest, das war eines meiner ersten so negativen Erlebnisse
mit Softwareherstellern.
Die haben ausnahmslos...
Na gut, ausnahmslos stimmt nicht.
Aber zu 99% haben die...
Und die Leute haben sich da...
...und die Leute haben sich da wirklich...
...und die Leute haben sich da wirklich extrem viel Mühe gegeben, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man noch was findet hier.
Class Report oder sowas.
Ach, klar, das gibt's jetzt...
Das offizielle Forum gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Ist auch egal.
Die Leute haben sich da wirklich sehr viel Mühe gegeben,
sowas zu erstellen.
Und die Hersteller...
Der Hersteller hat zu 99,9%,
das hatte man das Gefühl, gar nicht richtig gelesen.
Die haben immer geschrieben,
Works as designed
und design decision.
Das war die zwei Sachen.
So nach dem Motto,
du hast geschrieben,
ja, bei Klasse X,
wenn du dort diese zwei Spells
zusammendrückst,
dann,
sagen wir mal was übertriebenes,
dann crasht dein Spiel.
Oder dann löscht sich dein Charakter.
Oder vielleicht was nicht ganz so Schlimmes.
Dann hast du einen viel zu langen Cooldown,
der eigentlich nicht sein sollte.
Das ist ein Bug.
Und da haben die ernsthaft auf solche offensichtlichen Dinger,
wo wirklich jedem klar war,
dass es einfach Schwachsinn und Schrott und das ist...
Das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht und sollte so nicht sein,
haben die ernsthaft darauf geantwortet,
No, design decision.
Und da war die ganze Herstellergeschichte
damals schon für mich durch.
So nach dem Motto,
ich drücke diese zwei Tasten, das Spiel crasht.
Das ist kein Bug.
No, works as designed.
Design decision.
Seitdem kann ich diese ganze Sache mit,
es ist kein Bug.
Es ist so gewollt, nicht mehr ernst nehmen.
GitHub's whole opinion about this issue
is probably really similar
to some of the other people online
that are calling this a big nothing burger
because, well, to access the secret code
or the deleted code,
you need the commit hash,
which is this long string
that would be about as difficult to guess
as most secret strings and API keys
and other sensitive data like that
in the first place.
But seasoned hackers are not going to try
and brute force something like this.
No.
A much more complicated thing is that
a much more clever approach
would be to download an archive of commits
made from gharchive.org
Ach, die Seite war das.
Die Seite war das, okay.
That data that's in that JSON file
for all of the commits that were made
by your target user
and or your target user's target repos
and then go through those commit hashes
to find the juicy secrets that you're looking for.
And even if the attacker,
also sprich,
wir könnten uns jetzt den GitHub-Account
von dem SAP-Entwickler raussuchen
und mal gucken, was der alles public
jemals auf GitHub committed hat.
Das finde ich fragwürdig,
dass das überhaupt so ohne weiteres geht.
Ja.
Da findest du vielleicht raus,
der Kerl hat privat mal an irgendeiner,
ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas bescheuertes aus,
keine Ahnung, an irgendeiner
Rule34-Anime-Seite mitgearbeitet oder so,
was man vielleicht nicht vor, keine Ahnung,
zehn Jahren oder so,
was er vielleicht heute, was er nicht will,
dass das jemand rausbekommt.
Schon blöd, dass das so einfach geht.
... access these private or deleted commits
without actually guessing the full hash of the commit.
You see, the Git-Protocol permits the use
of short SHA-1 values
whenever you're referencing a commit.
And these short values,
are the minimum set of characters
that are needed to avoid a collision
with another hash value.
And the shortened values can be as small
as four hexadecimal characters,
which means an attacker would only need
to iterate through 16 to the power of four possibilities
to find those secret commits.
Now, there are a number of ways to avoid this...
Naja, solange euer Repo immer private ist,
ist es kein Problem.
Also, alles damit zusammenhängende private
und immer von Anfang an private war und so,
dann geht das.
Also, wenn ich jetzt was pushe bei mir auf GitHub,
wo ich nicht will, dass ihr das seht,
ja, dann sollte das immer private sein.
Man kann sich nicht auf alle Entwickler verlassen,
das stimmt.
... design flaw from resulting in the takedown
of your entire cloud infrastructure.
The best thing to do is practice proper triage
before committing any code in the first place,
so that you can make sure API keys
and cryptographic secrets are never actually getting
to GitHub servers.
This is another example of...
Ja gut, das ist...
Das war jetzt im Prinzip, was er gesagt hat,
was ich auch immer sage,
einfach keine Fehler machen, forehead, easy.
Aber früher oder später passiert es halt trotzdem mal.
... the fact that whenever you put something on the Internet,
you can never really delete it
or you can never really be sure that it's gone.
And another solution,
since this feature is part of the whole forking of repos,
is to just copy the repos instead of forking them,
so that your commit hashes are not going to have any connection
to the original repositories.
And another option is to just host
your own version control system instead of using GitHub.
I'd especially recommend this
for any controversial software projects
and just a lot of AI projects in general,
since politicians...
... are trying to pass regulations left and right for AI.
Warum YouTube das gefärbt ist, keine Ahnung.
Ist das bei mir auch so?
Wo ist der Balken gefärbt?
Das hier?
Ja, das ist bestimmt irgendein Feature-Ding,
was ich über Testweise hier bekommen habe von YouTube.
Dr. BroNubx, danke schön für den Sub.
... which could result in the unexpected deletion
of your repo from GitHub at any time.
So make sure you're being careful
when developing your open source software.
Give this video a tie-dye-torty or...
So sieht's aus.
Also, ist doch nicht so sicher, ne?
Nur weil das GitHub-Repo private ist.
Das ist eigentlich das, worauf ich raus wollte, Freund.
Der Fiat-Champ ist am Start.
Letztens hat einer ganz nett gefragt,
ob ich nicht weiterentwickeln könnte dran.
Ich hab dem auch noch auf GitHub...
Äh, nicht auf GitHub, auf...
... auf x ehemals Twitter geantwortet.
Kannst du mal das Video...
... als Link posten?
I'm sure that many of you...
... ich weiß auch nicht, ob das alles noch so geht,
weil das hat schon ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Vielleicht hat ja...
... ähm, GitHub da jetzt ein bisschen was dran geändert.
Rechenpower wie bei OpenAI auf meinem Schreibtisch, okay.
Was ist...
... was war deine Lieblingszeit in deiner Karriere?
Also, das muss man, glaube ich, ein bisschen entscheiden.
Also, was ich wirklich cool fand, ist die Zeit,
wo ich noch täglich ins Rechenzentrum gegangen bin.
An mehreren Standorten in Frankfurt.
Das hat mir einfach so aus...
... aus...
... ja, so aus...
... Hardware-Liebhaber-Sicht gefallen.
Nicht, dass ich das unbedingt nochmal machen möchte.
Und ich möchte auch nicht mehr so früh aufstehen und, ähm...
... fünf Tage Woche arbeiten und sowas.
Nee, was hat...
... was hat er wieder...
... hat er wieder irgendwelche Drogen getestet?
So funktioniert das Internet.
Ach, das hab ich angefangen zu gucken.
Das war irgendein...
... das war irgendein...
... Sponsor-Telekom-Video.
Hab ich aufgehört zu gucken.
Oder lohnt sich das zu gucken?
Das hab ich aufgehört zu gucken.
Ich hab...
... ich hab angemacht...
... und hab gesehen, dass...
... dass es ein, äh...
... quasi Sponsor-Video von der Telekom ist.
Sehr oberflächlich, ja.
Ja.
Täglicher Rundgang und Lämpchen erkennen, ja.
Also, das...
... das...
... das hat mir wirklich gefallen.
Die Zeit, wo ich noch täglich...
... ins Rechenzentrum musste.
In mehreren Standorten.
Die Sachen, die drumherum waren,
haben mir nicht so gut gefallen zu der Zeit.
Aber...
... so dieses täglich im Rechenzentrum gucken...
... äh...
... dort dann auch...
... ähm...
... ab und zu mal Kisten einbauen.
Noch oldschool rüberlaufen mit...
... Red Hat.
Nein, die sind nicht am DZX.
Das ist ein Telekom-Werbevideo.
Ich hab auch erst geguckt, ob die im DZX wären.
Aber, äh...
... beim Durchskippen...
... erschien es mir, als ist der bei der Telekom...
... und nicht im DZX.
Ich war aber im DZX auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Vielleicht sieht's da auch anders aus.
Aber es sah für mich aus...
... als ist es ein Telekom-eigenes Ding gewesen...
... wo die da waren.
Aber ich hab nur kurz drüber geskippt.
Ja.
Ab und zu Server eingebaut.
Dann noch damals mit...
... Red Hat DVDs rübergegangen...
... ins Rechenzentrum.
Da irgendwie zwei Stunden rumgehockt.
DVDs getauscht für ne...
... fragt mich nicht warum, aber es war der Fall...
... äh...
... ne Red Hat Vollinstallation auf ner Datenbank.
Die wollten damals auf der Datenbank immer eine Red Hat Vollinstallation haben.
Belegt euch das mal.
So ne Oracle-Datenbank.
Ich glaube, die wollten sicher sein, dass nicht irgendwelche Dependencies fehlen.
Und ne Red Hat Vollinstallation bedeutet im Endeffekt...
... da lief auch Gnome drauf.
Das war quasi...
... ne, ne Oracle-Datenbank, wo wenn du dich mit nem...
... äh...
... mit nem Bildschirm angeschlossen hast, erstmal ein Gnome-Desktop aufgeploppt ist.
Ja.
Vollinstallation Red Hat 3 DVDs, oder wie viele das waren.
Das war...
... ich mochte das, ja.
Server eingebaut, ausgebaut, äh...
... Zeug getauscht, Lüfter getauscht, CPUs getauscht, Netzwerkkarten getauscht, Glasfaser-Zeug...
... äh...
... Kabel...
... Kabel gepatcht.
Ich...
... ich...
... mir hat das...
... viel...
... Spaß gemacht, so die Sache im Rechenzentrum.
Ja.
Weil letztendlich heute gibt's das immer weniger.
Heute haben auch viele, viele Unternehmen gar kein eigenes Rechenzentrum mehr, so...
... gar nicht schon so viele...
... wie damals...
... bei uns, ähm, aber...
... es war schon cool.
Ich will...
... ich würd's nicht mal unbedingt machen wollen.
Auch die Umstände waren damals nicht so geil.
Aber...
... das hat mir gefallen.
Ja.
Die haben mir ne Augenbinde verpasst.
Dass er nicht sieht, wo sie hinlaufen, aber die Kamera hat's gefilmt, oder was?
Ha...
Vielleicht...
Hier kommst du wirklich nur...
Vielleicht gucken wir uns nachher doch noch.
Erinnert mich mal dran.
Wenden wir uns auch vorbei, wir kopieren das runter.
Wir können ja mal drüber skippen.
Vielleicht ist das...
Vielleicht ist das Video ja besser als gedacht.
Hier kommst du wirklich nur...
Alter...
Wurde die Plattform nicht erst gestern öffentlich vorgestellt?
Der Bauer hat das Ding schon erst mal geköpft?
Das muss ich mir schnell mal angucken.
Nicht...
Nicht 38 Minuten.
Wir gucken uns nur an, wo das Ding geköpft wird.
Ich find das immer sehr satisfying zu sehen.
Ah, vielleicht will er...
Ich will da einfach nur sagen, dass es jetzt ein neues...
ähm...
Delet-Tool gibt.
...aus als 1700, weil der Heatspreader ein bisschen schmaler ist.
Das machen wir jetzt im Schnelldurchgang.
...sieht die CPU von der Größe her gleich aus.
Wir wissen ja, dass so ein 1718 Slider, der ist auch nicht symmetrisch, weil die CPU auch nicht symmetrisch ist.
Eine nicht symmetrische CPU. Aha.
...dann eben hier rein.
Und dann macht man dieses Spiel hier.
Wir gucken...
Das ist so ein Prototyp, den sie da schon gebaut haben.
...sichern und ein Mikroskop, eine Stelle vom Delet an.
...was dann so aussieht. Also da sieht man jetzt die rechten SMDs.
Und wenn ich jetzt den Slider einfach mal nach rechts bewege...
...das ist die Bewegung, die man dann...
Passt, passt. Okay, geht nix kaputt.
...später vollziehen wird.
Auf der anderen Seite auch das gleiche Spiel.
Ich will eigentlich nur gucken...
Und es klingt soweit eigentlich erstmal alles cool. Zu dem Zeitpunkt dachte ich auch, alles klar, mein Ding...
Köpfchen der ersten CPU. Genau, das will ich mir angucken.
Die CPU sitzt damit schon drin.
Muss man nur auf die Orientierung vom Slider achten.
...muss man nur auf die Orientierung vom Slider achten.
Damit sitzt er auch.
Jetzt montiere ich noch die Schienen drauf.
Und damit kommt alles so zusammen in den Heater.
Schienenstelz.
Normalerweise wäre jetzt auf der Rückseite eben noch der Temperaturfühler.
Man sieht die CPU von hinten.
Und dann wäre der Sinn, dass man den Temperaturfühler so nach hinten auf die CPU führt, dass er da auch wirklich Kontakt hat.
Und so sichergestellt werden kann, dass die Temperatur richtig aufgenommen wird.
Bei mir ist der Aufbau jetzt aktuell noch relativ experimentell.
Auch ohne Steuerung.
Die Steuerung ist noch nicht ganz fertig.
Das heißt, bei mir ist das einfach nur angeschlossen.
Und ich check die Temperatur.
Alter!
Was? Wie? Moment.
Was bin ich sehend.
Früher hat man da einfach dran gedreht.
Und gut ist, das muss jetzt irgendwie Magic gesteuert werden.
Moment, jetzt wird's Advanced.
Die CPU heizt auch jetzt schon auf.
Bei mir ist das aktuell auch nur ein 40...
Ach nee, das heizt auf, dass das...
Ähm...
Das Verbindungsmaterial locker wird.
Oder?
50 Watt Heizelement.
Final kommt ein 50 Watt rein.
Einfach damit es noch ein kleines bisschen schneller geht.
Habe ich vorhin glaube ich nicht erwähnt.
Die CPU, die wir jetzt erhitzen und köpfen.
Die habe ich schon getestet.
Und die funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben natürlich schon mal Temperaturen aufgenommen mit Cinebench.
Und haben so Vergleichswerte, die wir uns dann auch anschauen können.
Ich will das später nochmal mit einer richtigen Retail-CPU machen.
Und jetzt aber erstmal schauen, ob es überhaupt...
Sind die verlötet?
Ich würde vermuten ja.
Diesen Kack, den Intel damals gemacht hat mit dem 8700K und der Wärmeleitpaste dazwischen.
Haben sie ja meines Wissens nach nicht mehr gemacht.
...funktioniert und ob die CPU überlebt.
Beim ersten Mal habe ich das Ganze schon mal aufgeheizt.
Allerdings ohne CPU.
Da hat es 25 Minuten gedauert.
Weil wir müssen mindestens 160 Grad Celsius erreichen.
Besser sind 165.
Dass wir ein bisschen Spielraum haben, wenn man das dann...
Ja, also wenn es dann ausgeht.
Just Incredible, das hast du nicht wirklich geglaubt, oder?
In der normalen Version soll es dann selber beim Erreichen der Temperatur,
bei der Zieltemperatur dann aufhören zu heizen.
Und dann muss man eben den Heatsplatter bewegen.
Also den Slider im Delitter, damit das Ganze sich dann löst.
Aber ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass es schon eine Weile dauern wird.
Und das ist ja nur der erste Schritt von zwei Heizschritten.
Nach 5 Minuten sind wir schon mal...
Jetzt wird es aber advanced.
Ich sehe da auch den Sinn für mich nicht drin, die CPU zu köpfen.
Bei 1700 hat das richtig was gebracht.
Ja, Chillfreak, meines Wissens nach,
Mal gucken, was die Messung da jetzt zeigt,
sind die Vorteile tatsächlich relativ gering.
Bei 75 Grad.
Aber das wird Geduld erfordern.
Nach 10 Minuten schon 117 Grad Celsius.
Wir sind jetzt bei 165 Grad Celsius.
Damit auf jeden Fall über der Schmelztemperatur
von dem Indium und versuchen das jetzt zu köpfen.
Oh, ich kann mich schon wieder erinnern,
an den Sound, den man bei 8700K
beim Köpfen gemacht hat, dieses Geknacke.
Ihr wollt nie Knack-Sounds aus einer CPU hören.
Ist übrigens nicht kaputt gegangen.
Läuft immer noch.
Habe ich hier neben dem Rechner noch drin.
Alles gut bei der Kiste.
Hat jahrelang ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Funktioniert immer noch.
Aber da habe ich echt geschwitzt bei,
wenn eine CPU knackt.
Das sollte jetzt ja nicht mehr so richtig knacken.
Weil das alles gelöst ist.
Er ist abgerutscht.
Oder?
War das das Knacksen von der CPU gerade?
Das hat mich auf jeden Fall viel mehr
an früher erinnern, wo die CPUs
nicht verlötet waren.
Also es lässt sich jetzt auch bewegen.
Heatspreader ist jetzt auf jeden Fall
lose.
Man könnte den nächsten Schritt jetzt in einem Schritt machen.
Das öffnen, während es heiß ist und den Heatspreader
runternehmen. Kann ich aber nicht empfehlen.
Viel Spaß, 170 Grad.
Weil da einfach zu viel schief gehen kann.
Deswegen machen wir das in einem zweiten Schritt.
Ich lasse es abkühlen,
baue alles auseinander und dann packen wir die CPU
Aber wenn es abkühlt, verlötet sich das dann nicht
wieder automatisch, wenn es aufeinander liegt?
CPU alleine wieder auf das Heizelement
und heizen die CPU nochmal auf.
Ohne den Delitter.
Um dann die Platine
von dem Heatspreader zu lösen.
Knappe Viertelstunde später.
Man sieht, die CPU liegt jetzt wieder drauf.
Hat Kontakt mit dem Temperatursensor,
der unten hoch steht.
An dem Heatspreader.
Und dann geht es deutlich schneller auf,
weil es einfach viel weniger Masse hat.
Und ab 160, 165
sollte ich die Platine abnehmen können.
Ah, ja.
Heatspreader ist unten geblieben.
Ist auch ein bisschen wärmer geworden,
als es eigentlich geplant war.
Wie gesagt, mir fehlt hier die Steuerung.
Finale Version wird an Temperatur gesteuert sein.
Aber wir sehen hier schon mal Heatspreader
und da hängt auch eine Menge Indium-Lot oben drin.
Und hier haben wir unsere
Arrow Lake CPU.
Wenn die wirklich quasi miteinander
verlötet sind, wird es am Ende halt auch nicht viel bringen.
Ich bin mal auf die Temperaturen gespannt.
Ob das irgendwie
messbaren Unterschied macht.
Sieht vollständig unbeschädigt aus.
Also SMDs an der Seite sehen sehr gut aus.
Kleber hat sich gut gelöst.
Und in der Mitte eben die Reste
vom Indium-Lot.
Jetzt werde ich erstmal hier vorsichtig
den Kleber abkratzen
und auch dann den Großteil vom Indium-Lot
und dann mit Flüssigmetall den Rest ablösen.
Ah, hier
guck mal.
Es gibt sogar mittlerweile eine offizielle
Silikon-Abkratztool
für CPUs von Thermal Grizzly.
Die haben aber alles am Start.
Der Großteil des Klebers
ist so ausreichend entfernt.
Jetzt geht es ans Indium.
Mit dem Flüssigmetall löse ich dann...
Ey, ich hätte echt Schiss, ganz ehrlich,
ich hätte Schiss auf meiner CPU so rumzureiben.
Selbst wenn es nur ein Stück Plastik ist.
Weil der Bauer weiß, was er macht, aber ich nicht.
Mit dem Flüssigmetall löse ich dann
den Rest ab.
Was ist das? Gutes Thermal Grizzly
Conductor
Kryonaut oder wie das Zeug heißt?
Ich muss das erstmal ein bisschen einwirken.
Wir montieren die CPU jetzt aber erstmal
mit dem original Heatspreader.
Dafür schneiden wir ein Cryo-Sheet
zu, packen das auf die CPU
Ein was? Ein was?
Da drauf.
Und jetzt probieren wir einfach
mit einem Wasserkühler Core One,
den legen wir einfach nur drauf, um zu gucken,
ob die CPU noch lebt.
Okay, der will einfach nur
gucken, bevor er es richtig fest drauf macht,
ob der Krempel nicht
kaputt gegangen ist dabei. Okay, leuchtet ein.
Wie wir sehen können,
ist es tatsächlich der Fall. Also,
erster dokumentierter Fall für uns,
geköpfte CPU hat überlebt.
Mittlerweile einen Monat später,
wie ihr sehen könnt, bin ich nicht draußen,
sondern ich bin gerade bei Asus in Taiwan,
habe die Möglichkeit die Intel Aerolink CPUs
285K zu testen
und ich habe jetzt auch eine CPU bekommen,
die wir gleich köpfen dürfen.
Also eine Retail-CPU, wo auch 285K
draufsteht, wo wir
auf Intels Nacken sozusagen,
selbst wenn sie kaputt geht, gleich auch mal
testen können, was ist denn Performance
und Temperatur.
Die CPU ist jetzt ganz gleich betrachtet,
wie man hier in CPU-Sets sehen kann,
einfach nur damit es einfacher zu liegen hat,
was ja auch der 80 Grad ist.
4,6 auf 4,9.
Und wenn wir in der Konfiguration jetzt den Cinebench A23
laufen lassen,
sehen wir rechts die Temperaturen.
Die haben dem doch da wahrscheinlich
eh eine super krasse CPU hingelegt,
oder? Eines der besten, die je vom
Fließband gelaufen ist.
Fließband gelaufen ist
vielleicht der falsche Ausdruck.
P-Cores ist halt ein bisschen schwer zu sehen,
weil hier P- und E-Cores ja immer gemischt sind
bei dieser CPU, aber wir sehen bei den
P-Cores so um die 80 Grad Celsius
und bei einigen von den E-Cores
so knapp unter 90 Grad Celsius.
Das ist eben davon abhängig,
an welcher Position sich die Kerne
befindet.
Und was bringt das jetzt?
Jetzt wird nochmal geköpft.
In den fast finalen Zügen,
also man sieht schon, der Delitter ist ein Stück weiter.
Wir haben hier das Heizelement mittlerweile
auch mit dem Temperatursensor hier,
der, sag ich mal, eingebaut ist.
Das Ding sieht mittlerweile richtig advanced aus.
Ich hab hier auch so ein Köpf-Ding,
nicht die der Bauer-Variante,
weil die war damals nicht lieferbar,
so ein anderes Ding. Das war super primitiv
für den 8700K, dieses Köpftool.
Da ist im Prinzip die CPU reingelegt
und dann, was war das?
Im Endeffekt irgendwie
Deckel drauf und dann geschraubt
und gut, das war's. Also beim
8700K hat das enorm viel gebracht.
Bei den Dingern glaube ich,
da bin ich mal gespannt am Ende,
bei den Dingern glaube ich,
bringt das nicht so viel.
Wir haben dafür jetzt auch einen Controller.
Auch hier ist es erstmal angedeutet,
also das Gehäuse wird später schwarz
und anders aussehen. Das ist dann gefräst.
Das ist jetzt erstmal ein 3D gedrucktes Teil,
was wir jetzt testen können.
Und hier wird dann eben der Temperatursensor
und das Heizelement angeschlossen.
Da haben wir drei Knöpfe.
Es ist schon deutlich advancer als damals.
Für die Steuereinheit muss 65 Watt USB-C sein.
Ich nehme da einfach mein Laptop-Ladegerät.
Das wird auch nicht im Lieferumfang dabei sein,
sondern nur so das Teil an sich,
weil ich mir denke...
Guck mal, die Displays kennen wir, ne?
Das ist so ein ganz normales
SD...
Ich weiß, das sind diese 0815
Diese 0815 Standard-Displays
Oh ja, das brauche ich jetzt.
Andrea Berg, ganz wichtig.
Ne, wie heißen die denn nochmal?
Welche im... ne?
Die kleinen, da habe ich sogar hier noch welche
in der Schublade liegen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Zumindest sind die Displays nicht verkehrt.
Das sind so diese Standard 0815
Microcontroller-Projekt-Displays
Hier, diese Dinger.
SSH, das könnte ich schon...
Aber diese Displays hier meine ich.
SDD, da ist es doch,
hier, da stand es doch.
SDD, die meine ich doch, genau die.
war schon mit sd gar nicht so verkehrt ja das ist ein standard display für so
kleine projekte die tun einfach deutlich was ist denn das da unten drunter ist
das noch weil das so groß ist es noch irgendeinen arduino oder so was weil
das ist ein großes teil was ist denn das kapitel irgendwie eine idee dafür
controller drin ist neben raspberry pi pico sieht es nicht so groß nicht so
und nicht so quadratisch eure machen und die meisten haben auch ein usb lade
gerät zu hause dass man sieht es ja auch nicht richtig durch hat und wenn ich
dann kann es sich auch lohnt so was zu kaufen ist gut um handy und laptop und
sonst was zu laden genau und hier gibt es eben die
möglichkeit die temperatur einzustellen dass wir einmal set und china kasten
kann ich über die köpfe hier oben ja das stimmt dass er gut dass das board wird
custom sein das stimmt schon interessiert aber was sie für für ein
microsoft
controller aufwenden ja die haben schon recht das bord das ist ziemlich sicher
kreisen und senken standardwert ist 165 grad celsius das ist das wo wir hin
wollen wenn ich dann hier rechts den knopf
drücken dann geht das heiz element an der stetiger hito an da steht auch mit
wieviel watt das heizt 55 watt und dann wird das eben warm und also auf jeden
fall das ist auf jeden fall kein linux based system also auch kein banana pie
oder sowas 60 grad das ist irgendwas kassen tinau dann also kasten bohrer
mit einer karte wenn sie auch auf einen schnitt an tausend watt prozent thirteen
water
mit vielleicht sogar einem ESP32,
ich weiß ja nicht, die Dinger würden sich ja super
eignen für so eine Plattform.
Geht es auch aus, um das Ding dann nicht
weiter zu erhitzen.
Oder wirklich einen Raspberry Pi Pico,
das kannst du ja mit allem machen.
Musst ein paar Relays ansteuern
und ein Display, das kannst du
mit jedem 0815 Controller machen.
Und jetzt hole ich die CPU aus dem
System raus, wir packen die hier rein
und dann machen wir das gleiche,
was wir schon mal gemacht haben, einfach nochmal
mit der Retail-CPU.
Professional Fire-Resistant
Surface.
Also gleiches Spiel wie beim ersten Versuch.
Warum ist das so blutig an der Seite?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur Farbe, das sieht aber gefährlich aus.
Das Spiel wie beim ersten Versuch.
Erst die CPU in den Delidder und anschließend
beides zusammen in den Heater.
Ich hab da ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste auf den Temperaturfühler gepackt,
einfach damit der Kontakt zur CPU dann auch
entsprechend gut ist.
Anschließend Heater aktivieren und wieder ungefähr
10 bis 20 Minuten warten.
Wir haben dann noch ein zweites Thermometer
parallel dazu angeschlossen, einfach nur um
erstmal zu checken, ob auch die ausgelesene Temperatur
bei unserer Steuereinheit stimmt.
Und es kam so in etwa hin, weil es bei einer anderen Location
wo gemessen wurde.
Das ist wirklich der komplizierteste
Kopfprozess ever.
Knack, gleich.
Ja.
Er war abgerutscht.
Nee, jetzt ist...
Danach alles abkühlen lassen bei etwas über 30°C.
Und dann den Delidder wieder aus dem Heater genommen
und dann auch wieder die CPU aus dem Delidder.
In dem Zustand seht ihr, wie der Heatspadder verschoben ist,
aber wieder fest sitzt.
Also wir haben den Kleber schon gelöst,
aber das Indium ist jetzt ja wieder erstarrt.
Deswegen jetzt wieder die CPU mit dem Heatspadder
nach unten auf das Heizelement.
Wieder schauen, dass der Temperaturfühler entsprechend
auf dem Heatspadder anliegt, damit es richtig ausgelesen wird.
Wieder aufheizen, dauert so 1 bis 2 Minuten
und dann bei 165°C Platine abnehmen.
Ich muss jetzt die CPU noch reinigen.
Natürlich habe ich die Acryl-Schraube
vergessen, sonst nehme ich einfach ein Acryl-Gehäuse
von Elmar.
Ich habe die Maske geborgt.
Jetzt muss man die CPU sauber machen.
Ich habe jetzt noch Flüssigmetall drauf gemacht.
Lass es jetzt wieder einwirken, wahrscheinlich 2-3 Mal,
damit ich alles vom Indium restlos abnehmen kann.
Ich habe jetzt schon die CPU soweit vorbereitet,
habe die CPU hier
aus Bord gepackt und habe auch gerade
den Wasserkühler schon mal montiert.
Ich mache es jetzt einfach mal an.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt,
vorher und nachher vergleich.
Der Loop angeschlossen ist,
um zu schauen, ob die CPU alive ist.
Ich spule mal kurz über sie vor.
Ich glaube, ich hätte es vorhin erwähnt,
aber sie ist echt nicht mehr im besten Zustand.
Die benutzt Asus hier mal zum Testen.
Nochmal 5°C, also
ein 360°C Komplett-Wasserkühlung.
EK-Komponenten,
ich kann euch sagen,
das alles an dem Kühler,
das niedrige Temperatur ist wirklich krass.
Das alles an dem Kühler dran.
Ich lasse es jetzt für euch nochmal laufen.
Ich kann euch sagen,
wirklich Temperatur,
Sturz als niedrige Temperatur ist wirklich krass.
Echt?
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich hätte gedacht, es macht so gut wie keinen Unterschied.
Also, gleiches Szenario wie das,
was wir gerade eben schon hatten.
Es sind genau die gleichen Einstellungen,
die ich im BIOS wieder geladen habe.
Kann ich natürlich auch nochmal ganz kurz zeigen,
also die CPU.
Vielleicht ist es auch GBA,
denn wir sind am Ende ein halbes Grad oder so.
Läuft nach wie vor bei 5,4 auf den P-Cores
und 4,9 auf den E-Cores,
wenn man das hier sehen kann.
Das ist auch genau die gleiche Spannung,
die eingestellt ist.
Ich lasse es jetzt nochmal laufen.
Und wir switchen mal kurz rüber auf die Temperaturen.
Sieht man jetzt Temperaturen zwischen 50 und 60.
Also, das ist echt nicht viel für volle Pulle.
Na gut, es hat eine Wasserkühlung drauf,
hat meine auch,
aber das ist ja kein Banane-Rezipio.
Sogar deutlich weniger als ich das dachte.
Ich dachte, okay, es sind halt vielleicht irgendwie 10,
15 Grad, aber...
Warte, ich hätte gedacht,
es ist so gut wie nichts zwischen eigener Ligierung
und
quasi
Werkszustand.
Unfassbar,
wie viel kühler das jetzt läuft.
Und der Score ist so
44.600.
Und warum ist das so viel besser?
Ich meine, das ist ja vorher auch
metallmäßig verlötet.
Wie kann das sein?
Da muss man auch dazu sagen,
die CPU war vorher am Limit.
Also 90 Grad mehr war da nicht drin.
Ich konnte auch nicht höher takten auf den P-Cores.
Sie hat ja da 5,4.
Das ist ja ein Ried, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Das ist ja eine riesen...
Übersehe ich da jetzt irgendwie was?
Giga hat es nur gemacht und
mehr war einfach nicht drin,
weil die CPU dann so warm war,
dass ich die Schwalben auch nicht mehr anheben konnte.
Das werde ich jetzt gleich mal probieren und gucken,
ob ich dann vielleicht auf 5,5 oder vielleicht sogar 5,6 komme,
auch ob die E-Cores höher gehen.
Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile ein bisschen Feintuning gemacht
am System und bin jetzt bei 5,716.
Also man kann bei der CPU...
Ja gut, Intel hat Ihnen bestimmt auch eine super, super CPU gegeben.
Das ja in 16 MHz-Schritten einstellen vom Multiplikator her,
also 5,716 bei den P-Cores,
5,1 auf den E-Cores
und das funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Erstmal ein Lauf noch mit Hardware-Info offen,
dafür nehmen wir halt ein bisschen Performance,
aber wirklich die Temperaturen, das ist absolut krass.
Hier der P-Core...
Meint er nicht, dass es den Retail-CPU,
den Retail-CPU, die er im Interlink gelegt hat?
Ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwie jetzt was gefakt hat,
auf gar keinen Fall.
Also ich traue...
Ich halte ihn für einen, der, sagen wir mal,
einen der besten und, wie nennt man das so,
realitätsnähersten Hardware-YouTube-Channels.
Aber wer weiß, was im Intel da hingelegt hat,
die haben sich doch bestimmt,
die haben sich doch bestimmt da irgendwie die Top-CPU rausgesucht,
bevor sie die ihm hingelegt haben.
12 ist nach wie vor der wärmste, 70 Grad Celsius
und selbst mit Hardware-Info offen sind wir bei 46.700.
Jetzt nochmal ohne Hardware-Info haben wir 47.100 Punkte,
also es ist wirklich, wirklich krass,
was man da noch rausholen kann.
Plutscht.
Das ist wirklich ein Hammer-Score für eine wassergekühlte,
im Prinzip 8-Kern-CPU.
Natürlich nur noch mit den E-Cores, die auch sehr, sehr stark sind,
aber wirklich ein sehr, sehr schnelles Ergebnis.
Wieder knapp ein Monat später
und die CPUs sind jetzt mittlerweile auch verfügbar.
Jetzt müssen wir Bescheid.
Auch unsere Produkte sind jetzt verfügbar,
zumindest mal der Contact Frame,
der Micro Direct Die Wasserkühler,
der hier wird zum Zeitpunkt dieses Videos schon Version.
Der 285K kann an sich nicht viel,
was er aber gut kann,
und das ist tatsächlich Cinebench A23.
Aero Lake Köpfen ist definitiv sehr komplex,
hat aber auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht,
die ganzen Sachen zu entwickeln
und die Temperaturvorteile, die man bekommt,
sind halt auch wirklich ordentlich.
Also wenn man dann 285K geköpft,
selbst mit starkem Overclocking,
bei irgendwo 60 bis 65 Grad Celsius halten kann,
dann ist es schon krass
und dann ist auch die CPU von dem,
was sie an Multi-Threading Performance bietet,
auch wirklich, wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Damit verabschiede ich mich.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, das macht halt keiner.
Die meisten Leute haben schon Probleme,
ins BIOS zu kommen.
Aber ich kann mir schon wieder krasse Hackerman vor,
damals als ich den 8700K geköpft habe.
Och ja, wichtig, das muss man sich unbedingt angucken.
Okay, es gibt ein neues Update.
Wieder 59 Sekunden.
Okay, zeig her.
Nicht zu heiß machen.
Ja, man sollte vielleicht das Wasser nicht trinken danach
oder da einen Pudding draus machen.
Aber ich glaube, das hätten auch die wenigsten Leute,
also die meisten Leute, davon abgesehen.
Ah.
Ja.
Die Temperatur ist viel kontrollierbarer.
Größtes Problem ist Recall, auf das ich keinen Bock habe.
... und das Windows 11 24H2 Update ist ein ziemlicher Clusterfuck.
Irgendwann musste es so kommen.
Ist das so?
MonkaS!
Wer hätte denn gedacht, dass man Chaos reinkriegt, wenn man Betriebssysteme in drei Entwicklungszeigen,
vier Insider-Kanälen und gefühlt zehn SKUs anbietet und Features gefühlt rein zufällig rauf und runter mergt?
Ja gut, bei Microsoft ist eh alles in der Hoffnung verloren, was da Windows-Entwicklung sagt.
... dabei jemals irgendeine Qualitätskontrolle durchzuführen.
Nun, das Resultat sehen wir jetzt mit Windows 11 24H2.
24H2 ist im Gegensatz zu 23H2 wieder ein großes Feature-Update.
Ah Moment, Updates aussetzen? Das mach ich mal kurz.
Äh, nur mal so, also...
... eine ganze Menge verändert.
Ich will das nicht.
Und offenbar damit auch eine ganze Menge kaputt macht.
Es ist ein hervorragendes Beispiel dafür, was aktuell bei Microsoft schiefläuft und nein,
ich möchte nicht darüber reden.
Das ist ein Thema für ein ganz anderes Video.
Was ich aber sagen will ist, I can fix him.
Weil es sonst keiner macht, sprechen wir heute über die Probleme.
Ich zeige euch, was ihr tun könnt, wenn ihr von diesen Problemen betroffen seid, wie ihr sie lösen könnt,
wenn ihr bereits 24H2 installiert habt.
Und ich sage euch auch dazu, wenn euch das Update nicht über Windows Update angeboten wird
und ihr nicht zwingend Lust habt, Zeit damit zu verbringen, euer Windows zu reparieren,
dann installiert es bitte einfach nicht, indem ihr das Update zum Beispiel erzwingt.
Ja.
Wobei, all diese Probleme sind nicht allzu schwerwiegend und man kommt schon drum herum,
wenn man weiß, was man tut oder wenn man bereits WindowsArea.de abonniert hat.
Zum Beispiel ist das erste bekannte Problem von Windows 11 24H2 mehr ein Anzeigefehler
und somit ein vergleichsweise kleiner Bug als wirklich ein Problem.
Nachdem ihr frisch das Windows 11 24H2 Update macht, speichert Windows bekanntlich ein Backup
der vorherigen Version, für den Fall, dass etwas schief geht und man auf den vorherigen
Zustand zurückkehren muss.
Das bezeichnet Microsoft als Rollback.
Und man sieht diese alte Windows-Version in den Einstellungen bei Speicher unter Temporärdateien
als Windows-Update-Bereinigung.
Normalerweise kann man diesen Update-Cache einfach über die Speichereinstellungen bereinigen
lassen und diese verschwinden dann.
Spark sorgt aber aktuell dafür, dass in Windows 24H2 diese Update-Bereinigung falsch angezeigt wird.
Das ist jetzt ja nichts Schlimmes, aber ich frage mich dann allen Ernstes, probieren die
den Kram vorher nicht aus?
Machen die das, wie ich vorhin scherzweise vorgeschlagen habe?
Gehen die davon aus, sie programmieren immer fehlerfrei und rein damit?
Von Heise?
Von... du meinst von... von denen hier?
Oder wirklich bei Heise?
Nein, nein.
Nee, von denen nicht.
Und dort auch nach der Bereinigung scheinbar 8,63 GB überbleiben.
Das stimmt aber nicht.
Die Bereinigung funktioniert...
Ach so, du meinst für...
Ja, du meinst dieses Video, das haben wir geguckt.
Dieses Video, was alles für Probleme gerade bei Windows 24H2 ist.
Ja, das...
Der Speicher wurde auch tatsächlich erfolgreich freigegeben, aber...
Microsoft hat die Tests outgesourced, ja, an die User.
Diesen Fehler hat Microsoft bereits offiziell bestätigt und man dürfte diesen mit einem
kleineren Update in der Zukunft noch beheben.
Keine Sorge also, euer Speicher ist tatsächlich nicht davon betroffen.
Ebenfalls ein solches Force-Positive ist der aktuelle System-File-Checker-Bug.
Sfce, also der System-File-Checker, ist eine Windows-Funktion, welche Systemdateien überprüfen
und reparieren kann.
Aha.
Bei Windows 24H2 findet der Kommandozeilenbefehl sfc slash scan now scheinbar immer einen Fehler
und versucht diesen dann zu beheben.
In Wahrheit ist aber einfach Sfc momentan kaputt und somit aktuell unbrauchbar.
Nicht, dass die Funktion ansonsten allzu nützlich ist, aber mit 24H2 ist er erstmal...
Ja, Bro, die probieren den Scheiß nicht aus.
...vollkommen dysfunktional, bis Microsoft nicht in wenigen Wochen ein kleines Bugfix-Update
ausholt.
Und warum braucht das wenige Wochen?
Schwerwiegenderes Problem von Windows 24H2 ist das Verschwinden von Mauszeigern.
Was?
In Chromium-basierten Anwendungen.
Okay.
Keine Sorge, wir arbeiten uns hier langsam zu den schwerwiegenderen Problemen durch.
Das hier ist so quasi ein Iceberg-Video.
Leider aber in dem Fall teilweise nur mit Symptombekämpfung.
Betroffen vom Mauszeiger-Problem sind natürlich Google Chrome, aber witzigerweise natürlich
auch Microsoft Edge sowie auch beispielsweise die Co-Pilot-App, weil sie ist nicht mehr
als ein Browser-Fenster.
Lösen könnt ihr es nicht, aber falls ihr das Problem habt, könnt ihr es zumindest
erstmal umgehen.
Öffnet dafür die Mauseigenschaften, was am einfachsten geht...
Das wirkt auch auf Elektronik.
Indem ihr main.cpl in die Windows-Suche eingibt.
Main.cpl.
Alles klar.
Gut, dass wir wieder 50.000 Untermenüs haben.
Beziehungsweise alte Menüs, ältere Menüs, neue Menüs, halbneue Menüs.
Gehen wir zu Zeiger und wählen dann einfach einen anderen Mauszeiger für die Textauswahl,
indem ihr einfach da den Doppelklick drauf macht und dann beam-r als Mauszeiger dafür
festlegt.
Bestätigt die Änderungen mit übernehmen oder okay.
Und dieses Problem von 24H2 wird euch danach nicht mehr auf den Zeiger bringen.
Ebenfalls ein Problem, wobei man momentan keine Lösung von Microsoft bekommt, wobei
diese schon in Arbeit sein soll, betrifft den Zwischenablagenverlauf von Windows 11.
Ist ansonsten ein recht praktisches Feature, das man mit der Tastenkombination Windows
und V öffnen kann.
Aktuell funktioniert die bei einigen Nutzern nicht mehr richtig, denn sie wird vollkommen
als leer angezeigt, obwohl man gerade einige Elemente kopiert hat.
Es betrifft aber nur Nutzer, welche die Suggested Actions bzw. die vorgeschlagenen Aktionen
aktiviert haben, welche aber nur in Nordamerika verfügbar sind.
Wenn ihr Windows 11 in Englisch mit USA als Region nutzt, dann werdet ihr eben diese Suggested
Actions deaktivieren müssen, welche ihr in den Einstellungen unter System und dann bei
Zwischenablage findet.
Wenn wir etwas tiefer eintauchen bei unserem Iceberg hier, gelangen wir auch zu den ersten
Bluescreens, die aber hauptsächlich auf unoptimierte Treiber zurückzuführen sind und nicht allein
auf das Update.
Ganz ehrlich, Bluescreen ist das letzte, was man möchte nach einem Update.
April für Insider verfügbar und da wäre ganz ehrlich genug Zeit gewesen für die Hersteller,
ihre Treiber und Software damit.
Man könnte aber auch sagen, Microsoft sollte ein Update nicht bringen, was Treiber, die
vollkommen funktionsfähig waren unter der letzten Dings, also die sollen sie zumindest
checken vorher, ob das installiert ist und das Update abbrechen.
Testen wenigstens.
Betroffen ist einerseits der Intel Smart Sound Technology Driver, kurz Intel SST, welcher
auf Geräten mit Intel Core Prozessoren nötig ist.
Nur der 11.
Generation unter Windows 11 24H2 zu Bluescreens führen kann.
Betroffen ist dabei die Treiber-Version mit der Nummer .5152 am Ende, was eben Gerätemanager
beim Intel SSD Audio Controller unter Eigenschaften und dann bei Treiber dieses Update holen kann.
Moment, jetzt habe ich irgendwie Mist getippt, oder?
Wo waren wir dann?
Stehen geblieben?
Die Treiber-Signatur neuer ist als...
Hatten wir das schon?
...Elden Ring.
...Auch das gewünschte Spiel.
...Gerät mit Intel Prozessor, Intel SST, welcher auf Geräten mit Intel Core Prozessoren nur
der 11.
Generation unter Windows 11 24H2 zu Bluescreens führen kann.
Okay, jetzt hoffen wir ja.
...Betroffen ist dabei die Treiber-Version...
Intel, wo wird Device Manager?
Audio.
Was muss ich gucken?
Da bin ich schon richtig, oder?
Ne, hier.
Okay, kann auch sein, dass ich Device Manager als...
...Gerätemanager...
als Admin. Okay, wir machen jetzt
Trick 17. Wir starten CMD.
Run as Administrator. Ja, ja, ja.
Super krass. Geheim. Noch nie gesehen.
Und jetzt sagen wir, Device.
Wie macht man
CMD Start Device Manager?
Was muss man da starten?
Dev MGMT
MSC. Das ist aber auch nicht mehr.
Also dann würde ich
obviously, logisch, ne?
Dann würde ich mal sagen,
dann habe ich keine Intel
Smart Sound Technology.
Installiert.
Da steht nix.
Und da steht nix.
Gucke ich richtig? Ja.
Okay.
View. Aber da ist
auch nix.
Da ist auch kein Intel.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Daniel Lull.
Das heißt, ich bin schon mal safe
vor Blue Screens. Nice. Gut zu wissen.
Mit der Nummer
Punkt 5152 am Ende,
was eben Gerätemanager beim
Intel
SSD Audio Controller
unter eigenem... Ich habe keine 11...
Das stimmt. 11th... 11th.
11th Generation CPU.
Das stimmt. Ja. Ich habe 13.900K.
... und dann bei Treiber
unter Treiberversion herausfinden könnt.
Wenn ihr eine 5152
am Ende stehen habt, dann müsst ihr zuerst
den Treiber updaten, bevor ihr eben
24H2 installiert. Dies könnt ihr
entweder über die offizielle Webseite des Treiberherstellers
machen, beziehungsweise des Geräteherstellers,
oder aber wesentlich einfacher,
der neue Treiber sollte ohnehin
automatisch in Windows Update angeboten werden.
Guckt dabei am besten einfach unter
Windows Update nach, ob ihr da ein Treiber
Update bekommt und prüft auch nach, ob
dieses eventuell in den erweiterten
Optionen bei optionale Updates angeboten
wird. Wählt da das Häkchen aus, installiert
den benötigten Treiber... Ich mach da gar nichts.
... und dann seid ihr auch schon safe für 24H2.
Die neuen Treiber... Geil. Und wenn man das
vorher nicht macht?
... Version erkennt ihr an der Endung
5714 oder höher.
Und keine Sorge, wenn ihr den
alten Treiber noch drauf habt, dann wird euch
das Windows 11 24H2 Update
gar nicht zur Installation angeboten. Ja, sehr schön.
Denn Microsoft hat für diese Geräte das Update
momentan blockiert. Gut. Wenn ihr es auf
einem Gerät mit Intel-Prozessor der
11. Generation manuell durchführen wollt, installiert
aber definitiv bitte vorher den neuen
Treiber. Etwas schwerwiegender ist da
schon das Problem mit Easy-Anti-Cheat,
wo es ebenfalls auf Intel-Maschinen momentan
zu Blue-Screens kommt. Schlecht. Konkret betroffen
sind hier von Intels Prozessoren der 12.
Generation sowie die vPro-Plattformen,
wo es bei der Ausführung von Games
mit einem veralteten Easy-Anti-Cheat,
von vor April 2024
zu einem Memory-Management-Blue-Screen
kommt. Hier ist die Problemlösung
aber etwas komplizierter, denn euer
Easy-Anti-Cheat-Treiber muss neuer sein
als April 2024
und dann wird es kein Problem geben mit
24H2. Das kommt aber wiederum
drauf an, ob das gewünschte Spiel
auch den Easy-Anti-Cheat aktualisiert hat.
Betroffen sein könnten somit alle Games
mit Easy-Anti-Cheat. Dazu gehören
Apex Legends, Call of Duty, Fortnite,
Destiny, Rocket League, Elden Ring,
iRacing und potenziell viele mehr.
Ihr solltet daher als erstes prüfen,
ob für diese Games überhaupt noch ein Update
für den Anti-Cheat verfügbar ist.
Startet das Game dazu einfach mal und
dann sollte Easy-Anti-Cheat
automatisch Updates installieren.
Da fragt man sich echt, probieren die den Scheiß vorher nicht aus.
Eigen Easy-Anti-Cheat-Version
und das macht die Sache noch etwas komplizierter.
Ihr könnt aber im Prinzip in den Programme
x86... Was geht da im Hintergrund
gerade ab? Ist das ein Hundeohr?
Ist ein Hundeohr, oder?
Noch etwas komplizierter. Oder was ist das?
Ihr könnt aber im Prinzip in den
Programme x86-Ordner zu Easy-Anti-Cheat
reinschauen und dort prüfen, ob die
Treiber-Signatur neuer ist als
April 2024. Wenn ja,
dann seid ihr eventuell safe für das
Windows-L24-H2-Update.
Der Installationsassistent wird allerdings tatsächlich
eine Fehlermeldung anzeigen, wenn ihr mit einer
inkompatiblen Version des Treibers versucht,
das Update zu installieren.
Das war nicht der Frankia Z.
Dieses Emote verwendet auch keiner mehr.
Das war mal früher so, begab allen Speedrun-Channels.
Die haben alle der Frankia Z gespammt immer.
Wenn ihr aber eine Internetmaschine mit
PC oder Prozessoren der 12. Generation habt
und ihr viele Games zockt mit Easy-Anti-Cheat,
dann würde ich aber erstmal nicht empfehlen,
das 24-H2-Update zu installieren.
Microsoft hat auch hier eine Update-Blockade
in Kraft gesetzt, sodass ihr euch auch
nicht automatisch per Windows-Update
dieses Update holen könnt.
Ein anderes Problem betrifft...
Ja, wir sind indirekt angestellte Tester bei Microsoft.
Momentan unter Windows-L24-H2
auch Nutzer von Western Digital
NVMe-SSDs.
Habe ich nicht.
Alter!
...kommen, welche mit der Fehlermeldung
Critical Process has died...
Was ist das?
Das wollen die mich verarschen?
...oder Kernel-Data-In-Page-Error
dargestellt werden.
In der Ereignisanzeige wird dann
The driver detected a controller error
on device RAID-Port 1 or 2 angezeigt,
was auf ein Problem mit dem SSD-Controller schließen lässt.
Das Problem hängt damit zusammen,
dass einige WD-SSD-Controller
einen Host-Memory-Buffer von 200 MB anfordern.
Ich habe zu Glück nur Samsung-SSDs.
Aber du musst ja mit dem SSD-Controller
mittlerweile Angst haben,
dass du irgendwann mal was verbaut hast,
was auch Probleme macht.
...H2 war es so, dass nur 64 MB gewährt wurden,
womit es eben keine Probleme gab.
24 H2 gewährt dem Controller,
aber dann die vollen 200 MB,
weswegen es eben anscheinend zu den Problemen kommt.
...hat Western Digital tatsächlich reagiert
und eine neue Firmware für seine betroffenen SSDs ausgerollt.
Ihr müsst dafür zur offiziellen Seite von SanDisk
bzw. Western Digital navigieren.
Die haben wir euch unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Und dort könnt ihr euch auch noch ein paar Sachen ansehen.
Und dort findet ihr einen Installer
für das Western Digital Dashboard.
Darüber könnt ihr die neue Firmware für eure SSD installieren,
indem ihr einfach...
Das Problem ist eigentlich bei WD,
das kann schon sein,
aber letztendlich muss Microsoft trotzdem sicherstellen,
dass was vor dem Update funktioniert, auch nach dem Update.
Selbst wenn es ein Fehler ist.
Sonst hast du ja das gleiche Problem wie unter Linux,
wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
wo da erstmal diskutiert wird,
ist es der Browser, die Mesa-Treiber,
der Kernel selbst oder was, whatever.
...nach Updates sucht.
Das neueste Update sollte dort tatsächlich direkt dann
...nach Updates suchen.
Und daraufhin könnt ihr auch ohne Probleme
das Windows 11 24 H2 Update installieren.
Und da gibt es dann auch keine Notwendigkeit
für irgendwelche Workarounds
oder irgendwelche Registry Tweaks.
Also ihr könnt,
wenn ihr eine der betroffenen SSDs habt,
die tatsächlich auf der offiziellen Seite
von Western Digital auch aufgelistet sind,
dann könnt ihr mittlerweile mit der neuen Firmware
auch 24 H2 installieren.
Es geht aber noch schlimmer.
Und damit kommen wir zu dem schwerwiegenderen Problem
mit Windows 11 24 H2, wo momentan weder ein Workaround noch irgendein Treiber-Update helfen kann.
Hier muss man dann so zusagen, die folgenden vier Probleme sind ähnlich wie die Schwierigkeiten mit Anti-Cheat,
hauptsächlich den einzelnen Hardware- und Softwareherstellern zuzuschreiben und nicht so sehr Microsoft.
Wir wollen aber nicht allzu easy sein hier auf Microsoft.
Ja, Windows 11 crasht hier tatsächlich mit einem Blue Screen, aber genau wie wir das damals mit CrowdStrike hatten,
zerschießen aktuell ältere und nicht optimierte Treiber das System und nicht so sehr ein Windows-Bug.
Da gibt es einerseits ein Problem auf einigen Asus-Geräten, die momentan das 24 H2-Update nicht erfolgreich installieren können.
Beim Versuch der Installation bricht diese mit einem Blue Screen ab und muss zur freijährigen Version wiederhergestellt werden.
Windows 11 schafft das normalerweise recht zuverlässig selbst, aber unbedingt darauf ankommen lassen würde ich es persönlich nicht.
Konkret hiervon betroffen sind immerhin nur das Asus VivoBook 14 x415Ka.
Ja gut, juck mich, juck mich.
Sowie das Asus VivoBook 15 x415Ka, jeweils mit dem Intel N6000 Prozessor.
Ich hoffe aber, dass niemand von euch dieses Notebook wirklich gekauft hat.
Also jetzt ganz unabhängig von diesem Problem, keine Empfehlung.
Aber wenn ja, dann ist euer Gerät nicht mit Windows 11 24 H2 kompatibel.
Laut Microsoft liegt das an einer nicht näher definierten Hardware-Inkompatibilität
und man arbeitet bereits mit Asus daran, dieses Problem zu beheben.
Betroffene Nutzer sollten das Update im Windows-Update eben auch beachten.
Je nachdem, je nachdem wie alt das ist, wird es da nie was geben.
Keine Ahnung, ob das ein semi-neues Notebook ist.
Einige Geräte mit älteren Treibern für den Fingerabdruckscanner könnten ebenfalls nach der Installation von Windows 11 24 H2 diese Funktionalität verlieren.
Das Problem verursacht immerhin keine Blue Screens, sondern nur, dass der Fingerabdruckscanner dann nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und betroffen sind laut Microsoft nur eine sehr kleine Liste an Geräten.
Wenn ihr merkt, dass nach der Installation von Windows 11 24 H2 der Fingerabdruckscanner nicht mehr funktioniert,
dann könnt ihr eventuell auf der Herstellerseite prüfen, ob dafür ein neuer Treiber vorhanden ist.
Wenn ja, dann könnt ihr den Treiber über den Gerätemanager über biometrische Geräte einfach deinstallieren
und dann eine neuere Version stattdessen installieren lassen.
Ebenfalls vom selben Problem betroffen ist das Programm SafeXamBrowser,
das ebenfalls seine Treiber nicht für die neueste 24 H2-Version aktualisiert hat.
Das Programm benutzt nämlich ähnlich wie EasyAntiCheat oder CrowdTribe
einen tief im System integrierten Treiber, um zu prüfen, ob ihr bei euren Tests tatsächlich nicht schummelt.
Blöderweise haben die Macher dieses Programms nicht damit gerechnet,
dass etwa seit 2015 jedes Jahr eine neue Windows-Version rauskommt
und sie haben ihre Software eben nicht damit getestet.
Wenn ihr das Programm nicht mehr braucht, dann könnt ihr es einfach deinstallieren
und das Windows 11 24 H2-Update soll...
Ich hab noch nicht mal verstanden, wie die Software überhaupt heißt.
Wenn ihr es aber braucht, dann müsst ihr warten, bis der SafeXamBrowser aktualisiert wurde mit dem neuen Treiber,
damit ihr...
Wusste ich nicht, dass es existiert, will ich auch gar nicht wissen, was es ist.
...11 24 H2 bekommen könnt.
Microsoft hat das Update immerhin für diese Geräte blockiert,
sodass System-Admins in Schulen oder Unis jetzt keine Panik haben.
Und dasselbe Problem betrifft auch das Programm VoiceMeter von AB Audio Software.
Ah, das hab ich früher, das hab ich früher verwendet.
Hier kommt es ebenfalls zu Memory Management Blue Screens,
weil die Software offenbar auch einen unoptimierten Treiber ausliefert,
welcher mit 24 H2 nicht funktioniert.
Und wir kommen schließlich zum finalen Boss der Windows 11 24 H2-Update-Probleme,
das tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass euer PC einfach keine Internetverbindung herstellen kann.
Das erleben gerade einige Nutzer auf ihren PCs nach der Installation von 24 H2 und...
Ich hab's tatsächlich selber auf meinen Computern auch gelegentlich beobachtet.
Dabei bekommt ihr bei einer Verbindung mit einem Kabelnetzwerk,
gelegentlich auch mit dem WLAN, einfach keine IP-Adresse zugewiesen.
Ist scheinbar ein Problem mit dem Netzwerkprotokoll, das tatsächlich mit 24 H2 zusammenhängt.
Und es kann anscheinend helfen, eine statische IP für den Betroffenen...
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Die haben doch nicht allen Ernstes DHCP kaputt gemacht.
Eines der most basic Sachen aller Zeiten, Alter.
Wie kann man das ernsthaft schaffen, DHCP kaputt zu machen?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
...nicht nach festzulegen.
Die einzige echte Lösung ist im Moment aber tatsächlich Windows 11 24 H2 zu vermeiden und auf 23 H2...
Ich hab, glaube ich, sogar eine feste IP eingestellt bei mir, aber trotzdem...
...ist ganz einfach. Und wenn ihr die alte Windows-Version noch nicht gelöscht habt,
dann könnt ihr ohne eine neue Installation auf Windows 11 23 H2 zurückkehren.
Dazu navigiert ihr in den Einstellungen zu System und dann zu Wiederherstellung.
Wo ihr unten bei Wiederherstellungsoptionen den Knopf Zurückkehren finden werdet.
Klickt dort einfach drauf und geht dann weiter und übersteht ihr Update-Bild.
Klickt euch hier in den Assistenten weiter und wählt, dass ihr zu einer vorherigen Bild zurückkehren wollt.
Dann wird Windows 11 23 H2 wieder auf euren PC installiert und zahlreiche der erwähnten Probleme sollten...
Warum die das überhaupt ausliefern, ist mir schleierhaft.
Du kannst doch nicht was ausliefern mit einer kaputten DHCP-Implementierung.
...vorhanden sein.
Now, that's a lot of damage.
Ähm...
Wie bereits im April dieses Jahres in unseren Videos angesprochen,
hätte ja Windows 11 24 H2 ursprünglich als Windows 12 rauskommen sollen,
wegen...
Echt jetzt?
...in der ganzen KI-Sache.
Es ist also unter der Haube ein größeres Update als normal oder als es vielleicht erscheint
und modernisiert tatsächlich unter der Haube eine ganze Reihe von Windows-Komponenten im System.
Darunter den Netzwerken, YouTube-Stack, zahlreiche Dinge im Kernel,
was Windows 11 eben tatsächlich bereit machen soll,
für seine KI-generierte Zukunft und...
...die keiner außer Microsoft haben will, Alter.
...eben auch die neuen KI-PCs, die ja alle langsam dieses Jahr rauskommen werden.
Viele Software-Entwickler haben einfach nicht mit so vielen Veränderungen gerechnet
und man muss auch sagen, Microsoft hat das im Vorfeld auch überhaupt nicht kommuniziert.
Ja.
Wer also nicht im Insider-Programm drin ist, der hätte das auch nicht wissen können.
Die meisten dieser Probleme sind nicht unlösbar, erfordern allerdings Treiber-Updates von unterschiedlichen Software- und Hardware-Herstellern,
weswegen ich momentan echt sagen muss,
wenn ihr nicht 100% sicher seid, dass ihr von keinem dieser Probleme betroffen seid...
Alter, was lächerlicher Kram wieder, ey.
...dann installiert euch einfach 24H2 erstmal nicht.
So, das waren auch schon unsere 12 Gründe, warum ihr das Windows 11 24H2-Update vielleicht noch nicht installieren solltet.
Warte lieber, bis Microsoft diese Probleme behoben hat...
Also die haben echt einen Arsch offenbar, Microsoft.
...und die Hersteller ihre Treiber dann im Griff haben.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, gebt mir gerne ein Like darauf.
Ja, kriegst ein Like, ich bin leider nicht eingeloggt.
Ich sag vielen Dank fürs Zusehen, tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ah, Mental Outdoor!
Ne, da haben wir uns heute schon einmal...
Rechenpower, wie auf meinem Schreibtisch.
Okay, teure Rechner gehen immer auf 14 Minuten.
Was für alle, die wie ich aussitzen möchten und eine Pro-Version haben...
...GP...
Okay, nice.
High IQ Chat.
Chat.
Ich hab jetzt meinen ganzen Tee gesoffen.
Ich muss pinkeln.
Nochmal.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Warte mal, ich mach nochmal kurz die Musik an.
Gleich wieder am Start.
So.
Komm, wir schauen uns doch das Video schnell an.
Fette, fette Workstation-Hardware kann man sich immer gut geben.
Das ist mit Abstand der ungewöhnlichste Rechner, an dem ich jemals gearbeitet habe.
Oder auf jeden Fall mindestens Top 5.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll.
Damit, dass da eine Nvidia CPU drin ist.
Was?
Inklusive Nvidia BIOS Einschaltbild.
Dass die Grafikeinheit 96 GB RAM hat.
Dass das Ding 480 GB Arbeitsspeicher hat.
Also insgesamt 576 GB schnellen Speicher.
Aber wahrscheinlich irgendeine komische Architektur ist, mit der man nichts machen kann, außer
AI-Kram laufen lassen.
Also klar, das ist Technik, die normalerweise in irgendwelchen Serverschränken in Rechenzentren
steht.
Ich hab sowas hier jetzt als Desktop-Rechner im formschön güldenen Gehäuse.
Kostet schlappe 32.000 Euro.
Wie ich da dran gekommen?
So viel mehr als ein voll ausgestatteter Mac Pro ist das auch nicht, oder?
Was man damit machen kann und vor allem, warum man damit auch vieles nicht machen kann, seht
ihr in diesem Video.
Bleibt dran.
Was kostet denn?
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Lass uns mal gucken, was kostet denn ein Mac Pro.
Mac Pro Tower kaufen.
Genau.
So.
Naja, das Video ging immer so bam.
Bam.
Na okay, nur die Hälfte davon kostet der, okay?
Immerhin.
An dem Moment, da geht ja noch mehr.
Na gut.
Aber Software brauchen wir ja nicht, wirklich, ne?
Diese Maus ist so grausam.
Okay, die Hälfte, die Hälfte davon, ja.
Wer KI lieber lokal auf dem Supercomputer betreiben will, hat womöglich Privacy-Bedenken
bei Cloud.
Jetzt kommt NordVPN oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ja, und wenn euch eure eigenen Daten am Herzen liegen, dann könnt ihr euch mal Incogni anschauen.
Ah.
Nicht nennen.
Korrekt adressierte Mail.
Die-.
.
Ah, ich habe ja als Supercomputer-Fachmann schon Erfahrungen mit dem Testen von teuren
Rechnern.
Neulich war ja ein 40.000-Euro-Rechner von Dell dran.
Ja, da habe ich Doom drauf installiert und das fand Dell so semi-lustig.
Also ich fand es auf jeden Fall lustig.
Hm.
Naja, jedenfalls hat mir daraufhin der Besitzer des kleinen Webshops gptshop.ai aus Unterfranken
geschrieben, ob ich nicht mal einen viel aufregenderen Rechner trinke.
gptshop.ai.
Was zum?
Aber schau mal, die richtige Top-Level-Domain, natürlich ja auch das Diamant-Logo für,
ich dachte es ist, ich dachte es ist, da klappt das Menü auf mit, Darkreader-kompatibel
ist das Ganze schon immer nett.
Geht ziemlich kaputt.
Ja.
Und jetzt steht er hier.
Und ob der wirklich aufregend ist, das versuche ich in diesem Video herauszufinden.
Ich meine immerhin, es scheint doch schon mal halbwegs entgradetes und entfranstes Material
zu sein.
Ich meine, dass der hier so außerhalb eines Server-Racks hier in meinem Büro steht.
Ja.
Also außerhalb eines Server-Racks hier in meinem Büro steht, ist schon sehr ungewöhnlich.
Ist das 19 Zoll?
Die Höhe?
Könnte man das auch quasi in einen Server-Rack reinfahren?
Das könnte ungefähr 19 Zoll sein, oder?
So, Pi mal Daumen.
Hier so außerhalb eines Server-Racks hier in meinem Büro steht, ist schon sehr ungewöhnlich.
Die Hardware ist nämlich nie für den Desktop-Betrieb vorgesehen gewesen, sondern gptshop.ai baut
die ja einigermaßen hemmsärmelig halt um.
Für.
Die – die schön Noctua-Verlängerung, und vielleicht auch Limitierungskabel, dass es
nicht so laut wird.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, genau.
Hier hinten schön die Dinger zusammen mit diesen, wie heißen die Dinger, Scotchlok,
genau, so Teile.
Steckt man zwei Kabel rein, drückt das dann zusammen.
Ist ja jetzt nicht das Geilste.
Ist aber schnell – so eine Vago-Klemme ist natürlich schon nicer, weil die halt auch
auch mehr Platz braucht. Sieht allerdings ein bisschen sehr gebastelt aus, aber wenn
es versteckt ist hinter der Wand, warum nicht?
Server-Hardware ist das und zwar spezifisch Hardware für GPU-Computing, also Rechner,
in denen vor allem Grafikkerne rechnen, aber nicht zwingend, um Grafiken zu berechnen,
sondern meistens ganz andere Sachen, zum Beispiel große Sprachmodelle wie GPT-4, also das, was
in ChatGPT drin steckt. Ja, konkret von solchen Dingern wird ChatGPT angetrieben.
So, und die Grafikeinheit, das ist...
Ja, aber vor ein bisschen mehr als einem wahrscheinlich.
Wenn man jetzt nur die Rechenkerne vergleicht, könnte man auf die Idee kommen, dass man
da sowas ähnliches wie eine RTX 4090 am Start hat. Hier mal so eine Tabelle. Ja, aber es
gibt auch riesige Unterschiede. Wir können zum Beispiel bei der H100 nicht mehr alle
Rechenwerke grafikberechnend, weil eben der Fokus auf Computing und KI liegt. Also ziemlich
riesig ist auch der Unterschied beim Speicher. Die H100 hat hier in dem Fall heftige 96 GB
Speicher.
Ja.
Die RTX 4090 nur 24 GB. Vor allem ist der Speicher aber...
Eine Karte ist doch nichts, oder?
Naja, Nvidia muss halt gucken, wo sie die Kohle herkriegen.
Oder bezahlst du für eine Karte anscheinend schon 4.000, 30.000 Euro?
Wenn's schnell. Das ist HBM3, also High Bandwidth Memory in der dritten Generation.
Ja, und der kann 3,34 TB pro Sekunde wegschaufeln. Eine 4090 schafft 1 TB pro Sekunde.
Aber ja trotzdem, diese H100 Grafikeinheit ist zumindest artverwandt.
Mit so normalen Consumer-Grafikkarten. Also grob kompatibel.
Der Rest des Rechners ist aber wirklich nochmal ganz anders als konventionelle x86-Rechner.
Und zwar kommt da als CPU eine 72-kernige Nvidia-Grace-CPU zum Einsatz mit ARM-Architektur.
Die wurde schon 2021 vorgestellt und seitdem hat Nvidia die nicht mehr verändert.
Ganz interessant am Rande. Konkret sind da ARM NeoVerse-V2-Kerne drin, die auch in Amazon
und Google Rechenzentren verwendet werden. Das ist ja auch ein sehr interessanter Punkt.
Bei Amazon heißen die Graviton und bei Google Axion.
Interessant ist auf jeden Fall, dass laut Amazon rund die Hälfte der Amazon-Rechenzentren
schon ARM-Architektur benutzt. Also wusste ich nicht, bevor ich dieses Video recherchiert habe.
Dachte, das wäre x86. Ja, aber das ist auch spezifisch Amazon.
Bei den anderen Anbietern ist der Anteil noch nicht so groß.
So, Einschub beendet. Zurück zu meinem Rechner hier.
War mir auch nicht klar. Was tatsächlich ungewöhnlich ist, ist die Kombination aus Nvidia-CPU und Nvidia-GPU.
Die dann auch noch mit einer extrem schnellen Schnittstelle verbunden sind, nämlich NVLink C2C.
Ja, da gehen 900 Gigabyte pro Sekunde durch.
Und diese Kombination aus Grace-CPU und Hopper H100-GPU.
Das heißt dann Grace-Hopper-Superchip GH200. Grace-Hopper.
Grace-Hopper ist übrigens ein Menschenname.
Ja, das ist die von der NASA, oder?
Ist das nicht die von der NASA?
Bilde ich mir ein?
Computerpionierin, die kam
Ende der 1940er Jahre
überhaupt erst auf die Idee, Computerprogramme
in einer einigermaßen verständlichen
Sprache zu schreiben, statt nur mit Nullen oder
Einsen. Von ihr kommt auch das von mir sehr geschätzte
Zitat, es ist einfacher, um
Vergebung zu bitten, als eine
Genehmigung zu bekommen. Das verstehen
vermutlich alle, die schon einmal in einer
größeren Organisation gearbeitet haben.
Ich schweife schon wieder ab, also
hier GH200 Serverrechner,
die in Unterfranken so
ziemlich Do-it-yourself-mäßig zu
Desktop-PCs umgebaut werden,
inklusive kurioser Hardware-Details,
zum Beispiel hier diese ganzen Lüfter-Potis
hier. Also, wenn man andere Leute
aus dem eigenen Büro verkraulen will,
einfach mal nach rechts drehen.
Aber man kann die Kiste auch erträglich
leise einstellen. Es gibt übrigens zwei
redundante Netzteile mit jeweils
2400 Watt. Maximal habe ich
eine Leistungsaufnahme von
832 Watt gemessen.
Bei ruhendem Ubuntu
Desktop waren es 225 Watt.
Es gibt nur einen nutzbaren
USB-Port, dafür
2 10 Gigabit.
Das sieht jetzt wirklich ein bisschen behelfsmäßig aus da.
Aber was kann man denn damit nun
machen? Ja, und jetzt wird es richtig interessant.
Erstmal ist das nämlich alles wirklich
unproblematisch. Man kann zum Beispiel einfach
einen Linux in armen Geschmacksrichtungen
darauf installieren, zum Beispiel Ubuntu Server,
wie wir hier. Und das funktioniert auch alles wie
auf normalen Desktop-PCs,
also in Spios, dann zum Beispiel von
USB-Datenträger booten, alles easy.
Aber wenn Ubuntu dann... Vielleicht ein bisschen
ähm...
Ist also in Spios. Minimalistisches
Spios. Dann zum Beispiel von USB-Datenträger
booten, alles easy. Aber wenn
Ubuntu dann läuft, dann wird es ein bisschen
komplizierter. Also klar, man kann halt
vieles ganz normal über die Paketquellen...
Würde ich gerne mal Endprock drauf machen, wie viele CPU-Kerne
der erkennt. Auch wenn es halt noch nicht
alle Software als ARM-Binarys gibt,
aber... Wobei...
Nicht so viele. Das meiste Standardzeug
funktioniert. Direkt zum Beispiel
so ein Wow-Moment hatte ich mit
Ubuntu.
Ulama, das ist eine Software, mit der man
große Sprachmodelle... Ist das von Facebook?
...einfach installieren und vor allem laufen
lassen kann. Ulama lässt sich auch einfach
ohne Verrenkungen auf dem GH200
installieren. Einfach den Anweisungen auf der
Website folgen, einen Befehl, zacki, zacki,
Ulama drauf. Chat-GPT,
beziehungsweise Anthropic Cloud
Qualität darf man mit allen aktuellen
OBSource-Modellen noch nicht ganz erwarten.
Aber die Dinger sind wirklich
inzwischen richtig brauchbar
geworden. Ja, also kleine Sprachmodelle
wie Lama 3.1
8b mit
8 Milliarden Parametern und einer
Dateigröße von 4,7 Gigabyte,
die passen auch in den Grafikspeicher
von so Consumer-Grafikkarten
und laufen da schön schnell.
Dafür braucht man keinen 32.000 Euro-Rechner.
Ich habe aber mal ein paar LLM-Benchmarks
mit kleinen LLMs mit
meinem eigenen Rechner gemacht und die
mit dem dicken hier verglichen.
Also mein eigener Rechner, da ist
eine RTX 4090 mit... Das ist ja auch nicht
schlecht. 24 Gigabyte Speicher drin.
Und tatsächlich ist der 8x so
teure GH200-Rechner bei den
meisten Lama-Sprachmodellen
nur so zwischen 30 und 60 Prozent
schneller als mein Rechner mit RTX
4090. Aber dafür müssen die
Modelle halt auch erstmal auf meiner 4090
laufen. Und das geht halt nur gut,
wenn die in die 24 Gigabyte
GPU-Speicher passen.
Der GH200 hat ja 96
Gigabyte GPU-Speicher. Das heißt, da
passen ganz andere Modelle rein. Zum Beispiel
hier der Nemotron 70B.
Das Ding ist 43
Gigabyte schwer in der 4-Bit-Quantisierung.
Das passt also easy in den Grafikspeicher
der GH200 und
ist da super schnell. Der läuft,
also läuft, aber auch
auf meinem Rechner mit RTX 4090
und zwar einfach, indem Teile
in meinen 32 Gigabyte
Arbeitsspeicher ausgelagert werden.
Das führt dann aber dazu, dass das Ding auf dem GH200
um den Faktor 20
schneller läuft. Also, riesen
Unterschied. Aber generell, der Nemotron
mit 70 Milliarden Parametern, der ist schon
ziemlich brauchbar. Also gerade bei Coding-Sachen,
aber der kann sich auch ganz gut,
meinen persönlichen LLM-Benchmarks,
diesen Martin-Luther-Witz, ganz gut
überlegen. Ja, und dann sind da auch noch die richtig
dicken Modelle. Also zum Beispiel Lama
3.1 405B, 229
Gigabyte schwer. Ja, und das
kann ich auf meinem 4090-Rechner natürlich
vergessen, weil der Speicher einfach nicht da ist.
Der GH200 hat zwar nicht
genügend GPU-RAM, aber eben
zusätzlich 480 Gigabyte
Arbeitsspeicher. Damit kann man das Riesenmodell
also nutzen, aber wegen des
...
Guck mal, wie viele CPU-Kerne.
Verdammt, Alter.
...verteilten Speichers nur mit 0,5
Tokens pro Sekunde. Also das ist extrem
langsam. Eigentlich zu langsam, um das wirklich
in der Praxis zu verwenden. Aber ganz klar,
wenn man ein lokales Sprachmodell laufen
lassen will, das in den 96
Gigabyte GPU-RAM des
GH200-Rechners passt und der
zu groß wäre für Consumer-GPUs,
das wäre die erste
sinnvolle Anwendung für diese
32.000-Euro-Kiste.
So, aber da muss ja eigentlich auch noch mehr gehen,
dachte ich mir. Es gibt ja etliche so
lokal... Wie sieht das aus mit lokalem Training?
Ich denke mal, dafür ist das Ding auch nicht schlecht.
...anlaufende KI-Anwendungen, also Bildgeneratoren
wie Stable Diffusion und
Flux oder Videogeneratoren wie
Open Sora oder Cock Video,
Transkriptions... Cock Video.
...Tools wie Whisper. Also da
kann man sich schon vorstellen... Warum heißt das so? ...dass Leute
und Firmen, die sowas sehr regelmäßig
nutzen wollen und sich da die Anschaffung
eines so teuren Rechners
lohnen würde. Also klar, weil die
meisten machen sowas natürlich in der Cloud,
aber gerade die Miete von Clouds,
Cloud-GPUs, ist sehr, sehr teuer.
So, und jetzt kommen wir hier in
gefährliches Territorium,
was meine Computerkenntnis
Credibility angeht. Wer den Channel
hier regelmäßig guckt, weiß, dass ich zwar
versuche, immer alles zu lernen, aber
definitiv kein Server,
Programmierungs, Linux,
Python Superexperte bin.
Also ich bin in der Lage, die erwähnten
KI-Tools auf unterschiedlichen Rechnern
zu installieren, aber das ist halt dann immer
x86-Basis und
die GH200-Kiste, die nutzt halt
ARM. Und da fangen... Läuft auf der Kiste
Doom? Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Zwar nicht sonderlich schnell, würde ich mal vermuten,
weil das garantiert nix von der Grafikkarte
nutzt und wahrscheinlich von den meisten
CPU-Sachen auch nicht. Also
kannst wahrscheinlich kein Doom mit, was weiß ich,
30, na doch, selbst
am Handy kannst du das wahrscheinlich mit 30.000
FPS laufen lassen. Das läuft dann
halt
rein Software-Rendering. Doom hatte, glaube ich,
eh nix anderes als Software-Rendering, oder?
Rein Software-Rendering auf einer CPU
auf einem CPU-Kern.
Also auch nicht schneller als so ein Raspberry Pi wahrscheinlich.
Probleme an. Da kann man zum Beispiel
nicht das von mir sehr geschätzte Installationstool
Pinocchio nutzen, aber halt
auch die auf den GitHub-Projektseiten
geteilten Installationsanleitungen
funktionieren meistens nicht.
Natürlich dachte ich zuerst, das liegt halt an
mir, weil auch auf x86-Maschinen
ist das oft mit
herumhantieren mit so virtuellen
Python-Umgebungen und so weiter verbunden und
nicht so trivial, aber halt mit
ARM wird es dann richtig fummelig.
Und klar, ich hab den Fehler erstmal bei mir gesucht,
aber wie... Ob ich wo eingeladen war?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das ist.
...dann herausstellte, funktionieren halt...
Ich weiß mit Ach und Krach, wer Knossi ist.
Einige Sachen einfach nicht. Zum Beispiel die
Machine Learning Library PyTorch,
die die Basis ist für etliche KI-Projekte,
die konnte ich nicht out of the box
mit der Nvidia CUDA-Plattform
verwenden, sondern das lief alles nur über
einen von Nvidia bereitgestellten Docker-Container,
was alles natürlich noch komplizierter war.
Ja. Ich hab's damit zumindest hinbekommen,
über CUDA zum Laufen zu bringen,
aber das war super lahm und
letztendlich nicht gebraucht.
Ich habe gehört,
dass angeblich, da müssen wir den Max fragen,
falls er noch da ist,
ich habe gehört, dass dieses
Transcriben des
Archivs, man kann ja
hier in meinem Archiv nach, keine Ahnung,
Modern Warfare 2 suchen,
und da sucht er im Transkript
dieses Transcriben
von dem, was ich sage im Stream,
Text, das passiert
meines Wissens nach auch über
Whisper AI. Aber die muss nicht
schnell sein, die kann halt ein bisschen ackern an den Videos.
Kurz vor Veröffentlichung
dieses Videos habe ich noch das
Bildgenerier-Modell Flux 1 Dev
mit ComfyUI zum Laufen gebracht
und das lief tatsächlich sehr schnell.
Ein Bild mit 1024x1024
Bildpunkten brauchte 4,7
Sekunden. Ich habe exakt die gleiche
Konfiguration auf zwei anderen...
Das wird einmal mit einer RTX 4090
da brauchte das ganze 12,8 Sekunden.
Mit einer RTX 3090
da waren es 28 Sekunden.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich nur ab und zu mal ein Bild generieren will
und das bei mir lokal,
dann sind 12 Sekunden auch vollkommen
in Ordnung. Wenn ich natürlich
jetzt irgendeinen Service anbiete und das verkaufen will
und dann sieht das schon wieder anders aus.
Aber das ist vollkommen
in Ordnung. Selbst 30 Sekunden
ist okay.
Andere KI-Software zum Beispiel
zum Video generieren, leider alles
ohne Erfolg, leider nur
Fehlermeldungen. Und ja, ich bin mir
sicher, dass jetzt ganz viele Leute aus dem Gebüsch
kommen und mir erzählen, wie man das alles
total einfach hinbekommen würde.
Das kann auch alles sein, aber ich traue mir
zu, jetzt zu sagen,
und das ist halt auch die Essenz dieses Videos,
glaubt nicht, dass ein vermeintlicher
Supercomputer mit den krassesten
Specs einfach alle eure Probleme
löst. Also mir ist natürlich klar,
dass die Zielgruppe für einen 32.000
Euro Rechner eh ziemlich
klein ist. Aber ich bin mir auch
ziemlich sicher, dass viele von euch, also
wie ich, schon oft gedacht haben, boah,
wenn ich diese Rechenzentrum-Hardware
hier am Start hätte, was man da alles
für coole Sachen mitmachen könnte. Ja, und
die Realität ist, kann man nicht.
Zumindest nicht, wenn man vorhandene Software
ohne eigene Anpassungen zum Laufen
bekommen will. Jetzt sagen wahrscheinlich einige,
wer so einen Rechner kauft, weiß
das alles. Das mag auch in vielen
Fällen so sein, aber es gibt bestimmt
inzwischen Anwendungsbereiche, wo
normale Leute, sprich Nicht-Coder,
überlegen, sich sowas
in die Firma zu stellen, um halt
lokal Dinge mit generativer
KI zu machen. Und zum Beispiel mit
über... Ich würde jetzt nochmal probieren, ob
ChatGPT die Heizung bei mir
im Keller ablesen kann. Ich habe das eben letztens
erklärt, was man da sieht.
Gucken, ob es das immer noch, ob es das jetzt checkt.
Geht das ja auch super, habe ich ja gezeigt hier im Video.
Aber alles andere unbedingt
vorher ausprobieren und euch vorm
Kaufen SSH Zugang geben lassen.
Übrigens, echte Workstations von
großen Herstellern haben nicht nur
Listen... Ach, by the way,
ich glaube, Chat sagt doch
was. Mein Mikro ist wieder falsch eingestellt.
Ihr hört mich, wenn ich Luft hole und sowas.
Das sollte eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Oder auch nicht. Aber ihr hört mich ein bisschen mehr.
Das liegt daran, dass...
Oh Mann. Wo stellt man denn hier
schon wieder das Mikrofon-Zeug ein?
Ich hasse dieses neue Menü. Mann, du findest
nix. 80.
Ich muss auf 80.
Auf 80 muss es, ja.
Jetzt hört ihr mich nicht schnaufen und ihr hört mich nicht
atmen so zwischendurch.
So, gut.
...wer die da drauf garantiert läuft,
sondern oft auch Optimierungsanleitungen
für bestimmte Programme.
Okay, mache ich jetzt gerade Kaufberatung
für zehntausende Euro teure
Workstations?
Finde ich selbst ziemlich lustig.
Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht haben ja auch
die 99% von euch
ein bisschen was gelernt, die sowas zwar nie
kaufen würden, aber immer schon mal gedacht
haben, was wäre, wenn man sowas hätte.
Also ich zumindest habe sehr viel
gelernt. Ja, wie ist das bei euch?
Wie seht ihr das? Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben
und abonnieren natürlich. Tschüss!
So Chat, wir
probieren erstmal was aus.
Das ist
ein Bild von der Webcam
meiner Heizung.
Wasserdruck.
Und das habe ich letztens versucht
von ChatGPT verarbeiten zu lassen.
Und das hat nur
sehr semi
gut funktioniert.
Lasst uns das mal ausprobieren.
ChatGPT
Ja, Chat geht nicht.
Man muss sich einloggen.
Sehe ich da links
einen CRT? Wo?
Da?
Ne. Und da?
Ne, du siehst einfach die Heizung
von vorne in groß.
Sonst nix.
Walve.
So, ähm.
Die graue Fläche, das hier. Ne, das ist
tatsächlich, das ist kein CRT.
Das ist ein Display von der
Heizung. Aber das ist definitiv kein
CRT-Display.
Irgendein low-cost, billig
LCD-Display.
So, hochladen geht nicht, oder?
Da muss man sign-uppen.
Okay, 10-Minute-Mail.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ChatGPT 10-Minute-Mail frisst.
Ich hoffe mal. Sonst haben wir
jetzt gelitten. Äh, wie ging das
jetzt hier? Sign-up. Brauch ne
Telefonnummer? Oh shit.
Okay, der hat ge...
Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz was aufschreiben.
So, perfekt. Bestes, bestes
Passwort überhaupt da. Und jetzt?
Ja, okay. Verify.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funzt da.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funzt.
Und wenn ich ne Telefonnummer brauche, dann
hab ich eh... Ich kann mich
einloggen mit meinem normalen Account, aber will ich
eigentlich nicht. Wer weiß,
was ihr dann für geheime
ChatGPT-Anfragen seht.
QWEN 2.5.
Wo kann man das ausprobieren? Kann man das online irgendwie
ausprobieren? Ey, ChatGPT, verify your email.
Kekke.
01 01
1990. Jetzt brauche ich bestimmt die
Telefonnummer. Okay.
Peter Ager.
12.
2.
1987.
Das stimmt zwar nicht, aber...
Dr. Peter
Müller.
Okay. Ich glaube, die checken,
dass das ne Wegwehrfemale-Adresse ist.
Okay.
Kann man Claude... Claude E.
kann man die...
Kann die Bilder erkennen?
Hab ich noch nie... Ah,
da bin ich jetzt nicht eingeloggt mit nem Google-Account.
Bin ich vielleicht in der
VM mit nem Google-Account eingeloggt?
Ah, dann nicht.
So, Chat. 12.20 Uhr.
Leute, ich putter jetzt paar Nudel.
Über die China-Chinesen-Website. Ah, nee,
dann nicht. Jetzt paar Nudel futtern,
Leute. Wir hören uns
im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.